will be used to react to triggered
abilities or spells. Reactions are super
fast and can lead to lots of exciting
interactions as they resolve before all
other spells. For example, if you have a
stupify in your hand and your opponent
activates a spell that really bothers
you, you can use stupify as a reaction
and draw a card before your opponent's
spell is resolved. This might allow you
to draw another reaction that saves you
from the situation, like a defy. Another
exciting example is dealing damage to a
unit with a spell before combat. If you
go into combat with a unit that's
already damaged, you should make sure
you win the fight. Otherwise, the units
will heal after the combat. Let's say
you have dealt six damage to your
opponent's mind spplitter with falling
star and you go into combat against it
with your watchful sentry. Your opponent
might want to activate an action in
response such as grim resolve to
generate extra might and win the combat.
You can still respond to that with a
stupify. You reduce the mind spplitter's
smite to six and because it still has
six damage counters on it, it will die
before the grim resolve can save it.
Which one is your favorite reaction card
in Riftbound? Let us know.
>> We are here at the Riftbound regional
qualifiers in Sydney. I'm here with Matt
and Nick. How are you feeling about the
weekend so far?
>> Oh, amazing.
>> Are you actually Uh, I honestly I lost a
little bit of hope today playing a bit
of Leblanc, but then I think going into
a couple of side events playing Vex, I
feel a lot more confident. So, I think
tomorrow we'll be running probably the
Vex going into it.
>> Interesting. And what about you? Who are
you running?
>> I'm running Ahri.
>> Interesting. Have you got much
experience playing Ahri?
>> Yes.
>> He is a He is a very He loves Ahri
always. Back home, it's nothing but
Ahri, so I can vouch for him. He's very
good. So all the other AR players out
there, watch out. We might have our best
of for the weekend.
>> Interesting. Those are those are
confident words. Are you feeling as
confident as he's making you out to be?
>> Yeah. Well, I named my deck the best of
already. So, if I don't get best of, my
deck list would be inaccurate. So,
>> we shall see. We'll see how it f unfolds
in the next couple of days. And uh good
luck.
We are here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifiers in Sydney. I am joined by
Courtney. How is your weekend looking
ahead?
>> Very busy, but I'm super excited. I'm
actually hosting trivia on all three
days of the week and I've got a bunch of
packs and prizes to give out and I'm
very excited to see the community and
hope they can answer all of my really
tricky questions. Oo, how how tricky are
we talking? Like like 10 out of 10
tricky. 10 out of 10. All right, picture
this. I've zoomed in on a picture of
Kha'Zix who is a bug. Could you tell me
that it is Kha'Zix?
>> I feel like I I could probably do it. I
feel reasonably confident.
>> I I don't believe you. I'll see you at
trivia. Okay,
>> I will try. I will I will be there and I
will do my best.
>> We are here down at the Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers in Sydney. I am
joined by Morgan. How is your weekend
looking so far?
>> Wonderful so far. Um, I'm amazed by the
turnout and we just found out that
there's 1,600 plus players for main
event tomorrow.
>> Are you competing? Are you excited?
>> I am indeed. I'm going for best of Vex,
but we'll see how we go.
>> And you're feeling confident.
>> As confident as I can be.
>> Well, that's something. I And have you
have you been practicing? Have you been
running it a lot in the leadup?
>> Uh, a lot of online practice, but then
flipping and flopping on my list the
last couple of days practicing with
these two.
>> I feel like you're not alone with that.
a lot of people kind of analyzing, oh,
what should I be running? What should I
do? Especially because of the release of
Unleashed so recently.
>> So many variables around
>> and have you changed things because of
any unleash cards?
>> Uh, a couple of changes, but funnily
enough, most of the changes are pulling
in Origins cards.
>> Interesting. So, we'll see how that goes
for you over the coming days. Fingers
crossed and good luck.
>> Thank you so much. Yeah.
Welcome back to regional qualifier
Sydney. It's so fantastic to hear what
our attendees are thinking and how
they're feeling about the day so far and
we had a bit of insight into everything
Logan.
>> Oh, we have so much insight to all of
the things here I see that we can talk
about it all day long but unleash so far
is proving to be very very dynamic, very
very meta shifting. LeBlanc is the
literal number one most represented deck
here at the regional qualifiers in
Sydney. We had a little bit of insight
earlier with Bolan, one of the EDG
players that has flown over from China
to compete here in Sydney about how the
meta in China does have quite a lot of
uh Masi and Ireelia as well. And we can
see that also reflected in the top
three. Of course, Leblanc leads the
pack. And then we have Masi being the
second most represented and Ireelia the
third. I have to see that graphic again
to double check, but I think that's
correct from memory. We have great
representation as per the graphic, the
timing here. LeBlanc the number one here
with a 7% share, but I want to point out
how healthy this meta is. There's no one
overwhelming favorite here, Ricey.
They're all in with a chance.
>> Yeah, we can see like even Beex with 50
is only like 30 difference between um
Leblanc and Beex. And even Fiora has 36
3%. 7% feels like when we bursting out
in the the field it might be like oh
there's so many levels but in when it
comes down to it that's only 7%. Yeah,
absolutely. That MF being Aurora as well
doubtlessly. So all that sort of
discussion around how oppressive it
could be only 44 being registered here.
I don't think that that many players are
actually going to come across Auroras.
>> We do have to wonder how many masteries
are running Aurora or mid
mid midyear um as well. But I totally
agree like the after all the discussion
there actually isn't that many Aurora.
>> Yeah. Yeah, no, definitely a lot less
than expected here as we do also see
Aurelia still being strong even with the
unleash meta, but Diana, another unleash
superstar, as is Vex. So, I'm really
loving the adaptability we're seeing
from the players here. They're willing
to forego previous legends to give it a
shot on these new ones.
>> As you mentioned, yeah, some of these
legends are brand new. Let's look at the
most used gear. You look really excited
about this, Logan. Let's break it down.
>> I love gear. Za's hourglass and guardian
angel. I would imagine Aurelia is
responsible for a lot of that, but also
Yei.
>> Yeah, Master Yi as well. And I I think
there's a few other players that we've
seen of running these zas. Green love
the zas. Guardian angel as well. It has
a pretty similar
ability as well where if you they will
die, you can kill the guardian angel and
keep this unit alive. Especially as well
with that Ireelia Sprite fountain. I'm
I'm not surprised as well either. I
think it's in quite a few uh mind decks.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And we do take a look
at the other ones. Last rights in Chaos,
Dazzling Aurora in Body, Boots of
Swiftness, also Chaos often times
coupled with those Aurelia decks. BF
sword in the order domain. Heart of Dark
Ice though also calm followed up by
Brutalizer and Trinity Force in that
body. So, a decent representation there,
but uh unfortunate to see no fury domain
represented in the top end of the gear.
>> I mean, I think Fury love going for
their spells, so I'm not too surprised
about that. But there are so many Fury
domain legends being played at the
moment, so that is also a little bit
surprising. But of course, most played
spells. This is where we're starting to
see some of that. Oh, so you said fury,
not chaos, so my bad. This is where
we're starting to see some of those
chaos uh spells come out. But you're
right. There's not many um there weren't
many fewer gears.
>> Yeah, absolutely. As we see here with
these most played spells, we were
talking about this a little bit earlier,
right? There's so much calm. There's so
much chaos. And when you think about it,
those two just don't go together in the
real world, but here in Roofbound,
they're a match made in heaven.
>> I kind of am really excited for uh the
next set coming out of Vendetta. I
probably don't want we don't know much
about it, but it's that opposites coming
through there. Right now, of course, we
do have these opposites, but not in the
same legend, just in the same
tournament.
>> One that I do really want to point out,
which is a superstar, and I think we all
called this one coming, was Starross,
the new uh, you know, it's almost a
cheap man's rebuke. It's three energy,
one power instead of the two and two.
And it's by like it's double facing,
right? You can bounce yours, you can
bounce your oppositions, and it just has
that sort of flexibility built into it.
And Hidden Blade though is the superstar
of that order domain, just able to take
out nearly every single unit in
Riftbound.
>> Yeah, it's such a strong card to be able
to do that. I mean, it's also great to
see people actually use it against
themselves, too. When you think about
Victor decks or other decks that have
that capability to kind of sacrifice one
of the units.
>> Yeah, Leblanc loves that one as well.
You can actually hidden blade the
Leblanc uh fragmented and get even more
card draw out of her. So you really do
love to see it. But let's take a look at
the most played units. Rice here.
>> Thousand tailed Watcher from Origins is
still the most used. And there is no
surprise there. It is such a versatile
card, but also it's a good closer. And I
think mind, which is one of the most
common domains I think so far in this
tournament, is going to love this card.
>> It is the most powerful mind closer that
there is at this time. So, it makes
sense that everyone running the mind
domain will run that thousand tail
watcher to close these games out.
However, a superstar riser from
unleashed is that Vex Apathetic.
Everyone's been talking about it.
>> Everyone has been talking about it. I
feel like I've been dreaming about it.
Nightmare in my opinion. With Vex
Apathetic being such a strong card, you
once that Vex is on a battlefield, it's
so hard to start playing. You can't use
any ambush. You can't use any reaction
speed thing um or put any like what
accelerates any units either. It
completely nullifies those sorts of
abilities. Very strong. And then there's
also scuttle crab.
>> Yeah, scuttle crab has definitely made
an appearance. We did actually get to
see one in an earlier game where the
scuttle crab died and gave over full
information to the opponent because that
is part of its death now. But Axan
mischievous. I have to imagine that
sideboard tech into Aurora's tide
turner. A fantastic chaos card to turn
the tide of those fights there. Rcy
>> disarming rag the same as action, you
know, trying to get rid of all the AOA
or any other gear that they just want to
get rid of from their opponents. Vmore
is one of the new cards from Unleashed
and that's actually quite strong as
well.
>> Very, very oppressive. As it reads, you
cannot deal combat damage if you are a
unit with less might than Vilemore. So
prevents a lot of those showdowns,
combat damage wins. Lonely Porro also
featured fantastic two drop to get you a
little extra card draw and uh just pairs
off nicely into those Aurelas, those Ye,
those mid-range Ye especially.
>> Yeah, it's I love Lonely Power. This is
a little me personally. I just love how
cute and adorable he is and I just want
to give him a big hug. But in Rift
Mound, he is actually quite impressive.
But as you said, he's got a that drop,
that card drop when he um does die,
which unfortunately he might die cuz
he's such a small teammate unit.
>> Yeah. No, of course. But he is designed
for that, right? We see the lonely porro
and the other two drops going down. We
also love the overnumbered, but I think
I spy Dewi, the regional qualifier
winner from Houston, the very very first
regional qualifier. I see. This is going
to be a special match.
>> Very, very exciting. We are I believe
we've this is our fifth round, right? So
we're watching people who are 4 Z. So
these are some really experienced
players coming in. We are going through
eight rounds today and so we are sort of
nearly halfway. Oh, past halfway.
>> Yeah, it's a good round. We we've seen
the first half. We're into the back half
now into that second half here. But both
of these players currently undefeated
which you love to see. Diwali a veteran
within the riffbound scene having taken
that regional qualifier on the Annie.
But here are the deck list and Dwali is
on Diana. So many of the pros have made
that switch over to Diana. She's in some
of the most powerful domains with that
mind and that chaos. And as we were
talking about that thousand tail watcher
very heavily represented
>> of course also starcross. We've talked
about that as well is also here. Last
one of the most common spells is in this
deck too. Sprite fountain as well. We
can see uh some of these uh decks are
using these really powerful cards. We
also see pondering polar which I believe
was on the bottom of our list for units
as well being used three in fact. But we
can't not talk about of course the
important cards that Diana likes to use
like Moonfall.
>> Yeah, Moonfall being her new signature
spell. Very very powerful. You can win
combat out of nowhere with that. you're
able to drag an enemy unit onto your
location and then minus the might of
every enemy unit at that location. So,
it's very much like her ultimate in
League of Legends. It just drags
everyone in and annihilates them. But we
shout out those battlefields. Abandoned
Hall
>> of course
>> seeing it one more time here. Ricey, we
know what it can do. And I expect the
Wally to put that to fantastic use here
as both of these players, they seem to
be in good spirits. They've got some
good energy there as they are vibing
before they get into this game. And
surely in their minds, they know that
they're as good as each other right now
because yesterday's results, they don't
matter. It's what you do here and now.
>> That is so true. These players, they're
both 4-0 currently. And of course,
abandoned hole. We've seen this once.
We've seen this twice. We've seen this
probably many more times today as well.
Now L is going to be playing Leona. I'm
very excited about this. We haven't seen
a Leona yet today.
>> If you may, uh, let me geek out about
this one. Right. So, I love Leona so so
much. Shout out Goo as well. Goo is a
Leona one trick. And so many people that
play Leona just love her, right? They
don't care about the meta. They just
love her style and her legends and her
champions. But we do take a quick look
at the deck here. A couple of Zenith
Blades, but that new buy with that stun
as well has shown up.
>> That's so true. That new buy with a
stun. very very strong card being able
to stun um a unit when they attack and
of course with that ambush comp ambush
combination is going to be quite
powerful. I also love the addition of a
back off as well into Lyanna. I think
there were quite a lot of stun cards
that came out with unleashed and of
course Lyanna loves stuns.
>> She also did get some support in spirit
forge but never kind of really rose to
the top here. It's right now with that
Nami as well that really really assists.
Gets some card draw with that Stellicorn
Herder. We do have sunken temple,
monastery of harana, and arena's
greatest as those battlefields, too. So,
if we do see that arena's greatest, we
know that they want to win hard, fast,
and early here, Ricey. But they're not
without removal. A call the week in
their main board.
>> That's pretty exciting. I'm very curious
to see how it's going to work against
this Diana, of course, cuz uh I mean, if
you're able to get rid of those
important units, it's going to be really
good.
>> Yeah, absolutely. We see Diwali is going
to be on Diana and there was no Baron in
that deck list. So everything will be
able to be targeted by any removal that
L wants to present on this Leona. Cole
the weak being such an important part of
that removal hopefully being able to hit
that thousand tail watcher finisher that
Diwali would be looking to play down.
But again both of these players they
currently find themselves at 40.
They are undefeated, which is part of
the reason they're up here on these
featured tables, to show off the best of
the best of what these decks can do,
what these decks can offer.
>> I'm very excited about Lyanna. Lyanna
was one of the uh decks that I was
considering playing back when I first
started in Origins, and I decided, no,
I'm going to go for Master instead. And
now I'm just like, I kind of want to go
back to her. and she seems so fun to
play with all the stunts going on as
well. And it's going to be really
exciting to see how L is going to be
playing Leona.
>> Yeah, I definitely think it's a very
passionate community, a passionate
crowd. The reason I love Leona so much
is actually she's one of my mains in
League of Legends as well. I'm a support
main. Shout out supports there. And uh I
argue with my co-caster that the Zenith
Blade is a hook. Others will doubt me
for that one, but you know, she's a hook
champ and Zenith Blade proves it to me.
So, I'm personally invested. But I'm
personally passionate to see this Leona
one here. And without a doubt, she
actually has one of the most beautiful
overnumbered cards in Ripbound in my
opinion. Just that contrast with that
gold and the black and chef's kiss to
the artist for that one. But enough
about the art of the cards. We are
getting ready to jump into this game one
between Diana Scorn of the Moon and that
Leona Radiant Dawn. And shout out to the
law here as well, the lovers duo. The
starcross lovers duo who never meant to
be.
>> And of course, we do have that starcross
spell card in the deck of Diana as well.
And that you look at there's a card of
the art of the card on Starcross. You
can see it's got the Leona symbol and
Diana symbol. It really is just meant to
be.
>> Yeah. Fun fact, Diana Lunari speaks to
her moon worship, the Lunari, and then
Leona Solari. their son, their worship,
both of their sort of religions within
League of Legends. So, it's such a
dynamic pairing. It's such a terrific
duo. Whoever put these two up on the
table must know their League of Legends
law. For sure. For sure. It's one of the
most really interesting stories and uh
pairings. I think uh it's one of my
favorite. I can't wait to see more and
hear more about it because here Diana
and Leona are just kind of just a nice
sweet pair. But in this one, they're not
going to be that sweet here.
>> No, they will not. No, they will not.
But I do love to see Diwali has adopted
some local culture here, wearing the
Grimace bucket hat, doubtlessly from a
Sojun to one of the fast food outlets
here in Australia, mate. Look at that.
Repping the local culture. You do love
to see it. As we're just making sure
these headsets are working, smiles all
around. We are absolutely set for a
wonderful game. I'm looking for Zenith
Blade. Zenith Blade is such a powerful
signature spell and I'm looking for L to
be able to use this effectively to shut
down the Thousand Tale Watcher plays
that Diwali is most likely looking to
play, but she's going to have to move in
to a deck that has counters.
>> Exactly. Yeah, because uh there's so
many spells that Diana loves doing if
you you and well, Lyanna is in fact a uh
a green so a calm deck that will
definitely have a lot of counters like
defy and I don't remember if I saw any
not so fast in their main deck.
>> No, we haven't actually seen any not so
fast presented in El's main deck. I
can't imagine that she'll be looking to
sideboard any of those in into Diwali.
There will be no Elder Dragons to ping
with their abilities. So, we've got to
be happy with that. That Zenith Blade,
obviously, that signature spell of
Leona's at action speed stuns an enemy
unit at a battlefield and then you may
move a friendly unit to that enemy
unit's battlefield. So, you basically
stun over there and then move over
there. So, it almost assures your
victory.
>> It really definitely feels like what
Zenith Blade does in the game of League
of Legends as well. You stun them and
you go towards them. And so I'm really
excited to see, as you said, how this
Dennis Blade is going to get played out
here in this matchup. There are only two
Zenus Blades in the main deck of L. So
hopefully we draw into it and show it
off.
>> Yeah, I think two is consistent enough
to make sure that you're going to hit at
least one of those in that game. But I
do want to point out three Namis
actually. So Nami is one of those brand
new unleashed champions that have come
out. And Nami reads, "You may pay one
recycled calm rune as an additional cost
to play me. When you play me, if you
paid the additional cost, stun an enemy
unit." And when I hold the next time you
play a unit this turn, ready it and buff
it. But it's that stun that plays so
nicely around Leona's legend ability.
Ricey, as we have started game one of
round five's best of three series here
between Diwali on Diana and L on Leona.
Dual is going to choose star tipped peak
for the battlefield. L is going to be
running Monastery of Hana. Of course,
I'm actually curious to see if uh Diana
is going to be running the um abandoned
hole within the second round here in
this one though. Going for the star
tipped peak. Not sure who's going first
just yet. Not sure if they've done the
chosen and done the dice roll. So, we'll
find out in a little bit. But this is
going to be a really exciting match up
between these two as we mentioned
multiple times. I'm also really excited
to see Leona because she's actually got
a bit more representation I think in
this regional qualifiers now with all
these extra uh cards of stuns.
>> Yeah, with the support that she's got
through Spirit Forge and from Unleash,
she's definitely climbing on that
representation here. And so with L
choosing that monastery of Hana when you
conquer here you may spend a buff to
draw one that also really synergizes
quite nicely with that Nami when you pay
that extra cost. And we do see them
working out who's going first here. But
um El just looked at it straight down
the camera. I swear no she's like oh
look at them down there having a chat
about my deck. But the monastery Hana,
as we said, when you conquer here, you
may spend a buff to draw one. And Nami
is a very strong enabler of that buffing
like we pointed out, which is why they
run that three set, right? To really
make sure that when she holds, the next
time you play a unit, it gets buffed.
>> Yeah, exactly. And so, of course, L
wants to try and get that holding with
Nami and get as many buff units as
possible and then use those buffs and uh
draw more cards. Yeah, card advantage is
key to winning these games here, Icy, as
we do see them shuffle up. They've got
their battlefields presented and it
looks like they're going to take a look
at their four. Ooh, we see a Leona in
there. I think we saw one of the porros
on L's side of that table. Very, very
keen. I think that was a cull the week
as well. So, already has one of the
stronger removal pieces in her hand.
>> Also drew into a zenith blade as well.
So, we do have that in the hand. So, I'm
very excited to see how it's going to
go. But firstly, of course, L's going to
go first. Does draw also a back off,
too. But lonely, sorry, not a lonely
puro. The other puro is going to be
stalwart puro is going to be the first
one played.
>> We do love to see a good stalwart porro.
Definitely not seen all too often. Uh we
did see it in the Ari and we are seeing
it here again in that Leona because it
is definitely more of a defensive unit
this one. And uh yeah, we see Diwali on
that Diana Lunari champion, that three
cost, happy to go second because you're
able to play that one straight out here
and it is a stronger response. It's
going to allow for that card filtering
and uh that synergy with the legend cuz
the Diana Spawn of the Moon in the
showdown, you can actually tap and get
that one energy.
>> L's going to be contesting and
conquering potentially star tipped peak
here where you hold one. Sorry. When you
hold, you get to channel one rune, which
is of course very very important for
Diana and of course Lyanna would love
that too. So that is the battlefield
that they are going for.
>> Yeah, I think that speaks to the game
plan here. You obviously want to hold so
that you can get more runes and ramp and
play harder and faster. Diwali did play
that stack deck searching for the
answers he needs into this Leona deck.
Now I will be surprised if he has a lot
of practice into Leona. So I would have
to imagine that there is some
opportunity for L to surprise Dwali, but
he did win that RQ in Houston on that
Annie for a reason. So I don't think
he's going to be caught too unawares. I
think he will be able to play around it.
That said, not many of us have seen much
Leona. So yeah,
>> I'm looking forward to seeing that. And
as you said that Zenith blade that back
off that stun that support piece that
came through from unleashed very
critical.
>> Dwali is going to go in with that Diana
onto Monastery of Herana. L is happy to
let that through. Does have four runes
up but is not going to be using them for
this conquest. So Dwali does go now onto
one point.
>> Yeah. So he moved onto that battlefield.
Started the showdown which triggered the
Diana Lunari and he used the Diana Scorn
of the Moon for that energy. So he had a
look, he predicted put that to the
bottom of his deck and then he drew uh
sorry revealed the card. It wasn't a
spell, so put it back on top and then he
conquered that monastery of Herana. So
he's just looking to deny L that buffing
that she probably wants to get rolling
with her deck sooner rather than later.
And it's followed up with a
>> hay is in the base of Diwali. Now it's
L's turn is going to be bringing back
Lonely Parro and is considering what to
do here. We do see that of course Leon
as you mentioned earlier. Is that the
card that's going to be played? It will
be.
>> That is Aurelia Fervent.
>> My bad. I was like, hang on. I was like,
that's not right.
>> Yeah, that Plundering Porro was brought
back to base and Aurelia Fervent has
been played onto the base of L here.
Dwali just going, "Yep, that's an
Aurelia Fervent has the deflect when you
choose." Oh, Ready. M's going to get
that plus one might. And Dwalli, he's
ready. He's got his six runes and he's
looking to start his turn here. Rasi,
>> it's going to be exciting to see what
Hui is going to be doing here because
Hay in the hands of Diana is quite
scary. We uh and he's such a versatile
card with that three options when he
discards and draws the cards.
>> Yeah, when a move draw one then discard
one and based on what he discards, he
actually gets that option. Spell for
draw, gear for two runes, unit for three
might. So, he's very flexible as you
say. He could be a beat stick. He could
get you that card advantage or he could
ready those runes very similar to Annie
and enable more actions than your
opponent would be expecting. But right
now these two have to be thinking about
their next moves. Both players at two
conquer points here as well.
>> Dwali does do they move into star tipped
peak here? Not actually using those
runes just yet. Still considering still
thinking. We don't quite see his cards.
So we can't see his inner thoughts just
yet.
I'd be worried if we could see his inner
thoughts.
>> Okay, that's that's a good point.
>> I'd like to know general thoughts if we
if we could get a look at his hand. But
the beauty of not being able to see his
hand is we get to practice and and play
around with those cards.
>> Qu goes in onto star tipped peak is
going to now uh draw the draw the card
and discard one and do one of the
following spell. If it's a spell, get to
draw one. If it's a gear, ready up two
runes. If it's a unit, give them three
might.
>> That's it. That's it. So he has moved
and we do see the two runes exhausted.
Dino Lunari has also just been sitting
here on that monastery of Herana as
they're just discussing I think the
sequencing there just trying to make
sure we've done it all right but like
you said we can't see the cards in
Dwali's hand and that leaves us to
theorize that leaves us to imagine what
could possibly be there. Now we know it
isn't in mind and chaos and we know that
he has thousand tail watches Gus
stupifies so I have to imagine that he's
got some control elements but I'm also
expecting a surprise he does have
Kha'Zix's mutating horror
>> true that could be quite surprising
indeed that is a I mean an ambush
uh unit so that does mean that is
definitely a surprise to be had but I
mean ambush units they don't do
necessarily too well into stun. L does
have a lot of stuns with Leona.
>> Yeah, it doesn't have that Vex apathetic
though, so you will still be able to
play it out. You will still be able to
get the benefit for assaulting that
unit. Ka'Zix mutating horror is a ambush
and when I attack or defend if an enemy
unit is alone here, give me two might
this turn and gain two XP. So definitely
not looking for the XP gain here. I
didn't see too many XP related cards,
that new mechanic coming through for
unleashed, but he's definitely valuing
that surprise six might unit in that
Kha'Zix mutating horror here. I see.
>> Yeah, Kha'Zix is one of those units that
takes me by surprise a lot. And so I'm
curious to see whether or not that's
something that he is considering. But
I'm This so far has been really
interesting. I love the fact that Leonai
did bring back that um Dwell Poro to
protect and maybe go in for the next
round.
>> Yeah, definitely. There's something to
be said for hold decks and something to
be said for conquer and knowing when to
do which. Obviously protecting that
plundering porro means that next time
around l will have even more units more
might present to be able to go back into
a battlefield that they want to conquer.
Right. Obviously Dwali still in that
building phase has that has that Diana
Lari but with the Hay on board that's
eight might that could easily come out
of nowhere and take these battlefields.
>> Yeah exactly. There could be quite a lot
of might on Quay indeed with that plus
three if he discards that uh unit. So
when he moves onto the battlefield,
we'll find out exactly what he decides
to discard, but of course he has to draw
first and do the entire sequence.
>> Yeah. No, exactly. We're we're waiting
with baited breath to see what worked
out. We're like, ooh. Ah, you know. Uh
but we are getting back to it here.
Dwali versus L. This is still the game
one of the best of three match for round
five here on our featured tables.
>> So he does move up. I don't believe
we've had the discard happen just yet.
So
>> yeah, the trash does still only have
that stack deck.
>> Exactly. Yep. So we'll just wait a
little bit as Yeah, L is discussing how
things have worked out.
Yeah, I think L is pointing out that you
haven't discarded anything yet
>> because he played the stack deck
earlier. He's moved. There still hasn't
been a discard for the Hay move.
>> So, I think they're working out that
actually you do need to discard.
>> Sorry, that's what I meant was
>> conversation.
>> We can hear them.
>> I'm eaves dropping.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's like ah player comes.
>> Yeah. No. Yeah. You haven't discarded
that one, mate. And there it is. The
sprite fountain discarded the gear.
>> It is the gear which does mean he gets
to ready up two runes. So those two
runes have now been readied. Pretty
exciting to see Quay in action. And
Diana is going to be falling back into
base into safety. But Vex Vex is now on
the board.
>> Yeah, that Vex apathetic very very
oppressive almost a mandatory pickup
here in these chaos domain decks. But
interestingly, he readied those two
runes and then has only exhausted two
more runes now to pay for it because he
floated them from earlier.
>> Exactly. That was I think that might
have been what the discussion was about
because he did exhaust those two runes
before he did the qu thing and then
ready them up with the gear. And so
that's exactly what happened. It's very
interesting tech that Dwali has used and
I actually really like how he's done
that. Uh cuz it really shows the
versatility of Quay and of course the
skills that Dwali has.
>> Yeah. The forethought that goes into it,
right? To get the most use out of these
runes because your runes are only
cleaned up twice per turn. And so he
knows that if he floats them now, does a
couple of other things, they'll still be
floating for when he comes back to what
he actually wants to do.
>> Yes, indeed. Now it's L's turn. Dwi is
sitting on three points, but L is going
in for the conquer. Getting themselves
to three as well. Going in with that
porro.
>> Yeah, that plundering porro has done
some work. It is that sorry, the
stalwart porro. The plundering is the
mind porro. How dare I? But that
monastery of harana and here comes the
heart of dark ice. Diwali having a look
at that one. I believe you exhaust and
give a unit three might this turn. There
it is. quite a strong gear. I mean it
does cost three energy and one power but
now that Ireelia is very strong and of
course the combination start happening.
>> Yeah. So Aurelia obviously being ready
gave her that plus one might and then
gave three from the heart of darkness
and choosing Aurelia to get that three
gave that additional that total of plus
five might. So that is a nine might
Aurelia right now.
>> I'm wondering whether Ella's considering
the Zenith play but I I do see that back
off as well. So, we'll have to see what
they end up playing because right now
looking at our showdown graphic, they're
both at nine might.
>> Yeah, nine might a piece here. El does
have five runes up. Diwali has four
runes up and that free energy from that
Diana Scorn of the Moon Legend there.
So, probably just calculating what
options, what opportunities L can do
here. Has kicked off that showdown after
moving in, but there is some discussion
occurring. So, it will be interesting to
see how this one plays out. Looks like
it's a question for the judges there
though.
>> It is. The judges are going to of course
come and figure out how they can help.
Of course, they are amazing, wonderful
people, human beings to help us out and
make sure the games are going quite well
for each other as yeah, Leona with her
zenith blade in hand uh the back off.
She has quite a few options at her
disposal.
>> Yeah, a lot of stun, which funnily
enough is exactly what Leona wants to
do. I mean, it's like you drew exactly
what you wanted to be able to synergize
with your legend and stun your way to
victory. That nine mightelia fervent is
sitting on that battlefield into Diwali
with his nine might too. So, we'll see
what kind of responses they have here to
uh answer the showdown.
>> Yeah, I'm very excited to see what those
answers are because the stuns I really
want to see how they work together. I
mean, there is that vex on the board
right now and so of course you want to
get rid of that vex. That vex is a
little bit annoying, a little bit
tricky.
>> Yeah, obviously as we've said before,
we'll say it a million times, that Vex
apathetic has risen in the meta very,
very quickly. It is one of the most
represented chaos cards here at the
Riftbound regional qualifiers in Sydney.
And Dwali, you know, he's an expert.
He's won that RQ. He will definitely be
going for those minmax value units. And
Vex Apathetic is simply one of them for
four power. Having that deflect, having
that stun, and being four might, it's
just value town.
>> It is. I mean, so much value on that
Vex. And I'm very Yeah, I want to know
if they're going to be using Zenith
Blade. I I feel like that would be my
personal choice. Maybe could even bring
over that lonely pearl from the other
battlefield.
>> Yeah, could definitely stun into the Vex
apathetic. Frankly, you could stun the
Vex and then bring that start poro over
and then increase your might, decrease
Diwali. That could be a play for sure.
It is an action speed, so L would have
to open the the chain there with that
Zenith blade and then that would leave
Diwali open to respond with any
reactions he may have, potentially
having some counters, potentially a star
cross, that kind of thing. Um, but right
now it just looks like we're enjoying
some snacks.
>> We are enjoying some snacks. We are
looking and revising ourselves on the
Star Tip. Star Tipped Peak is the ma the
battlefield of choice for Diwali and L
is has chosen the Monastery of Herana
which do have quite a few benefits on
themselves. Remember Monastery of Herana
L they go in or anybody goes in with a
unit that is buffed. They can use that
buff to draw a card.
>> Yeah, definitely. It's a nice resource
to have to get you that card advantage
that star tipped. If you hold it, you
get to channel one rune exhausted. So,
it just depends on the style that you
want to play or what resources you need
at the time. If you need the rune, you
go in for Star Tipp. If you need the
card, you go in for Monastery of Herana.
But this is definitely going to favor
Elmore because she actually brought an
engine to bring those buffs online,
whereas Diwali hasn't.
>> Yeah, we're talking about that Nami.
That Nami is able to buff your units,
but we haven't really seen the Nami, I
think, in the hand of Al just yet. So,
that buff generator hasn't isn't quite
available just yet.
>> Yeah, for sure. We're going to need to
see the longer game on this one. Right
now there are a few conquer points a
piece here. I believe it was two when we
last left off. And I think we're just
working out the kind of sequence of
plays here that was occurring before we
got into that nine might Aurelia Fervent
moving in to that battlefield. And I
wonder if it's Dwali waiting to respond
if focus has passed over to Dwali or if
it is currently with L right now. But
both of these players they're four and
zero. They've been playing out of their
minds right now, Ricy, to even get to
this point. And like you said at the
top, right, it's eight rounds today.
We're half we're past the halfway mark.
>> Yeah,
>> that's why the snacks are coming out as
well to uh make sure you guys refuel,
stay hydrated as well. It's very, very
important for such a long day. I mean,
it it's eight rounds and each round is
at minimum 1 hour. So, it's probably
like a 10-hour day for these people.
>> Yeah. They can't forget they need to
stay hydrated. They need to be eating as
many snacks as they possibly can, too.
But we do come back to life and we see
the buff in the Zenith Blade, as you
call.
>> Yeah, there goes the Zenith Blade and
they're going to be I don't know which
unit that L chose to stun, but that they
did bring over the um
>> pro over and uh now I I also see that
six on the Hay.
>> Yeah. So that would be the total might
of Hi, I have to imagine. Or is that 11
might on Hui
>> because we did see the spell be there's
no new discard here. Apparently five
might.
>> I haven't seen anything in the trash
that could bring Hui up to six might or
change that.
>> L has played the Zenith Blade.
>> I let it resolve.
I think they're discussing how this
one's playing out here because
>> I think with the zenith blade, it can
bring that that porro over the
>> stwart porro over to that battlefield
because it reads right action speed.
Stun an enemy at a battlefield. So that
would change the might favor towards L.
Yeah,
>> you may move a friendly enemy unit which
is not location restricted to that enemy
unit's battlefield.
>> Yeah.
>> So the store porro can absolutely do
this.
I agree with you.
>> Okay,
>> we're having some spirited discussion.
>> Yeah, spirited.
>> Yeah, we've got the might totals here as
well down on the battlefield, which is
nice.
>> Very nice.
>> Already showing 11 here as well, which
explains the store for a move in.
>> Mhm.
>> But we still haven't got the explainer
around what he's what sorry, what L has
stunned, what might reduction Diwali
will go through.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> They're currently at three points a
piece.
Three points a piece. If L does conquer
this battlefield of Star Tipped Peak,
they will go up to that four. An even
number, which does give the tempo, put
the tempo in L's hands.
>> Yeah, definitely favored to be on those
even number conquest points here as this
one's a slow burn. We need to we need to
slow down. We need to let this game
simmer and cook because I feel like a
banger is at the end of this period. We
see that Zenith Blade and I think what
L's doing here is just guiding us all
through those steps again. It's just,
yep, no worries. I stunned that unit at
the battlefield and then I moved my Stor
in and this is my play. And so now I
think with the judge and Diwali having a
look at that, they're going to go, "Ah,
okay, that makes sense." And then
hopefully the play will continue from
there. But look at the packed crowds
there. We love to see a full hall.
>> I love seeing the little Teemo hats out
there in the crowd, too. I think I've
spotted three. It kind of feels like a
find Wall-E kind of type event at the
moment. So, three Teemo hats. Do you
see?
>> There's There's one there. Yeah. Oh,
that's a green beanie at the back.
>> So, that was the third one.
>> Yeah. I I really want a Teemo hat
myself. I still haven't managed to get
one.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. But have you seen the really the
new ones that are out there that have
got the squeezy flaps and the ears flap
around?
>> Yes, they're really really cute. I love
them.
>> I love them.
But this is the Riftbound regional
qualifiers here in Sydney 2026 and we
are still just really getting started on
this game one of this best of three
match here between Dwali and L. Diana
versus Leona and we're just working
those plays out and um I'm sure this
will be a three game
>> barnstormer.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah, I want to use barnstormer. No, I'm
very excited to see what goes on in this
match because we don't really get to see
many Leonas. And uh Leona is such a fun
legend to play with all the stuns going
on. And we can see of course Dwalli is
playing Diana. Such a popular legend in
this meta especially with that Vex
Apathetic. Um especially with Das Tailed
Watcher, Gust Star Frost. These are some
very very powerful cards. Yeah, and I
really do appreciate this second look at
Diwali's main board if you will. All
right, so stupify little bit of card
control. You know, you draw some, you
reduce the might of your opponents.
Raven Bloom student obviously there to
benefit from all of these cheap spells.
The gust, the ride the wind, the stack
decks, that kind of thing. We'll
definitely get some work out of Eclipse,
which is a new unleashed card as well.
Very similar to smokeokescreen. It's
reaction give a unit minus four might
this turn, but it also has predict on
it. Rice. Yeah, predict, which is
something that Diana loves doing. It's
part of their champion unit as well.
When a showdown begins, may pay one to
and if you do, you may predict, then
reveal the top card of your main deck.
If it's a spell, draw it. And the same
thing with Eclipse. You look at the top
deck of your main deck, and you may
recycle it or leave it on top.
>> Yep, that's the one. And I'm also
enjoying when they submit their deck
lists that they've opted for the
overnumbered Plundering Pors here. Yeah,
I think we can all appreciate a really
nice plundering porro.
>> How many openumbered porros have you
got?
>> I've got two so far.
>> Yeah, I've got mystic porro and I've got
daring porro.
>> I've got plundering porro.
>> I think I've also got daring poro.
>> Hey,
>> I think they're the only two. I think
I'm on two as well.
>> Yeah, my wife and I, we're hunting the
playables. We want the plunderings and
the lonlies. They'll go straight into
our decks.
>> But I do love that they do these special
art treatments. But here at the
regionals, what matters is the mechanics
of those cards. And one of the most
important is, as we've said before, that
vex apathetic. It's such an oppressive
sort of board state controller that when
you play it, you stun it. It can't be
readied. So there's not much you can do.
But I think it'll find minimal value
here into Leona. Leona is not a very
fast deck. She doesn't want to play the
unit and immediately swing in. She's
happy to sit there for that turn like a
normal deck would see.
>> Yeah. It doesn't run at those ambush or
accelerate which is really really weak
against the vex apathetic and so with
this matchup Vex was played but I don't
know how strong is going to be into this
L we're looking at their deck again we
can see the back offs we see the Nami
they also do stuns V does stuns as well
and of course the zenith blade
>> yeah zenith blade is really good but I
spy with my little eye a card that saved
someone from an unchecked power earlier
Emperor's Divide. There is only one copy
of it, but it is so effective at what it
does that I think it's worth the one
drop in the chance that you hit it.
Stellicorn Herder excellent for that
card draw, but back off. And Nami
leaning into that stun sort of synergy
with that legend. As you said, the Vi
here too. And Scuttle Crab is just
present in every single Karm deck right
now.
>> I love Scuttle Crab. I'm not surprised
that death nail has such powerful
abilities attached to it. When poor
scuttle crab scuttle crab dies with only
zero might you get to choose an opponent
they have to reveal their entire hand
and as well as a hidden card and then
they you can also gain one experience.
doesn't really matter too much for SNR,
but for sorry for um
for L at the moment with no experience
uh units, but you know, it exists.
>> It's nice to have. I get experience. I
level up just because my deck doesn't. I
mean, why not? But I do want to take a
look at the champion unit here for that
Leona. Leona Zealot is the green one.
Six power uh six energy, one power. Oh
my goodness. Six. Can you imagine that?
If an opponent's score is within three
points of the victory score, I enter
ready. So, we were just saying there's
not much Vex will stop. Vex will stop.
Leona Zealot.
>> True.
>> Stunned enemy units here have minus 8
might to a minimum of one.
>> So, a fantastic tool to bring down the
total like might of your opponent's
battlefields.
>> Yeah, I'm very I would love to see this
Lona out in play. Not sure when El was
going to be playing it. as you mentioned
that um stunned from Vex apathetic in
this uh matchup at the moment. It it
does kind of diminish his Leona's enter
ready benefit. So maybe El will want to
play a bit earlier, but of course it is
a very expensive unit. Six uh six energy
and one power for a champion chosen
unit.
>> Yeah. And I do want to highlight once
again the actual synergy of Nami, right?
Because you read the legend of Leona.
When you stun one or more enemy units,
buff a friendly unit.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So Nami's got the stun. Nami's
got the buff. Legend has the stun.
Zenith Blade has the stun. And all these
buffs can be used on Monastery of
Herana. So what first game Monastery of
Harana tells me is that L want wants to
win this hard and fast. She wants to get
those buffs online. She wants to spend
them to draw those cards, get the card
advantage over Diwali on that Diana and
take this game one. Get that momentum.
get that mental edge over Diwali here.
>> Lots of combinations that El can use as
you mentioned that buff, the stuns and
uh especially with that battlefield um
the monastery of Herana. It's such a
good combination and I'm really excited
to see how all of this stuff works. I
mean, of course, you got the standard
yellow cards like Cold of Glory, Call of
Week as well. And Fiora is also in this
deck.
>> Not to be underestimated that Fiora, the
moment she goes mighty, which is very
easy. All you need to do is put one buff
on her. She becomes monstrous. I'm
pretty sure she gets deflect, ganking,
and tank or shield. I'll have to double
check that one. But she becomes keyword
monster there as it looks like we might
be headed back to our game. But Fiora,
before we move on, while I'm mighty, I
have deflect, ganking, and shield. So,
she becomes quite the menace and it will
become easy to bring her online because
of all the buffs that L has brought to
this field. But another unit in the main
deck that has just
made its way into every single deck that
can run her is Aurelia Fervent, right?
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Two Aurelia in this Leona deck. So, she
can definitely win fights at showdowns
as well. Yeah, this fervent Ireelia is
super duper strong and I kind of I want
to say a little bit annoying as well
because the ability of this Ireelia is
when you choose already me give me plus
one this turn and when we run calm decks
they have so many spells that you can
use that you can target Ireelia with
>> yeah absolutely speaking of things to
target Aurelia with we can see that in
El's deck there's also that discipline
that staple of that calm arm domain that
call to glory will also target. So that
will increase whatever it is Aurelia
Fervent has to bring. Uh and then we
also have Emperor's Divide to save. But
Ricey buffs you do need to target the
unit that you're going to apply the buff
to.
>> I was wondering that. I was wondering
that Logan because of how many buffing
with the legend existing of the legend
of Leona existing the dawn. You can then
potentially buff Aurelia and that will
give that buff to Ireelia and then
potentially that plus one because you
are choosing them. Nami exists as well
and when you play when Nami holds the
next time you play a unit that this turn
they'll also get buffed. So you could
hold with Nami play that Aurelia target
it and then it becomes another plus one.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Anytime you can get
additional might on that Aurelia
Fervent, you're going to have a good
time. It will help take you over the top
which is what L is trying to achieve
here with this Aurelia fervent currently
sitting at that nine M into that star
cross with Dwali presenting 92 and I
have to think these two they're trying
to work out how this is going to play
out the the sequence of play how we got
here the runes exhausted the cards in
the trash the runes recycled all manner
of game play and you can tell this one's
pretty important right now because we're
spending a little bit of time on it But
before we talk any more about those
sorts of judge calls and you know we
have a lot of amazing judges here who
are helping with these games, let's talk
a little bit more about the regionals.
Rice here.
>> It is as you said the first time in the
southern hemisphere. We've been spoiled.
We are very very spoiled and also uh one
of the first original qualifiers of the
the western half but now in the eastern
half of the world where which means we
have a bit of a clash of interesting um
communities coming through. We have of
course our Australian player base here.
We also have some people flying over
from Europe and America to play in this
regional qualifiers. And not only that,
we've been even having some Chinese
players come over to play as well. Yeah,
as you said, as we saw, we actually got
one of the EDG gamers down here. I think
you had the honor of interviewing him.
He won his game, so that's fantastic to
see. But it's that eastern and western
sort of meta that is different even
though we're just geographically, you
know, around the corner, so to speak.
There's those different play styles, and
it's great to see them coming together
here in Sydney. We do have a lot of
local uh Chinese uh players as well, you
know, as they were studying and
everything like that. So, they also
probably are quite influenced by the
Chinese play style over in China from
all those Chinese uh regionals as well.
And so, as Bolan was talking about in
that interview, he was talking about how
in the meta over there, there's a lot
more masc now and a lot more. We see
that here too. Not sure if this is a
global thing or if it's a uniquely
regional qualified Sydney. Look, I'm
going to tell you right here, right now,
there are smarter people than me all
around the world. So, it does not
surprise me that the Western meta and
the Eastern Meta have kind of converged
and reached the same conclusions of,
hey, these decks are good. We should run
these at the regionals, Ricey. And as we
saw, Yi is one of the most represented
decks here. Aurelia and Leblanc, but it
looks like we might be getting back into
the action here. Diwali at three, L at
three, and that yeah, it looks like that
Zenith Blade has resolved. It's in the
trash. Store Porro is over there on that
second battlefield. But I'm wondering
what unit was stunned.
>> Yeah, I would love to know which unit
was stunned as well. If it were up to
me, I'd probably stun Gray cuz he is on
five while Vex is on four. But
>> I do not know the minds of L. They are
better and greater players here on this
table right now. So, they are both 4-0
here in the regional qualifiers.
>> I could never go 40-0 on Leona at a
regional qualifier. This is just
phenomenal performance, especially
coming from an underdog, right? There's
so many players out here, like I've said
before, that are one tricks and they
become so good. They become so
specialized and niched in their legend
as Starcross. Starcross does come out.
We've talked about Starross many times
before and now we're about to see it in
action. Star Fox, you bounce one of your
enemy units and one of your own units
presumably here. Uh, Dwalli could choose
to bounce Quay here or of course the um
Diana that's in base maybe the Vex as
well. I wouldn't personally choose the
Vex. You kind of like having a hold. But
of course, if El's units, I would pick
Aurelia.
>> Oh, Aurelia makes sense. She will have
to pay that deflect cost though, so it
will be a little bit more punishing than
a normal star cross would be in anyone
else. And we do see that that rune has
been recycled by Diwali. So he will be
targeting that Ireelia and he has also
bounced his we're waiting for his unit
bounce his wave.
>> He's looking to save that one. And as it
stands right now, this combat will just
be down between this store porro and
this Vex apathetic. And Vex takes that
every day of the week.
>> Yeah, I mean poor Star Pro is only on
two. Not having that shield buff either.
So Vex with that formite is easily going
to take that. Now Cole the week has been
used by L forcing Dwali to get rid of
the Diana.
>> Yeah, Diana Lunari does go down. Hits
the dirt for that call the week. The two
and one coming from L there while she
has no units on the board. That is a
fantastic time to play it. But we're
back to Dwali. He's readied up that Vex
apathetic
and we'll see what he has to offer here.
>> One thing I'd like to note is that that
was a very expensive round for L only
having four runes left while Dwali has
he's moving them while I'm trying to
count them. Makes things a bit more
difficult. But Quay has been played.
That was five runes. So it still has one
rune up still to do anything or maybe
hold it for the next turn.
>> Yeah, definitely exhausting those five
and that one for bringing that Hay back.
So I would argue Dwali thinks that that
was a decent play. Obviously that star
cross saving that way because that would
have been most likely the primary target
here for L because L could have just
beat down Vex in combat there nice and
tidily. But we do see Monastery of
Harana is open. Star Tipped Peak is
open. No one is on any battlefields. And
that Aurelia Fervent is back to base.
>> Yeah, I mean in that Star only bounce
L's Aelia into L's hand. So of course L
can play it right now and definitely
chooses to. That's also a five energy
unit. Same like Quay, but doesn't have
that power cost.
>> Yeah, exactly. Five energy beats five
energy and one power any day of the
week, especially when you're trying to
avoid dramping yourself. But everybody
knows, everybody loves Aurelia Fervent
is four might deflect. And when you
choose or ready me, give me plus one
might this turn, Ricey. And that is the
entire turn. And sometimes people can
forget that.
>> Yeah, exactly. the entire turn because
after showdown's end they the units do
heal up but those mites those additional
mites do stay for the entire turn. I
also love the combination with that
heart of dark ice as well. It's a plus
three with the gear but with Ireelia
Furin's extra ability I mean she can go
up in size quite quickly.
>> Yeah, it's a repeatable plus4 might onto
an Aurelia Fervent. When you exhaust
that gear and you target her, you get
the plus three and that plus one. But
Hay
>> Quay moves in onto Monastery of Herana.
Does the drawing and discarding chooses
to draw chooses to discard the stupify
which does which is a spell. So he gets
to draw one card.
>> Yeah, definitely valuing that card draw.
I mean a stupify for a card draw just
makes sense, right? Because you're going
to play that stupify to get a card draw.
So why not discard it and get it anyway?
So I really do like that play here. But
Diwali currently in the driver's seat
>> going in for that Sith conquer point
bringing back onto Star Tipped Peak is
going to be also using three energy here
using um Diana as well. Very curious to
see what this three energy card is going
to be.
>> Three in one is Starcross. Oh, Moonfall,
Diana's signature spell.
>> It is in fact Moonfall. Diana's
signature spell. Choose a battlefield
where you have units. You may move up to
one enemy unit to that battlefield which
means Ireelia is gone.
>> Yeah, interesting. That's definitely a
big play from Dwali there. Removing the
only unit L had here, Icy. And we do
take a quick look at those points. Dwali
in a commanding position. He's at six.
He only needs one more turn. He's
holding both battlefields. He has six
runes up and has passed his turn here.
for
>> he has. He only needs to hold both
battlefields and he will claim game one
now. Eldo, we do know that they have
quite a few abilities. I mean, I like
that vi in hand.
>> Yeah, vi in hand, but not going to enter
ready as she opts for the Leona le
champion unit here. And because it's
within three, it will enter ready. So,
this Leona can actually get something
done this time.
>> We forget about Beg's apathetic though.
Even though that she enters ready, she
cannot move, which means how does she
get in there? She can't. Which means
that is game Dwali does take this first
game.
>> L forgot. I forgot. I'm I'm so glad I
knew him in there. But yeah, Vex
apathetic literally clutching that one
out. Making sure that Leona not able to
enter ready is stunned. cannot do
anything to get Diwali off of those two
battlefields in what was a slow and dare
I say tense game there I see while they
were sort of negotiating those plays.
>> Exactly. Yeah, it was quite a
interesting game and I really want to
see more of these stuns come through.
Vex. I thought Vex wouldn't be a super
hard counter to Leona, but when Leona
does enter ready on that less than
three, when it's three or more before
victory, she will enter ready, which
means with this game, El thought she
could have done it, but cannot.
>> Yeah. Now, we do take a look at it,
right? So, Vex is going to shut down
that Leona Zealot champion. Vex is also
going to shut down that ambush VI that
wants to enter and stun. So, it does
have a little bit of tech here into that
Leona deck that L has brought to bear,
but it looks like we're actually getting
ready for sideboards and shuffles, which
is really nice. I do like the uh the
card sleeves that we've got going on
here, but I would like to see this Leona
sort of come online a little bit more
here in game two. I don't think we
really got to see it shine in that game
one. I think the other thing that Vex
apathetic does shut down is the maybe a
Zenith Blade combo as well, like because
you can move a friendly unit onto the
battlefield. If you play a unit, you
could potentially bring that unit over
straight to that battlefield and fight
immediately.
>> But with that Vex apathetic, if you play
it that turn, you still cannot use
anything to move that to that
battlefield because that um unit is
still stunned and cannot deal any
damage.
>> Yeah. So, this replaces the move effect
from the unit. So you
>> Yeah, you can still move it, but it
still be stunned.
>> It's still stunned. Yeah. Which reduces
the combat the the might, which is
obviously a fantastic answer. But you
are playing it into a stun deck, which
will likely have a lot of stuns and then
just zero it out. But I would have to
imagine they're not going to play that
Zenith Blade in that situation anyway.
>> Exactly.
>> It is their signature spell. It is very,
very powerful and not to be wasted.
>> A stun card though that we haven't
spoken about, which is in Diwali's main
board, is that Existential Dread, right?
So you can stun an enemy unit and if
it's already stunned, you can actually
return it to hand if you pay the repeat.
>> So it's almost like we're in a little
bit of a stun off here too because you
know Elen stun, Dwali can stun.
>> But I really appreciated that game and
we do get to see this thorough shuffling
now that sideboard tech has been
introduced. And Dwalli taking that game
one finds himself at that advantageous
position. He's the one with the mental
edge. She's the one with the momentum
here and L is the one who has to find a
way back into this.
>> Yeah, the pressure is on for L. You
know, one game, first game loss does
mean you have to win two now in a row.
Uh don't have that fall back of that
extra game anymore. And they both 4-0 at
the moment. So if L does lose here,
they'll end up being 4-1 and Dual will
be 5, which 5-0 is a really good score
here in this regional qualifiers. Yeah,
4-1 still respectable, but as you say,
five and zero, that is the outcome. That
is the goal. That builds your story.
That builds your legend. Every regional
qualifier that you watch, every regional
qualifier that you see, there's always
one player towards the tippy top heading
into that top eight that is undefeated
and all eyes are on them.
>> I can hear the card shuffling and it's
such a beautiful sound. I don't know if
uh stream broadcast can hear it too, but
just hearing their car shuffling is just
I don't know. It's just something really
nice to hear.
>> ASMR at region regional qualifier
Sydney, but they're fresh sleeves,
right? So, they've got that extra crispy
clicketity clack of the sleeve
shuffling. However, we do take a quick
look at those battlefields. We have the
arena's greatest here for L on that
Leona. They want a quick game and we
have abandoned hall from Diwali. He
wants to boost his units up. Abandon
Hoe. I me we we've seen this in their
deck list and I mentioned maybe Dwley
wants to play this in that second round.
Abandoned Hull is so strong for
spellheavy decks such as Diana. If you
use a spell, you get to buff sorry you
get to increase the might of one unit.
>> Yeah, that's it. When a player plays a
spell, they may give a unit they control
it plus one might this turn. It's it's
basically Aurelia Fervent's ability just
not on Aurelia Fervin herself and you
can pick another unit. And we're already
into it. We are already into it. There
comes out the scuttle crab on L's turn
and Diana on Dwali's turn.
>> Yeah, turn one that Diana Lari always
great. But turn two, L moves in.
>> Moves in with that scarlet crab gets
themselves that first conquer point
and actually second one because of
Arena's greatest. I forgot about Arena's
greatest being their second battlefield
for L. So now L's on two right now and
yeah, Diana is in play. So I'm very
curious to see what L's going to do.
They still have four runs up. Out comes
that lonely parro.
>> Yeah, but they also have the dark heart
of ice as well. They've got the charm.
They've got the zenith blade. Aurelia
fervent. So l's hand is looking very
very healthy. But Dwali, he's not
inclined to give any information out for
free to any of us. Just has that alt art
dino lunar on the base at the moment and
is looking to respond to whatever L can
bring down here. We're just considering
our options because that Heart of Dark
Ice is that three energy, one power. So,
I can't play it now. Only has two runes
left open. But it works so beautifully
with Aurelia, as we've said a few times.
Now,
>> do I see a Vex? Is that Vex on the the
right?
>> On the right.
>> I don't know. It's kind of bluish
purplish.
>> Do you mean in Dwali's hand?
>> In Dwali's hand.
>> On the right side.
>> No, no, I don't mean right of the
screen. I mean right of his hand. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Absolutely. I don't
know. I can't see enough. It's vex
cheerless, though.
>> Yeah. So, that one is all about reducing
the cost of energy and power when it's a
cast spell there and increases the cost
for your opponents. So, that's one of
the older Vexes actually. It's really
nice to see that. I actually personally
run that one in my uh Aurelia decks as
well.
>> Yeah. From Spirit Forge Vex Cheerless.
When I'm in combat, friendly spells cost
one energy, one power less to a minimum
of one. And enemy spells cost one power
and one energy more. That is such a very
interesting interesting card to be
played, but it actually only happens
while violent combat.
>> Yeah. No, absolutely. And so you want to
be on the battlefield. You want to be in
those showdowns in that combat sort of
showdown situation with his vex
cheerless, but it's really going to hurt
what L want wants to do if she's trying
to play around that Aurelia as she uses
charm to drag Diana Linari into a
showdown.
>> Heart of Dark Eyes has been played and
used on that lonely prow. And as you
mentioned, charm is being used to drag
Diana into that showdown. Looking at
Dwalli, they don't have any runes up,
but of course, Diana's ability, Diana's
legend does get used as well. We did
just see that there is another Vex
Chilus on the top of Diwali's deck
there. But L, she wins that combat and
she does find herself up at four
conquest points here. Icy. So right now
she's off to the races. She's definitely
got an early lead. A stronger start here
than what was in that game one. And
we're I'm Oh, we see a star crossed. We
see Eclipsed as well. A thousand tail
watcher to close out that game when it
gets to that late game stage. Rice.
Yeah, that's going to be really exciting
to see if we get that. We might have a
quick game like we did previously. And
judging from what L is doing, currently
on four conquer points, it could be a
quick game. Now, Dwali's turn is
considering the Vex cheerless maybe
going to abandon Hoe and instead is
going to be contesting Arena's greatest.
>> Yeah, definitely the stronger one here.
I think they just both pass focus
judging by those hand signals. I have to
imagine that L probably won't want to
contest this too much. Dwali indicating
I have six runes up. Eld indicating I
have too. You know, you're going to have
to work for this.
>> It is a Lonely Pyro though. So, if
Lonely Pyro does unfortunately die in
this uh combat, it does mean that you
get that death now, that extra draw.
>> Yeah, the card draw which L has gone
for. So, they all both pass focus. No
additional cards were um cast and so
Lonely Porro dies drawing one card for
L. So, now Dwali has conquered that
arena's greatest battlefield. takes
himself up to two bonker points here.
>> Is that another Vex cheerless? He's
thinking about it. He hasn't committed
the runes yet, but that could be so
difficult for L to take that battlefield
if there are two Vex Chiluses because
that effect does stack. You'd have to
pay two energy and two power more for
everything you wanted to do.
>> That sounds so gross. So, very curious
if that is what he's going to be
playing. and he's looking at Star Frost
in his hand as well. And that would mean
if he is in a combat, Starfrost is going
to be just one energy.
>> Uh so it will reduce it by one energy,
one power. So it'll go down to two
energy if there's only one Vex. But if
there's two, yes, only the one. So that
could be quite the turnaround here. He
has opted for it.
>> He has opted it for it, but not playing
it in Arena's greatest going to be
playing it in the base. Potentially
looking towards the next turn. And now L
is going to be readying up all the units
of course including the scuttle crab.
Very curious to see whether or not that
scuttle crab is going to go back onto
abandoned hull or what she's going to
do.
>> I have to imagine that this scuttle crab
will move in for abandoned hall.
>> That's what I'm imagining too.
>> It's a free battlefield. You get a
conquer point.
>> You make Dwali work for it.
>> Mhm.
>> Maybe hold up some runes. Right. But we
do see the zenith blade. I think we saw
the Nami. Nami is there. Heart of dark
ice.
>> Yes. Now at three might this chunky
little stuff is going to go on to
abandon hole. Now we did see the charm
as well. And I think we saw he said
zenith blade. So there are a couple of
options for l here if you wants to
potentially maybe go for that vex on
arena's greatest.
>> Aras is an Aurelia fervent a charm as
you said
>> and then an army.
>> Yeah. And an emperor's divide. Couple of
options available, but not great spell
slinging if I'm honest.
>> Oh, I thought I saw a Zenith Blade. I
was I wrong. No, I do see the Zenith
Blade. There is there is swing down onto
Arena's greatest.
>> Yeah, L has had that in hand since the
opening. So, a great card to have there,
but weighing up those options with those
six runes. There's only so much that L
can do here and opts for Aurelia.
>> I think playing a little playing a
little bit safer. Bringing out the
Aurelia looking towards the next turn.
Currently on five conquer points. Aelia,
we know her. We love her. We love to
hate her. It is Ireelia. When you choose
already me, give Ireelia plus one this
turn.
>> The problem is if Vexilus gets into
combat,
>> Aurelia is a prime star cross target
>> because of that stacking cost reduction.
>> You'll be able to just pay the deflect.
>> Mhm.
>> But it makes it just the normal cost of
the star cross, right? So you're not
punished for it. It just net neutrals
with that one Vex.
>> Exactly.
>> So that's definitely good. Dwi moves in.
moves in. Dwali is not going to be using
Starcross here in that combat or any
other ability. Not going to be using the
Vex Cheers. And now of course shows his
hand because of the scuttle crab.
>> Yeah, the death on that scuttle crab.
Just exposing your opponent's hand for
that free information is such a boon
here. L taking the time on that notepad
to write everything down. So L has full
information, a full read on everything
in Dwali's hand and is better placed to
be able to play around it right now as L
just looks around thinking of her
options. What can she do here? But the
play is on Diwali.
>> The play still is in the hands of Dwali
who's considering Raven Bloom student at
the moment wondering is should I play in
the base? Should I play it on Arena's
greatest? Lots of options but you want
to make the right choice.
>> Yeah, definitely. Raven Bloom Shudin is
such a strong mind domain unit here. Can
be pumped to massive proportions. Pays
those two runes, exhausts the two and
Raven Bloom student. Oh, quick change of
mind. Doesn't change anything at the
game state. So that's okay. Plays out
Raven Bloom Student in the base and then
passes the turn with five runes up and a
fist full of cards.
>> Five runes and of course Diana Legend
up. Don't want to forget Diana Legend
cuz I know I often forget Diana Legend
existing in my games which is really
frustrating when you're trying to do the
maths. Now Heart of Dark Ice is going to
be the one used which of course Aurelia
gets ready was on one now dark of dark
ice being used adds three was chosen now
five.
>> Yeah the problem is this Aurelia has to
run into a Vex cheerless it's going to
cost reduce for Dwali it's going to cost
increase for L. So L's going to try, I
have to believe, and get everything out
now. And there is that Nami that we've
been talking about.
>> Nami on play will stun any unit
choosing, I believe, the Vex on Arena's
greatest. So that might be the target.
And also, you are able to buff when you
stun because of the legend.
>> Yeah, absolutely. You paid that
additional cost, get that stun, get that
buff. So now Aurelia is even bigger. The
buff chose Aurelia gave her that extra
one might and the buff itself gives that
extra might as well there Icy it's
becoming quite a big Aurelia
>> very very big if we can do quick math
that is 511
>> you agree
>> looks to be I was worried about the
Diana being tapped getting that energy
we see Dwali he's also tapped another
rune
>> and only costs one sorry two and one
recycle because of their vex
>> cheerless
>> cheerless and it has to pay also for the
targeting of Ireelia will in fact get
starrust. I don't think L has any uh
counters for that.
>> Yeah. So obviously being in calm uh you
would have Defy, but if you don't have
Defy in hand, you can't stop it. And
unfortunately, I don't think L has the
answer to that one. It would have been
quite the turn of play if she was able
to rip out Defy right there, right then,
Ricey. But unfortunate just hadn't found
it yet.
>> Has to play again. It feels like we we
just did this two turns ago as yeah once
again is bounced back to hand and El has
to end the turn by playing her
>> and Dwali finds himself on six points.
He's one turn away from winning. Same
situation as game one if he holds both
of these battlefields and gets both
those conquer points. He goes to eight
and takes this game two. So right now L
is up against it. Five points for
herself here, but she has to do
something to prevent Dwali holding both
battlefields.
>> Exactly. And interestingly, Dwali has
chosen to bring Vex back. I think going
for the conquer points later on rather
than the hold. Out comes Raven Bloom
student. Out comes Quay as well.
Building up that army in base. And now
it's over to L's turn passing over the
priority.
>> That's it. That's it. We do see the
focus return to L. She's on the play
only presenting that Aurelia Fervent and
that Nami going in to get that conquer
on the arena's greatest. But we have to
see how she's going to respond to Diwali
here because I have to imagine that way
he's going to discard that card the the
unit to give it three might to make it
even stronger and try and go over the
top get that double conquer like you
said.
>> Exactly. And with those Vex Chillers
existing two of them going into these
fights. L will be forced to be spending
a a lot of energy.
>> There it is.
>> Two play abilities, but Charm is being
used is going to be used on a one of the
Vexs.
>> Yep. Abandoned Hall buffing Aurelia,
>> of course.
>> And then chose Aelia.
>> Yep. Exactly. I'm now on plus three and
bringing in this Vex. That's it. Aurelia
seven might right now
>> as L is reminding Dwali of the text of
abandoned hall and targeting Aurelia.
>> He has that face that I have when uh
>> oh really when you when you when
abandoned hall targets Aelia that counts
as a target or gets another one. It's
it's such a frustrating tech but that
makes so strong
>> so dangerous and takes out that Vex
cheerless. It is on that battlefield
there. I think focus has been passed.
We'll see if Dwali has any options, any
answers here cuz the showdown has begun.
It's been dragged onto the battlefield.
>> I believe he has exhausted the legends
and exhausted one rune and because of
the Vex
>> ability as well. The eclipse only costs
the two energy now being used. It's of
course going to be target targeting um
Aurelia.
>> Yep. We'll see how this one plays out
because now Aurelia Fervent is down to
three might and Vex currently up to six
because he was able to turn abandoned
hall on for Vex cheless as well. El
though full hand. There it is. Zenith
Blade.
>> Zenith Blade does come out. It's going
to be theoretically stunning. Yes, the
Vex and will mean that L can bring back
up in the hands of Nami. Yeah, Nami will
scoot across from the Arena's greatest
to support her top laner
here just to make sure she does not go
down in the face of that mid laner Vex
Sheilus.
>> Exactly. And Nami being a support does
need to do this ganking, go to the top
and support everything. And so I'm
excited to see how this is going to be
played out here. Of course, has to pay
the cost and the extra cost of Vex
cheerless. That is why there was another
um exhaust and recycle. Yeah, good
reminder there from Diwali. So, that
Zenith Blade cost four and three power.
So, that is an expensive Zenith Blade.
Surely L hopes that this one pays off
here.
Is buffed.
>> Yep. Get buffed
>> for Nami to come across.
>> Buffed because of the legend of Leona,
the Radiant Dawn. When you stun an enemy
unit, you can buff a unit of your own.
And that is of course going to be
>> Ialia.
>> Vexilus is stunned.
Zenith blade
>> being hovered. It goes to the trash.
>> Vex chillis pinned
>> combat
>> back on the great the arena's greatest.
>> I believe maybe El chose not to bring
Nami over. I don't think you have to
move a friendly unit. I think it's you
may move a friendly unit. So decided to
leave Nami there instead.
>> You are absolutely correct. You may move
a friendly unit. So yeah, you don't need
to move her over. So obviously initially
decided to possibly do that and then
against it
>> Fiora comes out as well. We talked about
Fior a little bit in the break earlier
where if Fiora is mighty and it's so
easy to make a mighty just need one buff
and with that legend Radiant Dawn it's
quite easy to buff Le Fiora and she'll
be as you said a monster.
>> That's it. But L now in the driver's
seat L finds herself at that seven
victory points there. One point away
from winning this game too. But that
said, Dwali not out of this by a long
shot as it's six conquest points himself
here and does have three units present.
That Vex cheerless, that Raven Bloom
student, and that Huay brooding painter.
And we all know Huay can be boosted up
to at least eight very, very easily
here. That is a table full of runes as
well. There's nine up. Nine is quite a
lot of runes, especially when you also
consider this Vex cheerless considering
to bring that in first to try and get
that extra ability of making all the
spells cheaper. And they're going to be
contesting Nami on Arena's greatest. I'm
very curious to see what that hidden
card is. Uh looking at the deck list
that they have, I'm sure it could be a
few options.
>> One thing that I do love here that I
want to point out is that this Vex
Cheerless is sideboard tech. In the main
board, Dwali had those Vex apathetics
and then after game one, there it is.
Presents the win. Thousand tail watcher.
Dwali takes game two in a clean two game
series here. Icy
>> two zero for Dwalli. We know why he's so
good and what he previously achieved in
other regional qualifiers. We can see
still in this meta in Unleash is
incredibly strong.
>> That's it. That's it. Diwali now goes to
five wins, zero losses, zero draws here
at the Riftbound Regional Qualifier,
Sydney 2026 piloting, dare I say, a
favored Diana Scorn of the Moon against
I'll say a community favorite of Leona.
>> Was fun to see the Leona though in play.
We don't really see as many Leonas of
course as Diana. So it's great to see
how Diana
fights up against the Leona. Diana,
Leona. Yes, these two lovers, the
Starcross lovers are fighting here. And
now it's going to be Diana taking the
victory.
>> That's it. That's it. Diana wins out.
You heard it here first, folks. Leona
loses to Diana every single time. No
more questions. That case has been
closed. But that was round five of
today's eight rounds here at the
Riftbound Regional Qualifiers in Sydney.
We've still got three more ahead of us
here as well, Ricey. show some quality
Riftbound gameplay as we've said before
from previous regional winners just like
Diwali to aspiring regional winners just
like L.
>> Exactly. And it's great to see these
multiple um communities coming together
here in the regional qualifier Sydney.
We've got many people coming over from
Europe and America as well as from
China. It's really a exciting event here
where we get to see all these different
play styles, all these different
communities come together and show us
some fantastic riftbound.
>> Yeah. And speaking of play styles, like
we were talking about in that game, too,
right? That Vex change up. We're all
expecting Vex apathetic to be there in
that game, too. But it appears like
Dwali actually sideboard teched out all
of the Vex Apathetics and put in all of
the Vex cheeryses from Spirit Forge,
which was, I want to say, a heads up
play. It had the exact same impact like
it did in Spirit Forge. It forced L to
spend a lot more power, a lot more
energy than she wanted to, and it
reduced those costs like you called that
star cross so much cheaper.
>> Much much cheaper and also much more
expensive for L. And I think especially
considering L's deck of being order and
calm, those calm cards which are usually
really really important to keep your
Ireelia alive, keep your whoever else
you want to keep alive as well, maybe
Nami as well. and you just won't be able
to use those abilities, those defies and
everything. I mean, you could use them,
but they're just so much more expensive.
>> You're so so right, Ricey. But enough
from us. We are going to throw over to
the interview with the winner, Dwali.
>> Hello. Hello. We are here with Dwali.
How are you feeling after that match? We
had the sun and moon here stage of the
day. How are you feeling?
>> Uh, feeling good, honestly. Um, that was
my first time playing against Leona, but
um, I asked about the sig spell. My
friend Ver recently has been raving
about Leona, so I've read like the the
cards in the deck and everything and it
helped and I'm feeling good. I forgot
it's like sun versus moon. That was
cool. But, uh, yeah, it's feeling great.
Yeah,
>> absolutely. And obviously you are no
stranger to winning. You had a great run
in Houston way back when. How has your
approach differed when you come here to
Sydney?
>> Um, that's a good question. Uh, I talked
to Allan a lot actually and Pris and you
know I spiked Houston but Allan and um
Prisma had continued top eights. Now
obviously I've gotten close I got like
10th in Atlanta and I've top 64 in a
bunch and uh you know I asked them you
know I talked to them about deck
building about how to approach a
tournament like this and uh their
guidance has really helped um and yeah
that's kind of my mindset for this one.
I want to be back in top eight and I'm
going to try my best to do that.
>> Yeah.
>> Awesome. Well, so that was obviously
with Annie. You've got Diana today, but
you did share online. Then it came down
to the wire between a couple of decks.
What led you to actually making the
decision to go Diane?
>> That's a good question. So, um, my three
options were, uh, Azir, Diana, and of
course, Annie. Like, those are the three
I was considering.
>> Uh, I think Annie and Azir are both also
strong choices. Um, what changed my
decision at the end was talking to Allan
first of all. He's he's also playing
Diana. His list is very good. And um I
realized Diana can actually beat Aurora,
which I thought wasn't really likely,
but he can. And uh Moonfall's broken. So
>> absolutely brilliant card. So when it
comes down to it, obviously, as you
said, Allan is also playing Diana.
There's a best of at stake. How are you
feeling about that?
>> I mean, it's never great to contest him,
I'll be honest, you know. Uh but I have
to fight to I want to win the
tournament. So, if I want to win the
tournament, I'm gonna have to fight
against good players to do it.
>> And if it's got to be Allen, it's got to
be Allen. He's one of the best players
and him and Pris. So,
>> we'll see, you know.
>> All right. I would be remiss if I did
not say, "It is very Australian of you
to be snacking down on those shapes."
>> But there was definitely some chatter of
people being like, "Wow, interesting."
Uh, so do you think they helped or
hindered?
>> Helped. Helped. Definitely helped.
>> Yes. Yes. Yes, I'm staying with my
friend in Sydney and I've been uh you
know getting into Australian culture and
I'm feeling good. He gave me the bucket
hat. Oh, was the wrong way this whole
time, but yeah,
feeling great.
>> Absolutely, silent. We've had a couple
of interesting hats here today. Who
knows what we'll see coming on. Thank
you so much and congratulations again.
We'll see how you go for the rest of the
weekend.
>> Thank you so much.
>> Throw them back.
>> Thank you so much. Stepp and Dwali are
the bucka hat. We were talking about it
a little bit earlier in the game. And we
love seeing the Australian culture being
presented to Dwali and all our other
international guests. Love the bucket
hat. Love the shapes. I didn't realize
it was eating shapes. It just looks so
normal to me.
>> I saw the shapes, but they missed the
one question. What's his favorite
flavor? It's chicken crimpy or nothing.
Diwali.
>> No, I'm I'm a big barbecue and pizza fan
personally. You know, we'll have to
debate this off broadcast of course, but
fantastic insight coming from Dwali
about all the legends that he was
choosing.
>> Yeah. And not only that insight, but
also the respect. Obviously, he knows he
has to play into fantastic players, but
he needs to win and he needs to win
against these fantastic players and he
was talking to all of them very
respectfully and I think he's quite
humble in his position right now. But
enough about the past Rosie Rice Rosie.
We're looking forward to our game three
of our second featured matchup.
>> Yeah, game three of our second feature
matchup. I believe there must be one
currently. So, we're going straight into
it. We are mid game. Actually, it is
actually I think early days. Nobody has
any points right now. Um, it's actually
game two. Uh, Disco Jesus has got one uh
win and Linus
Linara
has nothing at the moment.
>> That's it. We do have Poppy the Legend
with Linus Allegra versus Set the Boss
with Disco Jesus. And God, I love that
name. That is such a fantastic name.
both of these players here in this game
two of our best of play series and uh
40. We do see that Rift Herald, that new
unleash unit though has hit the base.
>> I do wonder what kind of Poppy this is.
I am assuming it's going to be an Aurora
Poppy, but it's also good to see the
set. I don't think there are many set
players out there, but the sets that are
there, I feel like they're kind of
really strong.
>> I have to think that Colin really
inspired a lot of the set players,
right? Colin best offset at Atlanta. So
very recent memory. Sabotage.
>> Sabotage. Such a strong card. I used it
a lot in Origins and is being used still
today. Choose an opponent. They reveal
their hands. Choose a non-unit card from
it and recycle that card.
>> I honestly didn't even get to see what
was recycled because it was the quickest
decision I've seen from Disco Jesus.
He's like, "That's the one I want." He
knows exactly what he wants to get rid
of. I really want to know too. Maybe it
wasn't Aurora. I got no idea. But set
when I played and when I conquer buff me
spend my buff for plus four this turn.
This that can be quite frustrating to
verse because of this extra buff and
that extra potential to go an extra plus
four. Rift Herald is going to go and
conquer sunken temple giving Linus Ara
potentially the first point on the
board. Yeah, what I do love about that
Rift Herald though is when it moves to a
battlefield, you get to look at the top
three cards of your main deck. You may
reveal a unit from among them and draw
it, recycling the rest. And then the
death nail is you can basically play
that unit from your hand to your base,
ignoring its energy cost,
>> but you still have to pay that power. So
very versatile, strong unit.
>> Very versatile indeed. Out comes as well
the recruit and a hidden card. wasn't
able to catch that either, but Lynn is
now on one point. But Disco Jesus is
still sitting on four. Has brought all
of their units back into base, back into
safety as well, and is probably looking
to potentially conquer at least one.
Poppy is also out in play as well by
Lynn. And Poppy has that deflect
ability. And when they play, if an
opponent score is within three points of
victory score, Ready me and gain three
experience. That is not the case, of
course. Four is more than three.
>> Yeah. No, four is four.
>> Four is four.
>> Four is four away from victory point. So
not within that three-point threshold
from Poppy Paragon there as we do see
the alt art version on the base of Lin's
Algra here. But we see both of these
players considering their options. Disco
Jesus
>> seven runes up right now. I can't
believe doesn't have a full spread of
old art runes. What is this normal body
rune doing in Disco Jesus? Someone get
that man an old art rune. That is a good
point. But those alt runes that have
been released with unleash look
absolutely incredible. Out comes that
pit rookie aspir onto aspirants climb.
>> Yeah, aspirin's climb really loves to
increase the points of these games.
Taking it to nine conquest points.
>> That was a one thing I was double
checking as well. That means that we
want to be on the odd numbers. So that
five is really important. Yeah, five,
seven, and nine with Aspirin's climb
increasing the windcon up to that nine
points here. So, Disco Jesus looking to
conquer that, get that hold going, but
this is set moving in onto the top
battlefield.
>> Hidden blade gets revealed and L is
going to be hidden blading the recruit
instead being able to draw two off of
that recruit. Now, of course, Rift
Herald is still there on the point,
which is quite a mighty unit and
actually will in fact go to the trash
will be taken out, which does mean, as
you said, that Death Nell is going to
trigger. We do love a good Death Nell
here. Death Nell has definitely risen as
a mechanic in Unleashed. Obviously LMBL
being one of those ones that really
leans quite heavily into it, but that
set brawler big and nasty eight might
unit sitting there on that sunken temple
battlefield. So we do see challenge come
out going to be targeting the Poppy
which does mean that Poppy is now in the
trash challenge when you target you
choose a a friendly unit and an enemy
unit and they deal equal um damage to
their might to each other. So that does
mean that Poppy is now in the trash and
out comes that set.
>> Yeah, but he did have to pay that
deflect cost as well. So that was an
expensive challenge, but I would say it
is still a high value challenge removing
that unit from Lynn's board there. And
Lynn currently struggling to develop.
There it is. Dazzling Aurora.
>> There is the Dazzling Aurora that Lynn
needs. I wonder how many turns he had to
go through to find that in his hand
because this feels like it's a little
bit quite late game, later than probably
Lynn is wanting. Dazzling Aurora, of
course, at the end of your turn, reveal
cards from the top of your main deck
until you reveal a unit. Play it,
ignoring its cost. We all know where
Dazzling Aurora is. And uh now maybe
Lynn can come back for it. But is it too
little too late?
>> Yeah, definitely. He's just hard
slammed. And there's the Elder Dragon
right here. Elder Dragon, when you play,
you get to deal, you basically get to
execute a unit on every location.
>> Yeah, when you play me, choose up to one
enemy unit at each location, dealing one
to them. But critically, any amount of
your damage is enough to kill enemy
units. So, it is a great sort of minor I
want to say like a small board clear
here. He did ping two of those units
down. It will be up to Disco Jesus. How
does he respond to this? We is in body
and order. He does have salvages which
could still hit it. And there it is.
>> It completely nullifies that or a
salvage. You make a gear and you get to
draw one. So Disco J is still in the I
guess playing seat right now.
>> Yeah, he's absolutely still in driver's
seat. Yes, that is an elder dragon on
the board, but he's currently at six
points to Lind's one. This is a 9-point
game. As a reminder that Aspirin's climb
likes to drag these games out just a
little bit longer. Disco Jesus finding
himself at that seven. Moves in that
first mate going to eight. He hasn't won
it just yet.
>> Yeah, sitting on eight now. All he needs
to do is just hold one of these
battlefields. So, Lynn has to try and
get him off both of these battlefields.
So Disco now just building up his
defenses or potentially looking to close
it out in the next turn again.
>> Yeah, that elder dragon though nothing
to sort of shake your tail feather at if
you will. It is a 10 might unit that any
amount of damage it deals or any amount
of damage any of your things deal. Just
kill your enemy's units. That sort of
sea monkey there being played to the
Elder moving in. Elder moves and
completely of course gets rid of that
first mate and that means that Lynn is
now on two points but that's such a long
climb to go. So I mean two to eight
that's a six point difference.
>> Yeah but Aurora decks have been here
before. They love the late game and
we're looking at a hard cast of a big
unit judging by how many runes Lena's
Algra was just counting up there. Oh,
it's going to be the armory, which is a
gear. You can use it and you can bring
yourself out more recruits.
>> That's it. And hitting that sunken
temple would have been great. Pay that
one energy to draw that card too there,
Ricey. And all he has to do is swing
these recruits in because one point of
damage is to kill whatever's there.
>> That Elder Dragon ability is so strong,
especially with these recruits. Maybe
that is why they're running this
Vanguard Armory. And out come these uh
recruits. Going to put one in base, one
next to the Elder Dragon. Wondering
where the third one's going to just
going to go back into the base again.
>> That's it. Just building up that base,
building up those units, send them to
wherever he needs to send them to keep
clearing Disco Jesus off of these
battlefields.
>> Call the week is out now. Disco Jesus is
forced to of course call one of their
units and Lynn theoretically is going to
be calling their recruit. I wouldn't
call the Elder Dragon personally.
>> Yeah, I'm like theoretically either.
>> Can you imagine?
But like obviously in like chaos and
body they have like last rights, they
have morbid return.
>> They have all sorts of ways to bring it
back from the trash, but not so here in
a body and order style Aurora that is
Poppy.
>> Don't also forget Disco Jesus set the
boss's legend ability as well. You can
save some units with exhausting that
legend. I believe that might be what set
did just there. The legend is exhausted.
>> Yeah. So set brawler moves in towards
that aspirin's climb. Just looking to
get that card draw there.
>> Looking for that card draw. Of course,
once you're one point away from winning,
you're not able to win with a conquer
alone. You have to conquer both
battlefields or hold. So getting that
extra card draw is pretty exciting. And
>> that was very sportsmanlike conduct.
>> Yeah, looks like set was not exhausted.
The boss is still in play. When a buffed
unit you control would die, you may pay
one power and exhaust me to spend his
buff and recall it exhausted instead.
>> Yeah, but the sportsman like conduct I
want to point out is Lyn's Allegra
actually reached over and untapped Disco
Jesus's set saying, "Hey, you forgot
that mate. You got to make sure you
untap." You love to see it. Absolutely
sportsmanship at its finest there
because that is a significant legend
ability, Ricey.
>> It really is. It's such a strong save, a
life-saving ability in fact. And now set
the brawler has been buffed by removing
the buff. And out comes another
challenge going to be targeting.
>> Yeah,
>> I think the Elder Dragon did.
>> And so now comes the sacrifice.
>> Yeah, targeting the elder.
>> It's targeting the outer dragon.
>> Yeah. So you can target it with that
sacrifice before that challenge
resolves. You can actually get resources
off of that elder. So sacrifice at
reaction speed as an additional cost to
play this. Kill a friendly mighty unit,
which an elder absolutely is. Draw two.
Channel one run exhausted.
>> This might be game using that hidden
blade to take down the final recruit.
That will mean Disco Jesus goes and
takes over Sunken Temple, claiming both
battlefields and claiming this match in
a two0 fashion.
>> That's it. Game two goes over to Disco
Jesus as did game one. wins a 200 sweep
here in the round five featured matchup
set versus Poppy. That was a very body
very order fight there and it was great
to see and our first sort of dazzling
Aurora deck of the day.
>> I I feel like that's something most
Aurora players do like where was my
other Aurora? Where was it? I could just
see him looking trying to find it
through the deck. But of course it was
in fact not the Aurora that won. It was
the set. But we have more Riftbound for
you guys later. Make sure you guys stay
tuned after this break.
>> Welcome to Riftbound Basics. This time
we are talking about legends, chosen
champions, and signature spells. The
heart of your deck is your legend. This
determines which domains you are allowed
to play in your deck. Let's take Kaisa,
daughter of the void, as an example.
With her as your legend, you can play
cards from the fury and mind domains and
consequently fury and mind runes. You
also have the option to play a chosen
champion unit, Kaisa survivor or Kaiser
evolutionary. At the start of the game,
you can take this unit from your main
deck and place it in the chosen champion
unit zone right next to your legend. You
can play this card from this zone at any
time as if it were a normal card from
your hand. If it dies, it does not
return to the zone, but goes to the
trash. Another important factor in
deciding which legend to play is the
signature card. Even if the domains
match, you can only play this card in
the main deck of the corresponding
legend. For Kaiser, this would be
Atheian Rain, which you couldn't play in
a rumble deck, even though it's also
fury and mind. Which legend do you like
best? And is there one you only play
because their signature spell is so
good? Let us know in the comments.
Welcome back everyone to coverage of
regional qualifier Sydney. We are
getting through the rounds at this
point. I'm Julian Pat. That is still
Steph Panicasio. Round six is where we
find ourselves now.
>> Round six. It feels again like
everything is happening so quickly and
yet so slow. And here we are. Round six.
Basically at the tail end of the day,
getting closer to the end now. But
everything has been so exciting that I
still have a lot of energy. Hopefully so
do you.
>> Last I checked, we had 12 undefeated
players coming into that last round.
Obviously going to have fewer now.
Starting to narrow down the field, but
uh some pretty big names still towards
the top. I saw Allen still undefeated
after last round. I saw Colin Kaiser
still undefeated last round. And of
course we know Dwali who's on stream
just around ago still undefeated and of
course some local heroes in amongst it
as well. So still some pretty curious
diversity actually among the legends
that are there. So lots to look out for.
It was also really nice to see Leona
late in the day.
>> I'm not even on Yeah,
>> there you go.
>> Fine. It's fine. I'm not mad.
>> You're very chill about it.
>> I'm not mad. Yeah, very mad actually.
>> Yeah. Uh you know what? Leona did get
some tools in set three. So perhaps
we'll see Leona make it through today
too for the deck that was cursed for a
very long time. But we're going to
settle in on an upcoming match up cuz I
believe this is something that you're
quite familiar with.
>> Oh yeah. Oh yeah. Look, I am an Aurora
defender.
>> That's fine. I am and I will stand for
it and I'm very excited to see because
as we were discussing earlier in the day
there has been a very very high
representation of Aurora day one. Very
very excited to see how it's shaping up
at this stage of the day.
>> Not sure how well it will convert but I
guess we'll find out. We'll certainly
have some players
>> with that strategy looking good but when
we have the deck this will bring them up
for you and just uh have a squeeze of
what we are going to be playing this
round. Uh I will say you know there's
lots of interesting legends. There was
undefeated teamer from the last round.
Still there's a lot of lot of little
critters running around, but uh we're
going to have the big units this time
around. Oh, not for now. It's set to
kick things off. SW2588.
>> Yet another undefeated set.
>> Mhm. Look, I mean, I didn't expect to
see this many, but I'm very, very
impressed.
>> Yeah, sacrifice certainly a one of the
big additions to order in general. And
obviously Set and Fiora both like making
units pretty big. Uh make them mighty
even. And when you do that, you can
sacrifice them and potentially draw some
cards to get some resources. So, pretty
good stuff. off as you are going to be
on the other side. This is where you
wanted to start. Rambo's leg, our MF
Aurora player. And if you haven't heard
already, every single MF deck in the
field is also an Aurora deck.
>> Understandable. And we're seeing a lot
of completely understandable things
here. Obviously, we have our mobilizers,
our stack decks. Getting that Aurora out
as pos soon as possible. Bullet time.
I'm very excited to see how this goes.
>> What do you think of that unit split?
Three L1 Baron. Not the split I would
expect.
>> Yeah, look, I mean, I can understand why
fewer baronss. I think it's it's fair
enough. I run one in my deck.
>> Three elders though. Interesting.
>> Yeah, kind of all in. But uh can't argue
with Bergus, I suppose, cuz Rambo is 5
going into this round. And oh my
goodness, someone is actually playing
Valley of Idols. When you play a unit
here, you may pay one when you do buff
that unit. And yes, I know what that
does because I was looking at it for
Leona. I'm pretty sure. Mobilize going
to kick things off though for
Misfortune, which is kind of where you
want to be on turn number one.
Absolutely.
>> Get yourself an extra rune.
>> Yeah, look, if if you were going to use
Valley of Idols anytime, set seems like
a good time to do it.
>> Don't worry about the other things you
could potentially debuff your units, you
know, just a little valley action. And
of course, Set pretty resilient. We
actually just saw Set at the tail end of
round five uh blitz through a popular
Aurora player, so it certainly is
possible, but these Chaos AO decks can
be pretty tricky. and five runes as you
to the sweet spot to play. Catalyst
don't see it in hand though.
>> I know. Interesting.
All right, we got stack deck. Seeing
what we can get there.
Okay,
>> having a peek.
>> Not necessarily what you'd want.
>> Yeah, not going to be able to slam the
Aurora on turn three. That's kind of the
dream
>> for a lot of these decks.
>> Absolutely. But uh having a peek picking
a Gust I believe which seems like a
pretty sensible card early on trying to
stave off your opponent's point gain.
Notably is also an aspirants climb game.
Got so excited to read the Valley of
Idols text from memory that it is going
to be a climb game which makes sense for
a deck that does want to trigger Aurora
a number of times. Basically the more
times you trigger Aurora usually the
better spot your deck is in. So playing
tonight does make a lot of sense when
you do want some extra time to kind of
get set up. It's also good to see the
scriers bloom from unleashed. Good to
see that happening in here.
>> All righty. In we go. See going to make
it happen. That shepherd's handling
turning off the gust actually. Obviously
SW doesn't know that that was there but
does do a pretty good job as first make
a reset r ready and effectively move to
see monkey back. Bit of shortcutting
happening there but uh all well that
ends well as looks like rainbow is just
trying to make sure exactly what
happened. Yeah,
>> they do get a window though. Actually,
>> it's a reaction. So, you do get a window
with the first mate trigger. Wouldn't
get an action window, but happy to
basically discard and draw a couple
more. That gust no longer needed. So,
Luna Boon discard one, draw two.
Something we actually expected to see a
bit more in Diana, but I don't think any
of the lists are really playing it, but
an ejector wants to dig for kind of a
pretty small subset of cards. Makes a
lot of sense.
>> Definitely makes a lot of sense in
Aurora as well. Really trying to get it
out as soon as possible.
>> All righty. Scri Bloom. This is another
one where these uh Chaos Aurora decks
were pretty happy to have another card
that just filters through the top of
your deck and tries to draw a card.
Again, the name of the game is draw
Aurora and put the Elder Dragons on the
bottom. And that is one of the cards I
can see that is being uh predicted.
>> Yes.
>> So, those are going to go on the bottom.
I have to imagine unless you want a
catalyst, there is one that's going to
be kept. So, recycle one, put one on the
top, and then maybe draw one.
You effectively get to draw the card if
you leave it on top. It's not exactly
how it works, but that's basically what
happens at the end of it. Yeah.
>> Get an XP as well, which I don't think
is very relevant, but it's fun to it's
fun to remember
>> is catalyst.
>> So, we're going to commit. Going to have
the runes for for certain.
>> Yep, there we go.
>> But uh missing uh missing the other half
of the equation, we can say.
>> Haven't seen an Aurora just yet.
>> Look, it happens sometimes.
Unfortunately, luck of the draw really
does get those Aurora players. I can say
from experience. Uh but yeah, look, it
is what it is on these ones. You really
want to hope that you can get it that
early, but there are other ways to
adapt. We will see. Pretty confident
that set does have a point as well.
Don't think that's currently marked on
our overlay, but uh did get ready by
first mid and retreat and now back to
the valley for what I believe is point
number two in this game. So again,
Aurora, the kind of deck where you're
kind of on the clock, right? Uh they're
big scary units. those elder dragons. Uh
those baronss are pretty tough to
contend with. Even if it's just dead
blooms and mine spplitters, that's also
quite tricky.
>> So want to get your points early and
often if you can. And it is an aspirin
climb game. So looking for odd point
totals and I believe set is now up to
three after using that first mate. And
wandering on down to the climb now.
Going to reinforce with Poppy from the
hand.
>> Interesting.
>> So carrying a little bit about XP, but
does doesn't have that much to play with
here. Right now, it's just basically a
a big unit with deflect, which is good
enough sometimes in set.
>> Absolutely. Look, I mean, they're
getting a decent presence on the board
and still no Aurora. It's it's a good
position to be in by now.
>> And again, all the all the little spells
that kind of interact early, things like
Gust obviously can't hit units that are
this big.
>> You challenge sometimes in Aurora as a
way to uh fight off with other units and
win combats, but obviously you need
units to do that. And I have to imagine
those decks have maybe issued that card
with Elder Dragon Elder Dragon being
added.
>> A lot of them definitely have. Yeah,
look, I mean to have nothing on board at
this point in time, not ideal.
>> There is still plenty of hope. There is
still a lot to see how this rocks out,
but having that kind of presence is not
easy when you have not landed that
Aurora yet.
>> It's all not almost all the runes. 11 on
the table.
>> Six body, five chaos, which is
hilariously not enough to actually cast
an elder dragon. So mobilize going to
get the final one here.
>> Let's hope.
>> And mobilize again.
>> Oh yeah,
>> card instead.
>> See what happens.
>> Boom again. Another way to look, but
that one comes in exhausted. Going to
have to wait another turn. So how do you
navigate the non- Aurora games in Aurora
then?
>> Look, I mean I I navigate them with
grace, obviously. First of all, I'm very
very calm and collected. Look, I mean,
it's it's frustrating. It's not going to
be something that I think well, look, a
lot of players are coming into this
knowing that almost everybody has gear
hate in hand to be able to handle this
cuz we did know that Aurora would be
such a dominant presence. There are
still ways around it. I don't know that
necessarily having three elder dragons
would have been my choice for this. I
think I probably would have opted to
diversify my units a little bit more and
try and figure out another way in there.
I do think I would probably still run
the exact same amount, mobilize. I like
Scriers's Bloom. It It is frustrating to
have that waiting period for it, but you
got to do what you got to do.
>> Yeah, I think uh Elder Dragon just
natty, let's say, wouldn't be so bad on
this board. Although set does complicate
a little bit. Usually good at saving at
least one unit with a buff. And dragon's
a big unit, but it's not it's not the
biggest ever challenge going to be used
here to uh fight that poor misfortune
that just got played from the chosen
champion because, you know, wasn't
anything else to do and the only unit
Aurora had is now going to the rubbish
bin.
>> This is not a good place to be in as an
Aurora player. I can uh I can see that
there is definitely some uh
constonnation on the face there of
Rambo, but we shall see.
>> Double checking points as well. is Fay
Dragon. This is an absolute banger.
>> Promo Fay Dragon. Very nice looking
card. This one is a buff up to four
friendly units when you play me. It's a
seven energy, one power unit with seven
might,
>> but uh you know, not bad for the cost in
a deck that wants a bunch of buffs.
Also, when you spend a buff, you play a
gold gear token exhausted. I'm going to
be honest with you, I did not know that
was text on this card because never been
relevant in a second game I've
commentated.
>> That's fair. Yeah, look, I mean, if it
comes down to it, you've got that in
pocket, but yeah, usually really just
line one thing.
>> Yeah. So, even an elder at this point,
right? If uh if Rambo just wanted to
play one, if you did draw one, he could,
>> uh it would kill zero units. It would
deal one damage to one of those four
units and then set would save them.
>> Yeah. All right, there we go.
>> Pack of wanders. Treasure trove of a
little warmbo combo as the kids say.
>> Wombo combo indeed. Hoping for the best
there.
>> Only good for drawing a card this time
around. doesn't need the ramp as again
all the runes from the rune deck.
>> Stack deck again.
>> 1 2 three. Looking for one thing and one
thing only. And that is still maybe one.
>> Nope. There's bullet time.
>> Yep. Last rights and a catalyst.
>> Goodness. Yeah, this is super unlucky on
the draw for an Aurora player.
>> Rambo leg got to be feeling a little
tense right now.
>> I will say like little things impress me
here. Like I like set retreating all the
units, right? even though it's not
threatening a win cuz uh seven is not
two points away from nine which is the
points where we're playing towards this
game. But I think just retreating your
units in case there was an elder dragon
whether it's from hand or from Aurora
just protecting your units making sure
units are stacked in a location when you
do have a points lead that is this big
>> feels like one of those little things
but I think a play pattern that players
have probably started to adjust to given
that el has been kind of running around
quite a lot as catalyst going to be good
for a couple draws here.
>> Absolutely.
Unfortunately, it's usually not what you
play the card for.
>> Yeah,
>> look, this is this is not particularly
heartening for Aurora.
>> It's it's not nice to have to play an
Elder Dragon natural. It's it's just a
bit rough.
>> I mean, I think in on this board
especially, I think on your average
board, if you killed two or three units,
you might be okay on a set board
>> in there. This one a little bit more
complicated. All right, Fay Dragon
moving in onto the climb for a point.
Going to move on in up top lane as well.
Poppy's going to move in for a point.
>> And then I'm curious what happens next
cuz I feel like some wisdom says you
don't you want to leave your units in
two locations
>> or one against Elder Dragon. You don't
really want to leave them in three. And
that's exactly what SW does. All the
units stuck on the battlefield and say,
"You know what? If I hold from here, I
win. What do you have?" because Elder
Dragon isn't even good enough here.
>> Yeah, look at this point you've got to
be feeling pretty confident.
>> Sometimes you do get some non games as
it were on Aurora and certainly
navigating these tricky games when you
don't have access to that very powerful
piece of gear is valuable.
>> Look, that's one of the reasons I
maintain my status as an Aurora
defender. It doesn't always end up going
your way with the card draw. And when it
doesn't work out, it doesn't work out a
lot of the time. You really have to have
those strategies to be able to work
around it when something like this
happens. And it's just unfortunately not
>> Oh, there we go. This late in the piece.
Not ideal.
>> Unfortunately, uh I think Elder Dragon's
going to kill one unit thanks ability.
There's at least two units on both these
battlefields. And uh unless you can
clear one fully
>> going to hold for a win here. And
honestly, even the recalled unit is
going to threaten to reconquer even if
you do clear a single battlefield. So
mathematically, I don't think there is a
way for Elder Dragon to get the job done
here. And that's if you hit the Elder,
by the way, cuz if you hit the Baron, it
is comically bad in this situation.
>> Yeah, look, here's here we go. What's it
going to be?
>> You know, there's one elder on the
bottom, so it's slightly more likely.
It's closer to two versus one. There's
the Elder.
>> There we go.
>> But again, you just
>> It's just not going to be enough at this
point.
>> All right, we'll see what they want to
target. We'll go through the motions as
it were. I don't know if there's
anything else in Rambo's hand that could
maybe help here. But again, set in
particular, such a tough legend to kick
things off battlefields with. There's
the sea monkey hiding under that
shepherd's tail. There's a Poppy hiding
under those buffs.
>> And there's a pay dragon and a first
mate. Everyone's buffed, by the way,
including that set that just magically
snuck himself there onto the battlefield
that I didn't notice last turn.
But just having a look, having a point.
Sea monkey and Oh no. Is there more? How
is there more?
>> Sacrifice. Oh, that's just rude
>> at this point.
>> That's really just rude. Just drawing a
couple cards.
>> It's like, which one are you targeting?
No. Sacrifice it.
>> Sacrifice this thing. Draw a couple
cards. Ooh, of blades. That is very
good.
>> Interesting.
>> So, this one will probably bring it up
cuz you don't see this one too often,
although certainly something that Elder
Dragon uh did kind of bring to the
forefront. This one I believe is deal
one damage to all units at battlefields
>> if I recall correctly.
>> Yep.
>> And this one when elder dragons in play
is real punishing.
>> Oh yeah.
>> So set me kind of deciding when we get
to choose set.
>> Both of these are reactions hilariously.
Flurry is going to happen again.
>> So it looks like that is Oh interesting.
>> That makes
think that
>> prevents set from saving a unit cuz the
unit's going to get recalled back to
base.
So, I don't think double flurry kills a
unit here. You don't lose because your
opponent only has one unit at the end of
this. They get to choose which one they
save.
>> You can pick which buff you want to
spend on set as it were.
>> So, I imagine a Fay Dragon is going to
lose its buff, but keep its life,
>> but they will prevent Rambo from losing
this next turn.
>> Look, it's an admirable attempt.
>> Definitely a little bit of discussion
over how this is going to resolve. I
think I believe
>> Rambo is just asking
>> basically when does set happen
>> and I believe the answer is set is
basically effect you get to pick
>> when
>> place it as you see fit
>> did you try and save the no the sea
monkeyy's in the bin so he didn't try
and save the sacrifice unit
>> no
>> I don't even think you can do that
actually
>> so we're just going to go through flurry
here flurry plus elder very powerful
this is one of the reasons to not stack
the battlefield by the way
>> mhm
>> in by trying to avoid elder
by moving units to the minimum number of
locations you could use to win, which in
this case was both battlefields. You
open yourself up to flurry. So
definitely an exchange that
you could play differently, but you
can't play around everything. And I
think uh Set's choice made a lot of
sense to me as the players are going to
resolve their dodge call by the looks of
things.
>> Yeah, look, I think this would have
played out very differently were it not
up against Set. But I mean, as as far as
ways around not hitting the Aurora until
this late, I mean, it might be enough.
We'll see.
>> At least it wasn't the Baron.
>> Baron would have ended the game on the
spot.
>> Been rough
>> and and not in a good way.
>> That is almost 100% the reason why I've
only got one. And even then, who's to
say I think a lot of people are just
running the one at the moment, if at
all. I think people are opting for more
of the mind splitters. But it's
interesting to see again earlier today
we've seen a lot of unconventional
bruise and seeing how people are making
their decks a little bit more difficult
to predict in this qualifier. So maybe
there will be somebody out there who
does it a little differently.
>> Yeah, Aurora definitely a deck that
benefits a lot from you kind of
successfully solving the deck building
puzzle for the metag game.
>> I know uh Ali who's uh over down I guess
over from the states. Mhm.
>> managed to find a way to come to RQ
Sydney after winning the best of Civ in
Atlanta on of course Aurora. This was
before Unleashed uh the deck that Ali's
been playing pretty much since Origins.
>> Yeah, pretty much
>> had uh had a lot of words about which
unit composition you should play in a
deck like and it is a real choice and
certainly when you expect a decent
amount of the mirror, certainly when you
expect players to be prepared for your
strategy.
>> Absolutely.
>> Which units you use, which units you
play. I know uh we had a chat yesterday
to Villionaire, one of the challenger
TCG boys who's big Volbear Aurora fan.
>> Yes.
>> And I'm pretty confident one of the
reasons he likes Volibear more is that
Volibear is just also a ramp deck
>> by nature.
>> And you can just play a lot of your
units if you don't hit Aurora.
>> And you might as well at that point.
It's going to be putting you in a very
very different position to where you're
at here. But I mean, look, I I feel like
because everybody knows, all of the
Aurora players probably know that people
are strategizing specifically for this
type. It's one of those things where if
you aren't prepared to be able to
address the fact that people will be
targeting it, then really it's it's on
you, you know. have a quick read of set
in just a moment, but I'm pretty
confident.
I know roughly what the legend text
does. And I I believe our set player SW
here is capable
>> of picking which unit effective they
want to save cuz they're all going to
take lethal damage in effect from this
flurry of blades. I don't think the
second flurry does anything. And it
looks like the players have resolved
>> whatever question they had to the
judges. So sacrifice is happening. Fade
dragon, as I expected, did get saved.
>> Makes sense. And uh we are kind of back
in business as the turn has passed back
over. Our game's not going to end on
board as it is right now. Fay Dragon can
get point number eight, but we are
climbing up to nine this game.
>> Let's see a showstopper. See a first
mate.
No way to give the fate dragon ganging,
but there is a Fiora
>> lurking around.
And when she gets mighty,
boy oh boy,
>> boy oh boy indeed. It is still a little
hard to see the cards in hand for Rambo
Slag. I mean, keeping them close to the
chest, understandable, but there's a
little peak.
>> Here's Showstopper set signature spell.
>> Mhm.
>> Buff move on over that makes Fiora
mighty. Turns on all her abilities as
bullet time.
>> Bullet time
>> again. Trying to get the elder dragon
train rolling. pretty much has to play a
bunch of reactions
constantly to try and keep uh SW from
scoring enough at this point.
>> But that again is going to just
basically
recycle a rune and have Fiora lose her
buff.
>> So paying one I have to assume here with
bullet time costs one energy but you pay
uh basically power equal to how much
damage you want to deal. M
>> you can think of it actually quite a lot
like blade flow which we just saw but
only works at one battlefield.
>> I mean when there's only one that has
units at it right now that's all that
matters.
>> Certainly is.
>> You can of course scale the damage by
spending more power but not something
the elder dragon deck is really that
interested in doing.
>> No
>> as set is basically going to permanently
stay exhausted. I think didn't quite get
awakened just turn but we all know it's
ready to go.
>> So a little shortcutting there as buff
comes off. Fiora gets saved, but the
Showstopper, which would have been game
ending alongside the first mate that we
know is in hand,
>> is going to have to wait a while. Maybe
wait another turn to try and turn this
game around.
>> And uh the eighth the eighth point
doesn't feel that valuable as Fior is
going to get ready. Going to bas going
to basically make the play we wanted to
make earlier, but no way to regain over.
Can no actually cannot buff on Valley.
That one's only on play.
>> All right, so looking for point number
eight. Why not make him have one more
spell perhaps?
>> Looking very Yep, that's that's going to
result.
>> Oh, okay. Just actually reset set.
>> Interesting.
>> No way to buff a unit right now, though.
Just going to pass it on back. And we
know the card in hand, which I think it
was correct not to play.
>> Not very helpful. Just a warm armor.
>> All right, let's see.
Big dragon.
>> Big big dragon.
>> Can uh hit the the classic pack of
wonders. Want to pick up the elder and
replay it just for a little extra board
clear action. Don't know if I recommend
it, but it is a play you're allowed to
make.
>> I don't know that I would necessarily be
doing that right now.
>> You don't think you want to pay uh four
orange par recycle another rune deflect?
Actually, doesn't have deflect right
now, so you wouldn't actually have to
pay that cost. I thought maybe
shepherd's alien would get re-equipped.
>> Still just on the little bit too
expensive side for me.
>> Could be. Treasure trove. Looks like
pack of wonders is going to do the other
thing which is draw a card and
>> channel another rune exhausted whenever
it leaves the battlefield. Uh you're
supposed to recycle a rune, exhaust it,
and then kill it in order to get that
effect. But if you just pick it up with
the pack, you get much the same effect.
>> Mhm.
Now, what is going to result here?
>> I mean, Aurora is going to happen again.
It's now a 50/50 between Baron and Elder
Dragon. And Rambo will know that cuz he
knew an Elder went to the bottom in the
mulligan.
>> Absolutely.
>> Pack of again. Treasure Trove again.
>> More card draw. Got to be careful. You
don't want to draw your units. Yeah,
look, it's it's not ideal to be at this
point, but I mean, credit to Rambo for
being able to adapt as much as possible
given the circumstances. We get another
sky bloom.
>> Have to imagine there's
one more spell in hand that's relevant
here.
>> You would think
>> just with the way we're playing.
Otherwise, I would imagine trying to
hold onto a battlefield a little bit
more. I mean face up if you can't
actually even if you do push Fiora off
this battlefield
>> uh still going to lose.
>> There we go
>> to double conquer. So now Elder Dragon's
going to push off Fiora. Win that combat
pretty effortlessly.
>> Yeah, look that one's not really uh not
really a surprise there.
>> And at least put some might on that
battlefield again.
>> Some
>> Yeah, 10.
>> Just some. But if there's more
>> again, everyone reading Valley of Vitals
for the first time perhaps. Certainly, I
can't imagine MF had gone into it too
many times. So, pass Aurora Trigger. Is
it going to be Elder Dragon the second
or is it going to be Baron Nasher the
first? There's Baron.
>> It's Baron. Ah,
>> time to make the pit. That's a point.
>> That is a point. H interesting. So, this
does actually create a pretty
interesting wrinkle
>> because now
>> SW can no longer win by conquering two
battlefields.
>> Yes, you have to conquer
>> have to get all three.
>> It does make it a little bit more
contentious. Now, I look, as I said
earlier, I don't necessarily feel that
Baron is always the most useful. At the
moment, this isn't that bad. I mean, I
don't know how easy it would have been
for Set to push this Elder Dragon off
the valley, but certainly if you're
trying to basically lock your opponent
out of the final point for the whole
game, which is actually what you have to
do at this point.
>> Uh, I actually think making a third
battlefield and effectively turning off
conquering as a win condition does feel
pretty good here.
>> So, first mate going to conquer, but
that point cannot win. So, instead it
will draw a card. And I think at this
point SW is like, uh, I have to hold to
win this game.
>> 100%. And and look, I mean, when you're
81, you you would normally be feeling a
lot more confident. You probably still
are, but it is an interesting
arrangement that we've got up here at
the moment.
>> I spy finally MF player's hand, by the
way. And there is an Elder Dragon in
>> there is interesting.
>> Not ideal for the Aurora, but
>> one more in the deck as well we can get.
But again,
>> that's right at the bottom, isn't it?
>> Yeah, it is. I mean, it's fine. You'll
find it.
>> You'll find it. It's in there.
>> It'll take a minute, but
>> Okay, so interestingly, not overstacking
the climb.
>> Not even putting a second unit there.
Although, I guess Por getting played to
base doesn't preclude Fay Dragon from
moving over, but looks like the turn has
been nope, not passed back just yet.
Shepherd's heirloom getting considered
here. And look to equip the Fay Dragon.
It looks like Fay Dragon trying to pick
a fight. Yes, it is. Oh my goodness.
>> 8 9 10 11. Is that have been enough?
>> I don't think. Look, as I'm not great at
maths, but that doesn't seem like enough
to me.
>> More than 10.
>> Oh, but plus two from Baron. Oh no. Did
we forget?
>> Oh.
>> Oh no. I think we forgot that Baron gave
plus two. The D is on the unit.
>> Oh my gosh. Of course. Yeah, that's
that's not good.
>> It's late in the day, folks. Round six.
Goodbye to that FA dragon.
>> Playing still to keep your record
unblenmished to the Swiss. And it is
grueling. Little clerical error in the
math there from our set player. And
Elder Dragon gets to eat a Fay Dragon
for free.
>> Yum, yum, yum.
>> Four points now for our Aurora player.
This Elder Dragon is coming through.
>> Elder Dragon.
>> Two more units are going to go by the
wayside. Set's going to save one of
them, but it's just a lowly first mate.
>> Oh, this is turning around very quickly.
the dragon who reinforced that
battlefield
>> and that other friendly units text on
Baron Asher
>> proving to be quite potent as Baron
shifts on over to the aspirants climb
make it five points and all of a sudden
at three points a turn looking like
quite a quick clip to try and end this
game and this elder is going to finally
kill this first mate
>> and there we go
>> reinforce send on over Warmog's going to
stay there and I think there might have
been a window to try and win this game,
but I think that door has been closed.
>> Absolutely. I mean, look, if nothing
else, it just goes to show that even
when you do have that delayed Aurora, it
can turn around. And having those Elder
Dragons, it's it's just look, they are
very strong. There's no way around that.
There's still plenty of options. And in
this situation, having Baron did
actually make a difference.
>> Yeah. So, couple things maybe worth
noting there. For one, obviously players
don't know each other's deck list right
now. You can you can make some
assumptions about what is in the deck as
Rambo's leg does take game one. Pretty
dramatic comeback
>> down literally with no points left to
give back and did manage to find the win
there. Players actually just scooping up
despite not technically losing on the
following turn. Would have been n
impossible to crack through those
battlefields. So saving some time,
shuffling up for game number two
instead. You might need it given how
that game went. Yeah, look, I mean,
given that it did take that extra time
to get there, I do think that it does
come down to the draw a lot of the time,
but being able to adapt. O,
>> but again, you don't know the monster
mix, so maybe you could reasonably
assume that it is three elders and a
Baron after seeing one Baron and two
elders,
>> it makes sense. It makes sense. I think
you are far more likely to assume at
that point, yeah, there's going to more
likely be the third elder. I don't think
that many people are running multiple
barons.
>> I think especially after the first flip,
you know, there's at least probably all
the elders in this
>> uh in for game one at least.
>> So, if you're at that point, if you're
at that junction, you know, you need 1
to it does feel like stacking one
battlefield with at least two units and
trying to win by holding would make
sense. Obviously, if they only have an
elder, uh that is something you can win
pretty comfortably.
>> Yeah.
>> Although, Baron have to double check.
Does Baron have ganking? Cuz he did make
his way over to the climb somehow. That
means he has to leave the pit.
>> Ran's got a lot of text on it, folks. I
don't know if you've ever read that
card.
>> Well, the thing is misfortune.
>> Ah, gives very possible.
>> One of the reasons to play MF as your
legend is of course the ganking that
Misfortune grants. Sorry, I forgot there
was a legend that was relevant. That's
happens sometimes with XE. You can just
ignore all the other text because
they're so focused around their singular
gear, but not so there was a reason to
choose Misfortune over Civer just as an
example. I do feel that Baron does sit
far more comfortably in the MF decks for
that exact reason.
>> Yep, that makes a lot of sense.
>> So, uh that would mean that actually you
would need enough units to survive the
Baron and to be able to survive the
elbow. So, does seem tough
>> to hold a battlefield. I don't know if
there's another reasonable route at that
point in the game once it was Baron that
was flipped up because
it is just so hard to actually conquer
enough battlefields when there is an
extra one that you now have to get that
is being occupied by something whose
minimum might is 10.
>> Exactly. It's it's just such an extra
challenge when you're already contending
with the Elder Dragons as it is and you
anticipate more to come. It's Yeah,
>> it's it's definitely changing the tides.
>> All right. Well, players going to laugh
it off and we are going to shuffle up
for game number two. Certainly feels
like set has the source in this matchup.
>> Oh, for sure. And again, as we've
discussed, it does come down to draw a
lot of the time for that Aurora. And now
that we know what's there, it'll be
interesting to see what gets sideboarded
in.
>> Yeah, I think the other thing and the
thing I was going to actually say
partway through uh that first game was
that Ooh, that's a very good mulligan.
There's an Aurora and a Baron and an
Elder
>> in that hand. So, the two units go to
the bottom and we'll keep on keep the
card we always want to play as often as
we can.
>> But that does mean that the gear hate if
it wasn't in the main
>> certainly going to be on the board. We
can spy a salvage already there
>> in SW's hand.
>> Look, you got to do it.
>> I like the little eyebrow raise there
for me, but oh, no two drop.
Interesting.
>> Wonder what you kept.
>> So, we've got Monastery of Hana and Vile
Moore's Lair this time around.
Monastery obviously kind of a mainstay
of set one of the best arguably his best
battlefield.
>> Whenever you conquer here it may spend a
buff if you do draw a card. Not a lot of
buffs running around although a few more
now since unleashed got added
>> but certainly not a battlefield that
Aurora is going to be able to find any
card draw on. So kind of just something
that only set and set alone gets to use
in this matchup as double scriers bloom
gets deployed after the stack deck. A
very neat little curve as SW passes
back. No units to play right now. Big
Ringar in hand in the middle.
>> Mhm. And then the Vile Mosair obviously
also making it so set cannot move back.
Retreating to base. It does make it so
that you do have to go up against those
real big boys.
>> Certainly do.
Stuck in a deck that has a decent amount
of movement in it.
>> Can be a bit frustrating. Also,
obviously Aurora is just really wanting
to park their units at the battlefields
for the most part. Absolutely.
>> Don't really mind that you can't move.
Wasn't really planning on moving anyway.
>> Get a nice seat. Enjoy the view. Why
not?
>> A quick read of vile moss as well. Can
you gank with MF from vile moors?
>> Well, I believe it's just you can't
straight to base. So, I think you can
still
>> units can't move from here to base. That
is true. So, you can gank. So,
Misfortune once again that legend text
being relevant
>> coming in clutch. It does make a
difference.
>> All righty. So, set praw are going to be
the first unit deployed by either side
as SW finally gets something on the
board. Pretty good unit in a scrap. But,
uh, let me tell you, the Aurora units
are a bit bigger. And there are 3 4 5 6
7 8 nine runes now after that catalyst.
And that may just be exactly how many
Aurora costs to play.
>> Just exactly.
>> No big deal.
>> Big deal. And it's a mindspplitter
actually played from hand. So, the unit
composition has changed somewhat.
Interesting.
>> Looking for that gear head and is going
to find it. Very heads up play here from
Rambo.
>> Makes a lot of sense. You know that it
was going to be coming.
>> Don't mind delaying your Aurora by a
turn. Got a unit on the board that is
good in a fight and also to get some
information on your opponent's hand. And
you see
>> there is a salvage in hand and I don't
think it's going to be in hand for much
longer. Mine says when you play me, we
choose an opponent. They reveal their
hand. You choose a card from it and they
discard that card.
>> Get information and get rid of the gear
hate. Not bad.
>> All righty then.
>> We also got that Fay Dragon there still
in here.
>> I love me some Fay Dragon bits. No
salvage here in this matchup.
>> All right, so party started. Pass it on
back. Pick up your hand. I have the
information written down diligently by
MF as
believe. Passed it on back. No, never
mind. Not just yet. Picked up the hand.
Sky as Bloom. Have a little look.
>> See what's coming through. Looks like a
Luna boon and a bullet time.
>> Bullet time seemed actually pretty
decent
>> in the last game. Although again, uh
sets buff and sets legend text can make
it a bit annoying at times.
>> Yeah,
>> even if you kill multiple units at once,
they get to pick which one they want to
save.
>> So, passes back. Sat's going to awaken.
Runes are going to go right side up. And
uh we're going to probably get some
points on the board. I have to imagine
it's a scoreless game so far.
>> You would think so.
>> Through four turns or so,
but that's going to change that. Spend
the buff.
>> Mhm.
>> Make it bigger. Move on over cuz you do
get the buff back when you conquer.
>> Mhm. So, he's at eight then.
>> Decided not to spend on monastery.
Curiously,
>> you can no longer stack the triggers the
old way, which is where you congregate
your buff and then spend the buff
because monastery is like you now have
to meet the condition when you wanted to
use the effect. But I believe you can
still
>> conquer afterwards. And I think the
reason this all happened is that
>> wanted to make sure issue a challenge to
this mind spplitter.
>> Mhm.
>> And now Ash focus. That is incredibly
good timing.
>> We talk about cards being good. That'll
do it.
>> And Ash Focus. I think one of the
reasons these order decks feel a bit
comfier against Aurora. When you play
me, choose an opponent, they reveal the
hand. This text is very similar to
Mitser that you might notice. Choose a
card revealed this way and banish it.
When they hold, return it to the hand. I
don't know if you've realized this, but
Aurora not the best deck at holding. You
know what they are good at though?
Drawing the second one off the top of
the deck.
>> That'll do it.
>> Knew it wasn't there. Literally just saw
your hand. Literally banished your only
copy of Aurora. And sometimes it just
does not matter. Off the top it goes.
There's the third one lurking around as
Elder Dragon going to make yet another
appearance.
>> Ash going to go by the wayside. Second
going to lose his buff.
>> Again, Ash coming away does not mean the
card comes back. Have to actually hold
to get the Aurora back, but I think the
damage has been done at this point.
>> Look, you say that Aurora's not
necessarily great at holding. Elder
Dragon though
>> presents a pretty hefty presence.
>> Oh, I think it's good at holding when it
has a unit it can hold with. Oh yeah.
>> Getting a unit you can hold with us part
is usually the hard part.
>> Unfortunately, it's much easier when you
find another Aurora.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that'll do it 100%.
>> That's got to be a tilter for us player.
>> Seeing the Aurora with the Ash had all
the tech line up. Now we have to contend
with Elder Dragon once again. Already
lost our salvage to the Mindsplitter.
>> So what is next? Can see a bunch of
units mostly in that hand by looks. I
think I see a showstopper as well. Very
>> none of that is helpful right this
moment.
>> Not so much.
>> Punch first. Not a bad trick. Set can
get pretty big. So trading with an elder
dragon is possible
>> somewhere down the line.
>> Eden still.
>> I didn't say it was easy.
>> That's true. That's true. It is
possible. Like you said, is it probable?
>> It will be a trade as well cuz of course
the dragons text. Exactly.
>> Any amount of your damage is enough to
kill enemy units.
>> Mhm.
>> How very one-sided of Elder Dragon.
>> Wonder what we're asking here cuz we are
in should be at the end of MF's turn.
>> Aurora's already clearly resolved. So,
not too sure what we're trying to puzzle
through here at the table.
>> Judge question perhaps.
There's some smiles and laughs there
though. So
>> I would smile too if I top deck after my
opponent played out focus and took my
Aurora.
>> Oh, absolutely.
>> Cannot complain with that.
>> Well, one side's going to complain about
that.
>> Oh, yeah. But again, as an Aurora player
and defender, I would not be complaining
at all.
>> Look, uh, when you draw a when you draw
your good card, that is uh Oh, okay. Is
it didn't randomize the cards from
Aurora? Is that what happened here?
>> Ah,
>> and look, I'm not I'm not an expert at
uh at Riftbound table charades, but that
appears to be what the players might be
asking the judges. Uh you do So, for
anyone who doesn't know, whenever you
recycle cards in Riftbound, uh assuming
you recycle more than once, so a number
greater than two, which is almost all of
the time, with basically by being the
exception, uh you do actually have to
randomize the cards that you recycle.
This actually includes your mulligan, by
the way. You'll see players pretty often
when they mulligan too. Just give their
cards a little shuffle. Present them to
your opponent cuz you're supposed to
present uh your shuffled pile anytime,
whether it's your deck or your little
pile of recycle cards to your opponent.
Uh I think I don't think I've ever seen
a player voluntarily cut the two
mulligan cards, but it is something you
can offer
>> to your opponents. Um but I think we
failed to randomize
>> our deck. So, I think we're trying to
figure out what we're supposed to do
here
>> because if those cards are on the bottom
of the deck already,
>> tough to figure out which ones you're
supposed to shuffle, but there is a
relatively big pile of cards just left
of the deck and there's a pile left of
the Aurora. And that presumably is the
Aurora player's hand,
>> you would think.
>> So, I can't imagine the pile is very far
away.
>> It looks like a judge is at the table
having a chitchat to the players. from
the bottom of the shot.
>> A little bit of
>> back and forth.
>> Ah, so production little bit of
information
>> as it travels throughout. Uh, did
successfully randomize a pile of cards.
>> Yeah.
>> Pile of cards they randomized was their
deck.
>> Yeah. Not ideal. Sometimes when piles of
sleeved cards are face down, all sleeved
in the same card, which say of course
they have to be, sometimes you pick up
the wrong pile and shuffle it. And
sometimes the pile you're supposed to
shuffle, which is the pile of cards
you're recycling, is actually your deck
that shouldn't be randomized cuz it's
already been randomized at the start of
the game.
>> Yeah, look, I mean, it happens is not
ideal.
>> I imagine there is reasonable policy to
cover this.
>> You would think so. It feels feel
necessary,
>> but I imagine the player maybe also got
a warning.
Yeah.
>> So, uh, no speculation from us, but
judges looks like they're wrapping up
the situation nice and swiftly. And as
we resume play by the looks of things
because I just saw the set player draw a
card to the top of the deck. Wouldn't
you believe the card they drew is
salvage number two.
>> They do still have that showstopper. Is
that Yap coming through?
>> Looks like top decks cut both ways
perhaps, but we already have to deal
with one elder dragon.
>> Mhm.
>> That's going to get buffed. Move on in
cuz that's all the text on the card.
>> Spend the buff. Draw from monastery.
>> Recon get a buff. So doing the thing
that I said you could do.
>> Mhm.
>> Makes a lot of sense.
>> Yep. And players just comparing. Yep.
That's how it works.
>> Double checking with the table judge.
>> A little back and forth.
>> Looks like there's some very minor
clarity things being
>> talked about by the players. I don't
think it's
>> doesn't feel particularly
>> relevant. That's fine. I get a little
shortcutting happening at the table. I
think everyone knows
>> what's going on, but always good to be
safe versus sorry when you're announcing
your triggers. Salvage though is going
to draw yet another card was the card
off the top for the turn.
>> And now Seth's going to retreat using
that uh
>> awakened state and showstopper is just a
move. It does not exhaust the unit. Move
on back after grabbing point number two.
And we're kind of back to I don't want
to say parody, but back to maybe a more
more manageable place for set.
>> Slightly more. Yes,
>> maybe.
>> We shall see.
>> So, kind of the funny thing is, well, we
did see one other Aurora, but now I
don't know where it is cuz I'm assuming
the deck got rerandomized.
>> True.
>> After everything that happened,
>> one would hope.
>> Uh, but we did see one go by in the last
Aurora pile. So,
>> in theory, it's not that close.
And uh there is one in banish, but you
can only get it if you hold. And that
means the Elder Dragon has to go kind of
make itself vulnerable on the front
lines if it were.
>> I mean, look, even still with buffs set,
I don't think can match up numbers wise.
So, it it might be worth a try.
>> I don't know if you ever tried to punch
an elder dragon in the face, but body is
very good at making units extremely big.
even set on his own. If you can buff him
twice, you can spend that buff to get
four might.
>> True.
>> That will be enough to contend with the
dragon. So, I wonder what the options
will be. It's MF accelerated.
>> Going to be played from the champ. This
is another way to try and force a hold
out of your opponent.
>> There's a point over.
>> Maybe try and a bait set in here again.
Can be a little bit tricky to navigate
at times, but it does at least threaten
a hold while protecting your Elder
Dragon and keeping it in the back line.
>> Mhm.
>> But we know there are challenges in this
set. We've seen one already. They
actually saw one last game if I recall
correctly. So, we'll see if the problem
can be solved cuz now it's just an Elder
Dragon and a Misfortune instead of an
Elder Dragon, a Misfortune, and an
Aurora.
>> An Aurora
can see
a little bit about what's going on in
SW's hand there.
>> Spend the buff.
>> Make my monster bigger.
>> Mhm.
>> My monster is a shirtless man that wants
to brawl. In we go onto MF. That's eight
might versus five. Bullet time.
>> Bullet time.
>> Did pass in showdown. Little little
weight there that didn't necessarily
happen, but that's all right. Now you
pay the energy once the spell resolves
and is going to pay one. And again, deal
one damage, which is enough to be lethal
at this point. And all of a sudden,
>> oh, we're asking the judge question
about ambush.
>> Uh
oh.
I believe. Yep. The unit will take
damage. So, can't don't want to play the
ambush unit there. You'll just get it
bullet timed.
>> Uh, but you can obviously Rengar can go
where enemies are.
>> Mhm.
>> Has Omega ambush as it were. And, uh,
this Rengar is pretty big. So, we're
going to have to force another spell. It
is bullet time number two.
>> Bullet time.
>> So, that hold is going to complete,
which means Aurora is going to come
back. I think that was the play set was
hoping
>> could tip the scales, but instead it is
Aurora holding on
>> to their battlefield and getting back
their signature enchantment.
>> Yeah, look, I mean, having that Elder
Dragon in play really does make bullet
time just that incredibly more
effective.
>> And you can see like Rambo's build of
Aurora is very elder dragoncentric.
>> Oh yeah, 100%.
>> Multiple bullet times, multiple flow of
blades in the main deck in game number
one. So clearly expecting to have an
Elder Dragon in play and then play the
game from there, which is even more
feast or famine. You can certainly,
>> you know, pull the levers a little bit
on Aurora and uh try and have your deck
exist in a place when you don't have
your signature piece of gear, but this
version, no, very much
>> dedicated to the life of the Aurora
player. By the way, couldn't actually
play the Aurora uh that they got back
from Banish because uh some runes
recycled, didn't have enough, but last
rights.
>> Got a little shovel.
>> It caused some issues perhaps. Start
recycling those units. Recycle that mine
spplitter perhaps that we know is in the
bin.
>> Not going to equip just yet considering
it all. Thumbing that chaos rune
considering if it wants to be thrown
under the rune deck, but no, not now.
Just pass it back.
And again, that can make units big, but
no units to start with. And uh
tough to tough to break through right
now.
>> Absolutely.
I think at this point when you're 2
three you can be a little bit more
patient with it. Obviously not ideal for
set at the moment given that there are
no units but now we have a fade dragon
so it's something
going to make unit pass and try again
next turn. So two points for Aurora from
three up to five. This is a regulation
game. So playing to eight as runes get
channeled and we know in fact everyone
knows that there is an Aurora that could
come down.
>> Mhm.
>> Nine runes at the ready. We'll see if
that is the line that Rambo wants to
take.
>> Like it was a Luna boon but in hand
obviously still
>> when in Sydney play Aurora perhaps.
>> Perhaps when in Sydney, why not?
>> I certainly do.
>> There it is.
>> Not quite north. Not quite south enough
for the Aurora, but hey,
>> you would think that, but a couple
months ago there did get uh a little
southern aurora. Well, and then a few
months later, we get this.
>> Mhm.
>> Love that.
>> Aurora number two technically, but
there's one we've seen before.
>> Mhm.
>> Going to be activated in a moment cuz
the shovel is being bestowed on Civer.
>> Mhm.
>> And a unit is going to get recycled.
There's one. There's two. Hey, that is
coming back as well, just in case.
>> Just in case I need it back. Oh, never
mind. Maybe you don't want the mine
split up.
>> Poor guy.
>> Oh, okay.
>> All right. Little recycle again. We got
to recycle your little pile very
carefully.
>> Didn't paying attention.
>> And now we go again. Time to spin the
wheels
to find a mind spitter. You have more
than one in the deck.
>> Reinforcing the V. Nope.
>> Monastery
somewhere. Reinforcing monastery.
>> What would you like from my beautiful
collection of cards? Ooh,
>> by peacekeeper fay dragon punch first
viora first mate and warmog's armor
>> nothing standing out hugely maybe just
take the biggest unit maybe take the
first mate
>> yeah look I mean
>> I mean buy actually good on offense
>> yeah and and has been showing
particularly well this weekend from all
accounts
>> stun units also don't deal damage so
that would actually be a way to win a
combat with elder dragon without getting
your units traded off.
>> Mhm.
>> But I think that is probably what you
want to take. And yeah, by peacekeeper
is going to hit the dust.
>> Would have been pretty good on this
turn, but unfortunately set having to
take a setup turn to try and win back
some of this territory
>> meant that another mind spplitter has uh
>> magicked out of the deck thanks to
dazzling Aurora. And uh if we do want to
take out this elder dragon or either of
the units really at these battlefields,
it is possible, but it might be quite
costly.
>> Yeah.
All right, warm up.
>> They also do need to to deal with MF
there because the shovel,
>> correct me if I'm wrong, but can just
bring back the other mines spplitter as
well.
>> That is why Rambo did keep the mind
spplitter in the bin instead of put it
back in the deck for Aurora. Wanted to
have a unit
>> they could play if Lost Rights did get
the opportunity to. So, we're punching
>> and we're rolling on over without the
Warmox.
>> We played the Warmongs. I feel like the
Warm Works maybe wants to join
>> join the party
>> dragon.
>> Don't need the buff. I guess it is plus
one extra might.
>> Every little bit helps sometimes.
>> Yeah, I don't know. Played it for fun
perhaps. That's all right. In we go.
Over to the Elder Dragon.
>> My unit is quite large.
>> Mhm.
>> My unit is less large, but my unit will
lose its buff.
>> Well,
the issue there though is there are now
multiple options.
>> That's true. So now you could Yeah,
look, Rambo could bring out the mind
splitter. Could bring out the other
elder dragon that's just gone in there.
>> We do have to pay for it. So, uh,
doesn't have enough runes for one of
those things.
>> Yeah,
>> spplitter is still a very, very good
play.
>> All right, that's why the warm was
there. Wanted to re-equip it later,
>> try and win the combat. And uh,
decent amount of might, but should be
some units traded off here. Fade dragon
is only so big. eight might I believe
and it is uh seven each on either of
those units but punch first is the
reason why SW believes he's going to win
this combat outright and I believe it
did cost a lot of ruins to get there but
the board is finally clear
>> and now it's simply the Aurora still in
play to deal with
>> look I mean even that on its own is
still very very capable of turning it
back around for Rambo
>> yeah only two runes left at the end of
that play all the body runes recycled as
well so had to use a ton of resources
there just to basically get this board
back to parody. But surely at some point
they'll run out of units. That's I think
what Set is thinking.
>> Trying to think how many elders has
set seen. I think just one.
>> Just the one.
>> But you've seen mind splitters and you
didn't see mind splitters in game one.
So you have to think the unit pool is a
bit more diluted than it was before.
>> The Baron could no longer be in the
deck, but
>> I don't actually know.
Can't really bank on that one though.
>> Feels like Elder is the unit you don't
want to see, but I don't know if Baron
is much better
>> given how big it is.
>> Just doing the dosey do here. And Aurora
is going to get triggered once again.
So, playing some setup things and
flipping cards over. There's Baron.
>> Oh, there he is.
>> Big purple warm makes yet another
appearance and that should be up to six
points, I believe.
>> And Baron is actually threatening to win
the game next turn.
>> Mhm. Hold
for one, gank over for the other. And 12
might is a big number. So despite the
heroics to try and remove all the other
units, I don't know if there's any juice
left in the tank as that sabotage is
drawn just a touch too late
>> by set.
You can move there from anywhere. So we
will indeed move on to Baron.
>> And something bad is about to happen.
>> Gust push your first m away.
Not big enough to take out the Baron.
>> Spend the power. Lose the buff.
>> Mhm.
>> Did have that gold awakened, I imagined.
>> So, Warmog's still there. The unit
doesn't actually die. It does get saved.
So, the equipment does stay on, but
again, the problem still presents
itself. If you cannot remove this Baron,
it will remove you from this round of
the tournament.
>> Mhm.
>> Baron's allowed to leave the pit. That
seems a bit um law inaccurate. Yeah, but
fun
>> fun for someone.
>> Fun for me and fun for Rambo if all goes
well.
>> We're going to be uh one of our
potential undefeated MF Aurora players
here. Not again. There weren't that many
undefeateds
>> going into round number five.
>> 12 I think you said earlier.
>> 12.
>> So going to be fewer as the rounds roll
on here. certainly expected to see the
deck near the top table and looks to be
continuing that run at least on for one
player
>> unless SW has a way out of this. Still
plenty of time left to navigate this
game and a third if we get there but it
is seeming increasingly more
challenging.
>> You can see a big smile breaker on
Rambo's legs face. I think understanding
that the game is well with graph this
Fiora pass it up
>> and just going to make him do it. Make
him have it. Make him remember that MF
Legend does give ganking, but one point
for holding.
>> Flip over the runes, draw the card.
>> Hope your opponent draws an extra card.
Maybe not a lot of things left, but
there's the ganking. There's the last
point. And oh, that isn't enough now
because of Baron.
>> Mhm.
>> So, let's just draw a card instead. The
same problem that SW had in the last
game.
>> Tripped me up in this one. So, still
have to conquer or hold. Maybe Baron can
hold.
>> It's very possible.
>> That's very funny to me. But uh
unfortunately not enough to win cuz you
you created this problem for yourself, I
might add.
>> Baron holding somewhere other than Baron
Pit. Very funny to me.
>> Game not over yet. One point away,
>> but that point must be earned by
conquering by scoring all the
battlefields all by holding. And
currently we've only scored two out of
now the three battlefields that are in
this game.
>> Last rights digging through the trash.
>> Mhm.
>> Put ND back. And let's put a bullet time
back. It looks like
>> Looks like
>> you approve of these choices. They they
work quite well together, so it's nice
they're together on the bottom of the
deck, I suppose.
>> Yeah, good for them.
>> And again, Marin is very big. Even
bigger than the Elder as far as might
goes.
>> Mhm.
>> Apparently even bigger thanks to the
shovel, which is a very harrowing image.
That
>> big worm holding that shovel. Bloom
going to get popped. MF is exhausted cuz
she was used earlier. Mhm.
>> And I believe we saw a unit. So, that
one's going on the board.
>> Looks like I saw something with a big
clust on it.
>> Mhm.
>> Can't quite tell. They're just barely at
the edge of the screen there.
>> Keeps him pretty close. One's
immobilized.
>> Leave him there. Build the movie. Right
about that one.
>> Go again. Count all the room. Yeah,
>> not a roar trigger.
>> There we go.
>> It's on the top of the deck. Look at
that. Another Baron.
>> Well, now each Baron gives each other
Baron plus two.
>> Mhm.
>> But you do not make another Baron pick
cuz there's already one.
>> There's already one there. You don't
need more of that.
>> Don't need another one. So instead, it's
just uh 26
might
>> to break through or lose till one hold.
>> Oh, isn't it? 12 + 12 is 24. They each
get Oh, it is more.
>> Yeah.
>> No, no, no. It's even more. It's So, the
the base is 24. It's two 12s. They each
get plus two from each other. That's
plus four. So, 28 plus the shovel's 30.
>> Goodness me.
>> Look, I'm trusting your maths on this
one. You've done it a lot faster than I
did.
>> It says other friendly units have plus
two. They are each friendly units. Rambo
will get the die out and mark them.
>> Mhm.
>> So, that should be 30 and that should be
game. Rambo's leg undefeated. Still six
and zero now here at RQ Sydney. Oh,
look. Again, as an Aurora player, I love
to see it. I love to see it happen,
especially given that there was that
moment of maybe not so much doubt, but a
little tension for Randos leg earlier in
that first matchup, but good to see that
Baron did come in clutch there. It was
interesting to see a second one come in
as part of that sideboard.
>> Now that you mentioned it, there is at
least three units
>> in that sideboard cuz we saw three of
them and there might be even more.
>> Quite possibly. But definitely changing
the composition in game two, adding a
bunch of extra units
>> in this match up. Mind splitter
certainly looked very good.
>> I'm a big splitter in this deck.
>> Obviously have access to sabotage as
well. So ways to kind of deal with the
gear hit before you play your Aurora.
>> Absolutely.
>> And uh really thought Ash focus was
going to get it done there. But
>> look, I mean
>> sometimes again they just have it
lurking as the next card down.
>> It Yeah, it is what it is. Luck of the
draw sometimes can really just do
wonders.
>> Yeah. Turns out the hand is not the top
of the deck basically.
>> Pretty much
all smiles which is wonderful to see.
>> Yeah. Look, X1 certainly a very good
spot here at this point.
>> Absolutely.
>> X2 to make day two. X1 still live top
eight.
>> Mhm.
>> So, uh not a lot of tournament left for
today. Lots of tournament to play
tomorrow. And both these players in
prime position
>> to make day two. In fact, Aurora is
going to be locked for day two. Rambo's
leg. Uh if they lose the next two
rounds, still going to be playing
tomorrow.
>> Love to see it. I'm very excited to see
how it shapes up tomorrow as well. But
looking very, very pleased with himself
there.
>> Yeah, granted, you definitely don't want
to lose the next two rounds. That would
be kind of a tragedy to start 6 and then
lose the last two rounds, even if you do
make day two. But Aurora finally on
stream kind of uh in true fashion we can
say for the first time and I think uh
>> can see why the deck is feared and
respected
>> as it should be. But again I know
there's the all all the contention this
is just evidence that sometimes it can
go your way and sometimes it's a lot
harder to make it go your way.
>> Felt like quite a lot of counterplay
there. I think maybe set needed more
like I didn't see any copies of
unyielding spirit which would help a lot
against Elder Dragon specifically. That
being said, not every deck is on all the
elders, so you do kind of have to pick
which monster composition you think the
decks are going to be playing, which can
be kind of a tricky thing to metag game
for.
>> So, we'll see. You know what? Better way
to find out about how Aurora is getting
played these days.
>> Let's find out direct from the source.
>> Let's talk to an Aurora player.
>> Thank you very much for that one,
Julian. I am here with Rambo's Leg, the
winner of round six. Currently 600. How
does it feel to have locked in that day
two?
>> It feels great, actually. Yeah, it's
super nervous.
didn't want to be on camera, but we had
to do it. And uh yeah, it was real
sloppy, but
>> I'll take it.
>> Take anyway we can get it.
>> Yeah, that's it. Sometimes the nerves
can get the better of us just a little
bit here, but you've persevered and
you've came out on the other side. The
winner of that round six matchup into
that set.
>> How many sets have you played into so
far today?
>> This is actually the second one. So, I
was uh I was a little bit more prepared
this time. Uh that actual the other set
is the only one I dropped the game to.
So,
>> Ah, okay. It's a It's should be a pretty
easy matchup, but um you never you never
know because the deck can always fall on
its own. So
>> that's it. That's it. And we do have a
lot of Auroras here today. What made you
decide to go with Misfortune instead of
say Civer or Poppy or even the hidden
Fiora tech?
>> Yeah, I actually sat next to the Fiora
Aurora guy uh last round. So um it was
really interesting to see that. But I
think MF has better endgame scenarios
with ganking. um multiple times today.
And I should have shown on camera that
last one. Um I was supposed to equip the
last rights, gank over. Yes. Then play
the MF from graveyard accelerated to
conquer for the last point. Uh that's
actually how I beat the other uh set.
>> Uh so it's you have a lot more
maneuverability and mobility around the
battlefields, especially when Baron
pit's there because no one really
understands how to play against the
Baron Pit. you just think to to go in
there and it's so you get a lot of
opportunities now until people realize
what they're supposed to do.
>> Yeah. So it sounds like you're a very
experienced Aurora player. I it sounds
like you've been playing since Origins
maybe and then you've seen the the you
know the big Nasher and the Elder as
well and found a way to utilize that. Is
that fair to say experience?
>> Not at all. I' I've been playing this
deck for about 3 weeks now. Um I started
playing after seeing the Vegas stream.
Yep.
>> Uh so it it really inspired me. I hadn't
been I hadn't played any TCGs for
probably like a year or two years. Wow.
>> And I saw it and I was just like, "This
is great." Like I It speaks to you.
>> Yeah. And so I was just like, "Let me
start playing." And then let me see
when's the next RQ I can play for.
>> Oh, Sydney. Okay. Well, that's far. But
uh ended up just getting the ticket
right then and there and just um have
been playing it non-stop since then and
it's been a lot of fun.
>> Okay. So, speaking of far, where have
you come from? All the way to Sydney,
Australia.
>> Yeah, Southern California. So, yeah, it
was uh I really wanted to play in an RQ.
You really did. Uh yeah, and so made the
trip. Um I hadn't traveled out of the
country for years, so it's just one of
those things where,
>> you know, uh you see the world,
>> play a game. Like, yeah, that sounds
great.
>> It worked out. Well, that's so special
that you've traveled so far. You're
currently six and zero. You've
guaranteed your day two. Are there any
matchups that you're
less comfortable playing into coming
into the last few rounds?
>> Yellow decks with Cole and um like
basically Victor is always the
nightmare. um just because it's uh it
has a hard time against other things. So
that's always the the hope is that it's
it doesn't make it as far because it
gets caught up by all the other uh decks
that have better matchups into it.
>> But u the Poppy Aurora is frightening.
Uh so I I don't like that. But at the
same time um I really can't complain. Uh
I I I figured that it was going to be a
very flat distribution of decks. So, you
know, playing the second deck at the
same time probably won't happen till day
two. So
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. I I think as long I just stay away
from Victor. So
>> that's it. Well, fantastic. Thank you so
much for those insights, Rambo's leg.
Congratulations on 600 and locking in
your day two here at the Riftbound
Regional Qualifiers, Sydney 2026.
>> Back to you, casters.
>> Nice to know there's at least one other
person from Southern California that
travel to Sydney that is going to be
making day two, joining me qualifying
for day two. I always qualify, though.
That's one of the nice things about
being on the cast desk.
>> Yeah, we're kind of just here by
default. It's great.
>> Yeah, I'll take it.
>> Yeah, good enough for me.
>> Still counts. We're here for day two.
>> Certainly are. We are in round six, by
the way, cuz we are still playing in day
one. And we have a feature match once
again for you all. We're going to be
jumping into game number three between
some pretty fun ones. One of our legends
is Kha'Zix. And the other one is
everyone's favorite little yle. It's
Teemo.
>> Is it?
>> I believe so. Did I get that right? I
believe that right.
>> It was on.
>> Might be on your right. It's on Teemo.
>> That's a very funny looking yle. There's
on on the left.
>> Definitely on.
All right, let's see where we're at
here. We do have the Baron pit already
out.
>> Oh goodness.
>> Truly jungling in this set.
>> Very much so.
>> All righty. So, got a little chaos
Kha'Zix up in that top battlefield
hanging out at Forge. Obviously the
battlefield that wanted to bring to this
game.
>> Players have split the first two games
by the way. So, we are in game three
right in the middle of it as you can see
at five points to four
as St. Oz, I truly hope is Australian.
>> Mr.
Mother over point.
>> You never know.
>> You never know. Little suspicious.
>> Mhm.
>> Either way.
>> Maybe just for this weekend, we can we
can make him an honorary Australian just
in the name alone.
>> What an interesting spot to be in. Three
battlefields does mean that the point
totals get a little different. you now
go from five to eight a little more
cleanly from time to time. His last
right is going to get raked by dislaming
rake. Certainly a card we expect to see
quite a bit more of this weekend out of
the calm deck especially if they don't
have other access to good gear hate.
>> Mhm.
>> Lonely power going to reinforce and uh
it's quite a lot of little units here in
this on deck. So, I'm getting the
feeling that it's probably more of an
aggressive on list, which I think has
been kind of the default,
maybe best on deck as far as how those
players have decided to pardon the deck.
Certainly not an expert, not hanging out
in the on discords getting all the info,
but that is what the what the little
birds tell me.
>> The little birds,
>> little the little internet birds.
>> They whisper to me and they tell me
about sometimes.
>> It's very specific from little internet
birds.
>> All right. All right. Well, Baron again
still buffing up that Kha'Zix. So, it's
seven right now on the forge.
>> Saint still feeling good about the point
lead, but desert's call kind of the
classic from Azir is going to be making
even more units. And it looks like we're
trying to set up to do a perhaps a
triple conquer situation on the next
turn.
>> But again, Baron is very large. So,
>> oh yeah,
>> not sure how easy that's going to be.
>> I'm also not seeing any XP. Yep.
Anywhere.
>> It's all been spent. All been spent to
get this going.
>> Well, Baron has successfully made it
back to base. Can now go somewhere else.
>> Mhm.
>> We'll start with the sabotage. What you
got?
>> Is it good?
>> It's all right.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Charm and a brutalizer. One of those
would have been pretty good.
>> Mhm.
>> At trying to set up for the triple
conquer. So instead, it goes under the
back to the bottom of the deck.
>> Brutalizer goes back to hand. Make that
orn a little bit bigger, but have a
feeling that orn's not going to be quite
big enough yet with the baron. Now or
can certainly get big enough to battle
Baron.
>> Oh, definitely.
>> You need quite a bit more gear for that.
>> Look, I mean, Baron's a big boy. What
can I say?
>> Very large and often in charge.
>> Very large.
>> All right, five points piece.
Has shuffling. Looks like a blade flurry
and another card which leads me to
believe. Although there is a Kha'Zix
that would be the chosen champion
though. I suspect this is Aurora Kha'Zix
by the way.
>> Yeah.
>> Going to gank on over. I guess you don't
even have to gank the bar. You're just
allowed to move there from anywhere.
>> Mhm.
>> So ganking or even if it's not true
ganking, good enough to clear that
battlefield. get point number six as a
buff gets granted thanks to Kha'Zix's
ability to the Baron. If Baron wasn't
big enough, it's now one bigger for a
nice unlucky 13 might.
Going to have to get pretty big on for
dealing with a lot of this.
>> Yeah. Where to next?
>> Thinking about it. Parents probably
wants to go somewhere.
Do
>> you want to get stuck at biomores?
>> Do you want to hang out and uh
>> maybe join up with your Kazix in the
other battlefield? Looking to try and
score two points if you can.
>> Right into the VMO's lair there.
>> Going to threaten to hold two.
>> Two is good. Three is better, but
All right. So, off to seven, I believe.
>> Mhm.
>> Not that it's going to matter all too
much cuz feels like Baron is still the
big problem have to deal with.
And we know it's just a brutalizer right
now in hand, which is uh a little
something, but not a lot of something.
>> Yeah.
>> So, top of the deck's going to have to
be kind here. I think
that charm would have been real mint.
Instead, it is ooh electing your order
for the redraw.
>> Not what you'd be hoping for.
>> I don't do a quick might calculation. I
believe on is plus is it plus one every
gear or plus two every gear for on
>> uh I believe
>> it's just plus one.
Kind of makes all your gear whether you
can equip it or not just a little bit
better
indeed. on forge god. I have plus one
for each friendly gear. Deflect two also
which is very funny
>> especially if you have a find a speller
on your on but uh currently no gear in
play. So on is just a four.
So 4 8 12 + 4 is 16 + 2 is 18. Sand
soldier going to make that 16 left, but
is going to conquer that first point
necessary to potentially win this game
and also stay undefeated.
>> Whichever player takes it here is going
to be uh sitting pretty for day two.
There's that brutalizer paid for by the
uh on does have weapon master, but I
think act I think
looks like the brutalizer cost just got
paid by Oh, no. Did get paid by on.
>> Yeah,
>> forge making it one cheaper cuz you do
control it. I think you just have to pay
the power though. Yeah.
>> Yep. Just the power to play gear or use
gear abilities.
>> Yeah. So did Oh, sorry. I can see the K
moon exhausted. That's what I was trying
to figure out. So it's six total. Uh
three for the brutalizer, four for the
on and then one more on top. So you can
think about it as plus four alto
together which is eight. That's what the
diet is representing on's total might
here.
>> So eight is bigger than seven which is
currently what that Kha'Zix is
representing.
>> But is can we take the Baron out? That's
kind of the other question. Baron
currently at 13.
And if we do a quick maths, that's 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12. That's not enough.
>> We have to move in with a little bit
more.
>> Get more.
>> All right. 4 + 8 is 12. That's still not
13.
>> Do some quick maths there.
>> 8 9 10 11 12 13 14. That is enough
>> there with the sand soldier on top.
>> Three twos are six. 8 is 14. So that is
just enough. Mhm.
>> to defeat the Baron in combat. That will
shrink the Kha'Zix as well. Kha'Zix all
the way down to five at the end of this
all. Now, this is all assuming, by the
way, the Kha'Zix doesn't have anything
relevant in hand.
>> We know what's up. The the rest of Saint
Sand is, I think, face up at this point.
Maybe one extra draw from the Y that we
don't know about, but not a lot left in
the tank, we have to assume.
>> All right, so pass back. Can you beat
this? I have 14. All these little guys
swarming into the pit trying to collect
the delicious buff. Oh no.
>> Oh, there we go.
>> Is that blade for actually enough to tip
the scales? One extra damage is all we
need.
>> Oh, there's two. That's even worse.
>> Oh no.
>> Now the twos get taken out before it
even matters.
>> It's just it.
>> That's just on left against the 13 power
baron. On is going to lose that fight
many days of the week.
>> Mhm.
>> I don't think he can get through now.
Sand soldier goes by. Yep, that is a
unit out of battlefield that did take
two damage.
In fairness, Baron does take the damage
as well, but I don't think that's going
to be relevant.
>> Not so much.
>> Very, very unfortunate there for St. Oz.
>> Two damage marked on the Baron.
>> Two damage marked on the Kha'Zix as well
for what it's worth. But not sure that's
the Well, I guess you can if the the
score totals are correct and Kha'Zix is
only at six points, you can at least not
lose next turn.
>> True.
>> And then threaten to win cuz you should
be able to beat the Kha'Zix in combat
cuz about to lose this combat and at
least give up the brutalizer.
>> Mhm.
>> That one happens.
Now drop boulder and lonely parro should
be able to team up and beat the Kha'Zix.
>> You would think
>> Kha'Zix does get bigger when alone but
should be bringing a friend here despite
the lonely Porro being lonely. Does not
want to be in this upcoming instance.
Have a quick read of Kha'Zix's mutating
horror. Does have ambush when I attack
or defend. If an enemy unit is alone
here, give me plus two this turn and
gain two XP. So already bigger thanks to
the Baron. Already bigger thanks to the
buff.
>> Mhm. Lonely Porro moving in or wants to
draw the card instead.
>> Made the Kha'Zix bigger for that.
>> Well, yeah, that's it.
>> Okay. And I think maybe the point totals
may not have been fully updated cuz I
think Kha'Zix was at seven, which meant
it doesn't matter if you can't move the
Baron.
>> That extra card draw did not find what
he needed. And Kha'Zix is six and zero
here at RQ Sydney.
>> Love the little cup noodle deck box
there as well.
>> Oh, that's wonderful.
>> I honestly that would uh that would that
would do quite well right now. Yeah, I
think so. It seems about time.
>> Anybody in the venue wants to fly over?
>> I wouldn't say no.
>> Yeah, say no.
>> So, back to back I believe back toback
Aurora games in that round. Although
again,
>> didn't see
>> don't didn't can't confirm. Can only uh
>> speculate.
>> Speculate. Yes.
>> But yes, seeing Baron there. Little bit
of a hint.
>> Little bit of hint. Well,
>> little bit of a hint possibly.
>> Six rounds through. You having fun?
>> I'm having so much fun. This is great.
>> Well, that's good cuz round seven's
coming up. Don't go too far away. We're
going to record when we return more
coverage of Aki Sydney.
>> Hello, Riftbounders. Are you wondering
how the game developed with Unleashed?
Let me give you a little introduction.
The calm domain has reinvented its
defensive capabilities. With powerful
pump spells and counter spells, calm
decks were already good at contesting
their battlefields, but with unleashed,
holding the fields becomes a whole lot
stronger. A standout example for this is
back off. Three energy, no power. This
card on action speed stuns a unit and
draws a card if played from hand.
Incredible. But leaving three runes open
isn't always an option. Luckily, you can
also hike this card if your runes are
exhausted or you want to keep them open
for another card. Fury, on the other
hand, brings plenty of new ways to
assert pressure onto your opponent.
Every jungler's dream is coming true
with smite. Finding a new way to remove
units. It simply deals three damage to a
unit at a battlefield for two energy and
one power. While those stats are not too
impressive, the unit will also be
banished when it would die. This takes
powerful death nail effects out of the
equation and can also remove follow-up
if your opponent relies on resources
from their trash like Fiora worthy that
can't be played through spectral matron
anymore. Order has been known for its
hard removal and kill spells. Now, what
if I told you that you can remove your
opponent's hand as well? Ash Focus gives
you full information about your
opponent's hand and lets you banish a
card of choice for five energy and one
power. They will get it back as soon as
they hold a battlefield. But with full
information and one card less in the
opponent's hand, it's now on you to not
let that happen. Chaos has been
chaotically bouncing cards left and
right, pushing them front and center,
and now you will also be able to reach
the opponent's units in base.
Starcross's reaction speed removal is
revolutionary, especially when it hits
the base as well. For three energy and
one power, you can return a friendly and
an opposing unit back to the owner's
hands. While this can give you an
incredible advantage with play effects,
it also disturbs your opponent. It slows
them down massively and can sometimes
deny powerful effects like Elder Drank's
passive kill ability. While this domain
has already been good at controlling the
opponent's units, the mind is now
finally greater than the sword. The mind
domain receives a fantastic gear removal
card. Turn to Dust will turn any gear
into a temporary problem for two energy
and no power cost. While it does not
immediately help you remove units that
are boosted by equipment gear, you can
easily take care of seals, dazzling
aurora, or other great gear that stands
in your way. Now, what's scarier than
body units that are standing on your
opponent's side of the field just
waiting to overwhelm you with their
physical prowess, the ones you didn't
see coming.
Ringa Trophy Hunter has to be on your
opponent's mind at all times. Every time
your opponent feels secure about the bot
states, the Apex Predator could be
played on a battlefield where they have
units for five energy and one power,
either as an ambush or reaction speed to
support your other attacking or
defending units, or as a lonely attacker
straight from hand with its powerful six
smite. What cards do you think are going
to see the most play? And which domain
do you like the most after Unleashed?
Show us at your next tournament.
We are down here at the Sydney RQ. I am
joined by the incomparable Dave Guskin.
How has it been being in Sydney so far?
>> Uh, good. I arrived yesterday morning.
Uh, it was very long flights and then I
had to work all day, but it's been
really great. All the people are really
friendly. Um, got to go to a game store
last night. It was really fun.
>> Awesome. And how has the reception been
like in Sydney? Obviously, this is a
huge event. So many people here.
>> Yeah, I heard there's maybe 1,600ish
people in the main event. Very exciting.
Um, yeah, everyone seems really excited.
A lot of high energy around Ripbound,
around Unleash. So, really cool to see.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And are you going to
do a little bit of exploring around
Sydney while you are here?
>> I don't know if I have time this trip.
It's kind of a quick turn around and I'm
here at the event for most of the time,
but um I want to come back. So,
hopefully we'll do more events in the
future here and I'll be able to come
back. So, yeah.
>> And obviously, we are so close to just
having Unleash release. How has that
changed the game for you guys at the
moment?
>> Yeah. So, Unleash has been really,
really good reception. And I think um
set over set, there's like more players,
there's more people buying product. It's
really great. Um I think unleashes a
little bit of a shakeup. You know,
there's a lot of new mechanics. Um we'll
see if it kind of like disrupts the
metag game in significant ways. Um
obviously a lot of power to the Aurora
decks. Um some interesting kind of new
builds with XP. So we'll see. Yeah, it's
kind of exciting to see.
>> So with the main event coming tomorrow,
do you have a gut instinct on what we're
likely to see a lot of given the
release? Um, I would guess the most
prevalent deck is are dazzling Aurora
decks. Um, you know, Elder Dragons,
really, really strong. Um, I think that
there's a lot of interesting kind of
like purple X builds. Um, I think a lot
of interesting Leblanc builds, so I
probably expect those to be uh lots of
people playing them. What what will win,
I don't know. Um, but that's kind of
what I think the field's going to look
like.
>> Awesome. Well, at this point, it is
still anyone's game. We'll see how it
goes, but thank you so much and we'll uh
we'll see what happens.
>> It's amazing hearing what Dave has to
say about Riftbound. It's so good to
even have him here as well. I believe
there's been quite a few signings and
meet and greets. And Logan, I know you
have got the pleasure of even having
some of your cards signed.
>> Absolutely. I got a set of the spirit
forged overnumbered seals signed by the
man himself, Dave Guskin. It was a
pleasure. It was an honor to meet the
man. Very, very, you know, heavy
contributor to Rip. I'm pretty sure he's
the creator of it. Just
>> Oh, yeah. Maybe. Y.
>> Yeah. So, ripper to have him down here
in Australia for our first ever regional
qualifier in Sydney, right?
>> No. Absolutely amazing to have the man
himself here and to hear some of the
insight as well. Hear his predictions as
well. I think he had some pretty good
predictions. I I mostly agree with what
he said. So, let's see if it comes to
fruition. But right now, we are in round
seven, Logan. And let's see who our
featured match up will be.
>> Yeah, we're getting to the pointy end.
And as a reminder, we do have those
predictions here. So far, Diana being
one of the high represented, but as it's
tracking, pastry time is definitely on
track with the most decks registered for
that legend. However, Prismat is
fighting his way through the field on
that Annie.
>> I I basically chose Annie, I would say,
because of Prisman and because of how I
think he for the Chaos domain becoming
quite strong. I think in the hands of
Prisman, he can do pretty well. So, I'm
I'm hoping he obviously will be making
day and I can't say obviously at this m
he is making day two and so my hopes are
still alive.
>> Yeah, absolutely. I did see I went for a
walk around in that main area and
Prismat is at the tippity top tables
there. So, he is very much in contention
for that day two, but we will see him a
little bit later. And as you said, this
is round seven. This is the pointy end
of the day here. I see
>> it is but getting to we're going to be
seeing some really really highlevel
plays coming in now cuz round seven
means that these players are going to be
6-0. And uh we want to talk about as
well your prediction being Diana. We
definitely have quite a few Diana
players that are also still 6-0.
>> Yeah, look, I'm a big fan of Diana and
Diana was definitely my prediction and
we're seeing a lot of the sort of top
players on her at the moment. We saw
Dwali take out his game against that
Leona. We see Allan is also running
Diana. They have a lot of belief that
this is the strong legend. But what I'm
sort of missing here is the Leblanc,
right? I want to see some more Leblanc
games, which I have to believe we're
going to be getting tomorrow. just those
temporary death nail shenanigans that
she kind of brings to the rift.
>> She brings a lot of shenanigans, that's
for sure. The death now as well as all
the reflect tokens. They're absolutely
so interesting mechanics coming in. I I
love the all the new mechanics that
Unleashed has brought onto Riftban. Of
course, we talk about the experience. We
talk about these token units. We talk
about Baron and uh the of course Ivan
with the the the battlefield changes
too. Like so many new mechanics coming
in with unleash.
>> Yeah. The hunt mechanic which is that XP
that ambush as well. So surprise units
instead of spells and the brush which I
earn creates. We do love to see that.
Baron pit from that Baron Nasher here
too. But um it's just really good to see
the meta shaked up right every set you
like to see a little bit of healthy
change coming through. Oh we see a
thousand tile watcher there.
>> Hey green and blue. It's a mind and calm
deck. So, what do you think we're
watching?
>> I mean, right now it could be it could
be Nar. It could be
>> Oh, shall be
>> Ailia. It could be Ailia.
>> Ooh, we're also getting to see Azir.
>> I love seeing Azir. I also love to hate
seeing Azir because the way that Azir
works is absolutely fantastic with that
legend ability. Your sand soldiers all
have weapon master and you can also use
your legend exhausted to play of course
that sand soldier. And the way that the
interaction between this and
arise the signature spell is absolutely
I think kind of groundbreaking. It's
definitely a game turning moment.
>> I do love though they've added a couple
of cards from unleash here. We do see
that shadows call which is also very
very popular in Leblanc. We do see that
scuttle crab, that soul sword as well.
But importantly, we have sacrifice. So
obviously Azir with that legend ability
is creating sand soldiers, the two mites
with that weapon master. So you've
already got so many juicy targets to
sacrifice and get this card advantage,
which is so strong in these decks.
>> Some people won't even consider poor
sand soldiers real units anyway. They're
just token units. Oh, you're gasping at
me.
>> Justice for sand soldiers. So being able
to sacrifice a sand soldier who's still
mighty, it just feels like a kind of
like a no-brainer. It's just such a good
use of that sacrifice. Excited to see
how this Azia does use it. But of
course, we also want to see what this
calm and
>> mind. Is it mind? It was calm and mine.
The deck will be. Yeah, that's it. I I
am interested to see it. I'm glad we got
that sort of cheeky little deck tech
there on the Azir. And again, as you
shouted out so correctly earlier, we do
not show those sideboards, that hidden
tech for these players to index towards
as we see Lilia. I called it. I said it
was a Lilia. So, this will be the second
Lilia of the day. You've got to be happy
with that, Rice.
>> I am happy with that. I'm also happy
with I don't know those matchups is kind
of cute and fun. It's it's the token
units versus the token units. It's the
sprites versus the sand soldiers. One of
them is two might, one of them is three
might, one of them is not temporary, but
one of them is. Yeah, but I do see that
unchecked power and that is going to be
an absolute sweeper that cleans up Azir
and that's something that Azir does not
have access to because he is not in that
mind domain there Ricey. So that could
be the game difference as our gamers do
that respectful handshake. The game is
upon us.
>> It really is upon us, Logan. We are
heading now into game one of round
seven. Both of these two players are six
and zero. We have Dusk Rose Lab in the
hands of Lilia. We have Hall of Legends
in the hands of Azir. We have Yellow
Kaza versus Santism. It's going to be a
great matchup.
>> Definitely looking forward to this
matchup and it's interesting to see
different battlefields. I can't say
we've actually seen a Hall of Legends
today. So, it is nice to see those
represented that Hall of Legends. When
you conquer here, you may pay one energy
to ready your legend. So it's it's
bringing that Aurelia legend tech
>> over to Azir
>> which means as we know what Azir's
legend does he get multiple multiple
sand soldiers and remember the old
weapon master we don't want to forget
that of course first round is going to
be yellow cluster playing and out comes
that scuttle crab I kind of want to say
scuttle crab is a staple but I don't
know if we can say that just yet very
very popular unit in calm deck So, of
course, out comes that scuttle crab.
Santism on the other hand is going to be
playing a sand soldier and of course a
eye of the Herald. One of the uh gears
that of course as yet loves to run.
>> I will be brave enough and I will say
it. Scuttle crab has quickly made itself
a staple. Absolutely in these calm
decks. It's in every single one here as
we do see that first sand soldier has
hit the deck and has that gear equipped.
>> Sanderson also has a scuttle crab in
hand. So both of these players at the
very least are going to be considering
or if not playing Scuttle Crab quite
early. Out comes two Raven Bloom
students from Yellowcaster and in the
hands of Lilia with that lots of spells.
These Raven Bloom students, they can get
quite mighty.
>> Yeah, look, that's a banger of a start
if I'm Yellow Cer sitting on two Raven
Bloom students. We do see the legends.
Oh, he's flexing the graded overnism.
There's only so much I can handle with
this awesomeness being presented on this
board.
>> 9.5 rating, that's not too bad. 10, but
my goodness, a signature 9.5 is pretty
good indeed.
>> That means it's a 10 10 and a 9.5 and a
9.5. So, not enough to get that sort of,
you know, super duper high grade, but
you'd love to see it. And that's one of
the aspects of Riftbound that I really
love is that you can actually kind of
flex your like super pretty legends, and
they make them pretty here. I see.
>> They really do. It is great having a
legend out on display and you can put it
in a very very safe case to make sure it
stays safe and stays pretty of course.
Now Santaim has gone on to
Dusk. Yep. Dus Lab uh to get that point.
They're currently both on one point each
and we can see Azia with that sand
soldier and a recruit as well.
>> Yep. Currently just considering their
options. Those six runes, sorry, five
runes up. They have those three order
two calm and they all look really really
nice in that alt art there. And
>> BF's order comes down and is going I'm
not sure if he's equipping it just yet.
He's definitely considering playing it.
>> Oh,
>> his his cards his hand has been of
course revealed to yellow caster through
that rift scuttle crab which does mean
that you know um yellow caster knows
exactly what Santism has knows about
that BF sword.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I mean, you just played
it out there for free, so it's like
here's some more free information.
Here's reaffirmation of the previous
information you gain. He already knew.
Ooh, charm, though.
>> Charm's going to be pretty exciting.
He's going to be charming over that
Raven Bloom tuner to try and get rid of
it. Will actually trade out one of one
of the sand soldiers for it, but uh the
recruit still stays there. And of
course, the gear has to return to base.
>> That's it. Both players, one conquer
point a piece here. So it is an evenly
drawn match as the dusk grows lab it
seems to be creeping across that play.
It's trying to get away from sans is
like no you're conquering me not today.
And that eye of the herald will be
played.
>> Eye of herald will be back. And scuttle
crab comes into play as well but of
course exhausted won't be used just yet.
Uh and I mean scuttle crab is such a
wonderful uh card. we alluded to before,
it's becoming a staple of calm because
of how versatile and how many different
abilities it has for just being only
two.
>> Yeah, it's an extremely high value card
as well, right? So, obviously being that
two energy, it doesn't dramp you cuz it
doesn't cost you any power. It's going
to get you that card draw as well.
You've got a unit on the battlefield or
the base and as you say that death nail
giving that free information over so you
know how to play into your opponent,
what answers they could have into
anything that you want to put forward.
We do see yellow caster on the play
here. Has his six runes up and ready to
go. Looks to want to exhaust three here.
Ricey
>> is exhausting the three. Let's see what
he's going to be playing for the Oh,
it's going to be his chosen champion,
Lilia Forn. And if anyone is unfamiliar
with Lilia Fayorn, this thorn will be
producing from leaving a trail behind of
a lot of sprites. Of course, you want to
try and keep that Lilia Fayorn alive as
long as possible to produce as many
sprites as possible, but everybody wants
to target the queen. That's it. When I
move from a location, play a three might
sprite unit token with temporary there.
Notably, not ready. However, that's what
the Lilia Bashful Bloom Legend will do
for an exhaust and that four cost
reduced per sprite on the base or
battlefield of yellow caster has played
that plundering porro though and given
the turn back to Santism.
>> Santism is going to approach Dusk Rose
Lab with that sand soldier and recruit
going in of course also with the eye.
He's going to be trading out the sand
soldier once more. But hey, Sandism has
one more conquer. They're currently two
a piece. Yeah, these are some early
trades happening here. Yellow caster not
having any spells to sling around to
boost these Raven Bloom students up. It
feels like they haven't seen the value
that you would hope for or expect out of
Raven Bloom students in these early
players. But this is an Azir deck. It's
able to get that early game tempo with
these sand soldiers constantly pumping
them out as we see here again and
equipping that BF sword with that weapon
master. Weapon master tapping the
exhausting the Azir legend as well to
bring out that sand soldier and then of
course weapon master equipping it
straight away. So that is a quite a buff
sand soldier right now. BF sword plus
three. It certainly is big.
>> Yeah, five might presented right there
with that one sand soldier token. That
scuttle crab has moved forward to
conquer that hall of legends as well. In
Hall of Legends, you conquer it, you pay
one energy, you can ready your legend,
which enables you to pump out another
sand soldier. However, Santism now at
three points. Yellow caster at two. It's
a close race here. And things are moving
quite quickly.
>> Moving quite quickly. Three and two. I
mean, it's yellow's turn right now. Has
that plundering power you mentioned
earlier available to push up, but it's
going to be using four energy right now
and going to be exhausting Lilia. Out
comes the sprite. And it is in fact
ready. Yeah, we do love a ready sprite,
but I just saw a sneaky cheeky card in
Yellowcaster's hand. If Santism is
allowed to develop a big board, which it
looks like he's wanting to do,
Yellowcaster does have an answer, but I
won't reveal it just yet.
>> Okay, so you're leaving me in the dark.
Yeah, I should have been paying
attention to his hand more than his
plays apparently. But Plundering Pro
will go out onto the battlefield Hall of
Lance and will take that conquer. Out
comes the gold. And now we get to see
what you so hear from us.
>> Triple defy.
>> My triple defy. And of course that
unchecked power. Is that the one?
>> That was the one. But the death nail
from the scuttle crab. It gave up the
ghost. I was trying to build up the
story, trying to build the surprise. And
scuttle crab said not today.
>> Even though judge is laughing, I think
about that.
Well, we know where the ties are now in
yellow's hand.
>> All Yeah. All in the hand.
>> Yeah, probably. You're so right. So, the
next time Santism goes to do anything,
he has to play around those Defiers.
Even if he removed one of them, he knows
there's at least two more in Yellow
Cers's hand here. So, I'm looking
forward to seeing what the trash is,
what his decision to remove was. And um
yeah, it looks like we've got those
sprites.
>> Yep, lots of sprites.
>> I don't know why I'm talking about
removing cuz Scuttle Crab only gives the
vision of the hand. You don't have to
pick any.
>> I didn't hear what you didn't hear that
you said that. Oh, my bad.
>> I'm so used to sabotaging mind splitter.
I'm like, "Oh, you see the hand? You
ripped the card out." But no, that is
not the case. Yellow caster does have
all of his cards.
>> Out go the two sprites and will force of
course those sand soldiers recruits back
away. And now
>> that's four points for Yellowcasta
claiming Dusk's lab.
>> Not to be outdone, we are in a defy
race. Santism actually has two Defiers
in his own hand as well. There is
currently five out of the potential six
to fives in these players hands right
now. So that is going to have a lot of
answers to what they're going to want to
do here.
>> I wonder if Yellowcaster thinks the same
has happened to Sanderson because he'll
defy something then could defy the defy.
Then the defy the defy the defy.
>> Firehead is melting with how much
defying could possibly occur here. But
obviously defy cannot respond to that
unchecked power being seven and two as
well. He will be able to wipe that board
if he does decide. Those sweepers so so
powerful here. But yellow caster, he's
deep in the thought tank here. He's
trying to decide how can he move in.
>> Just an update. We Yellow caster is the
Azia. Santism is the Lilia. So we've
updated that. I thought I saw that
before with the the deck list. Yeah, but
everything else is correct. It was just
the little names up the top. So Azia
yellow. That makes sense to me.
>> Yeah, thank you so so much for that one.
Uh, I was definitely calling that one
wrong as yes, yellow caster on the Azia,
Santism on the Lilia, we have it right
from here on out. It doesn't change the
fact there's five to fires in hands as
that sand soldier moves forward.
>> Moves in with is that the Vi as well.
>> That is that's the new ambush stun Vi.
>> Als Vi looks so good right now with that
ambush. Hands down. When Vi attacks,
they can stun an enemy unit here. And
with that ambush that does well that he
is attacking he can stun anyone who the
one remaining person on the the
battlefield.
>> Yeah it can definitely stun and he will
conquer that battlefield going to four
and he's made an advance on the second
battlefield. Ricey this is a big turn
for yellow caster able to conquer two
>> using guards to do so as well. He gets
to play two sand soldier unit tokens and
pay the power to ready it. That may have
been what happened there because those
sand soldiers are ready and on attacking
those battlefields now at five conquer
points.
>> Yeah. So we go over to Santism here.
Santism does have a full hand of runes
up. That is all 12 ready and available.
That unchecked that triple defy. It
looks like a sprite fountain there too.
Judging by the art and the energy
looking to exhaust a little more than
two here.
>> That looks like a lot. That could be the
unchecked power.
>> Oh, you're thinking uncheck.
>> It could be unchecked power. He doesn't
have a board state to slow himself down.
Santism. It could clear yellow caster
before the arise comes out, but it still
doesn't clip the gear.
>> Yeah. And I mean, unchecked power is
quite a costly spell, which means defy
can't defy it.
>> Exactly. It does get around those
Defiers, but it's going to be the two
and one instead here coming out from
Santism for that Sprite Fountain. Sprite
fountain where you get to play a ready
sprite on play and then the next turn it
will be it's temporary so it will die
and trigger that death now and gets
another sprite out comes uh what did it
was that sprite burst as well so there's
more sprites the already and then I'm
wondering if that legend also got
exhausted because one two three four
>> yep
>> in the legend down there exhausted cost
reduced because of those sprites and is
able to go in and conquer on Hall of
Legends and up Lilia Bash Bloom one more
time and is able to produce another
sprite
>> and produce it for cheaper as well
because every sprite that is on the
board Lilia Bash Bloom the ability is in
fact one uh energy less for each of
them.
>> Yeah. And it doesn't have a threshold
either. So if you have four sprites you
can reduce it to three.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. So four sprites means it's reduced
by four energy. So all you need to do is
exhaust bashful bloom to play that
readied three might sprite. But enough
about sprites. We have a soul sword
hitting the base of yellow caster's Azir
side over here. And just look at how
shiny those cards are. You can see the
surge foiling the promos. He's
definitely blinged this deck out in
preparation for appearing on camera here
for us at the Riftbound regional
qualifier in Sydney. Right.
6 Azir bling down looking quite strong
as well. Look at all those uh gears and
equipment on the board, but I mean so
are the sprites and sprites on the board
too. This is a token universe token unit
build.
>> That's the one you do love to see. It is
a token race off as Santism on six
points is potentially one win away, one
turn, my apologies, away from taking
game one here because it's that critical
even point score as we've spoken about
before. Yellow caster nipping at his
heels. Five victory points here. So, he
only needs three more himself. And it
looks like both battlefields currently
clear.
>> Yeah,
>> but Yellow Caster, his base is looking a
little bit healthy right now.
>> Quite healthy. indeed. I don't know what
cards he has. Maybe he has that needed
arise. I wouldn't say needed, but you
know, quite a strong card in Azia. I
just see Defies. That's all I see in his
hand. So many Defies.
On the other hand, Sandism also has lots
of Defies and has these sprites going in
with one sprite. Has a second sprite as
well. Did use the Lilia Bash for Bloom
to bring that out only for three energy.
>> Concede.
>> Okay. That is game.
>> That's game.
>> Yeah, cuz all Sanders need to do was
conquer. Yeah, that's it. And then you
send the sprite in and you conquer hall
of legends. You pay the one, you ready
up your legend and then you create
another sprite ready and conquer the
second battlefield.
>> Yeah, in fact, uh there's only need two
sprites and that's what Santism did
have. So, first game goes to Santism,
but this is a best of three. So, what
will happen in this next game? You can
see the two of them quite happy, quite
enjoying themselves because that's what
it's all about here at Riftbound.
>> Yeah, I definitely think they drew far
too many defies though. I I think they
had to wish that maybe, you know, on the
side of the Azir there that they did
actually hit that Arise because we saw
four pieces of equipment. If that Arise
had come down, he would have got four
two might sand soldiers for each one of
them and then read two and had some
presence on those battlefields. But
unfortunately, they were left wide open
and Santism just uh took the advantage
and he brought it home for game one.
>> He did. He did. And um I'm very curious
to see whether or not we're going to
actually see that arise. I mean, we saw
Defies, but we didn't actually even get
to see the Defies really get played.
They they knew they knew each other's
hands with that scuttle crab as well.
So, it's like these two these two decks,
they're not mirror matches cuz uh
they're not the same domains, but this
calm domain and this uh token unit kind
of makes them play very not I wouldn't
say similarly, but they have very
similar cards. Well, they both play the
very similar strategy of aggro tokens,
right? So, Azir wants to be creating
those tokens, getting them on the
battlefields nice and early with his
equipment. Lilia wants to be creating
those tokens and get them onto the
battlefields full stop to just conquer.
So, Azir typically not a old deck, but
in the face of Ailia wants to be like
conquering and Lilia wants to be
conquering. So, it forces Azir to be
that more hold style, which is just an
uncomfortable place to be if you are on
that Azir.
>> Yeah. So seeing whether or not the Zia
has an answer to this Lilia deck. I mean
the boat 6 and right right now Lilia has
that one game under their belt. So has
the pressure on the Azia on Yellow Cer
to try and turn this game around. That's
it. That's it. Yellow caster is behind
right now. Sentism up that game one.
Yellow caster has to win this one to
stay in contention with this best of
three. However, both of these gamers,
they're six and zero. They've both
locked their places into day two here.
>> That is a very good point. They will be
both heading towards day two. And as
they're both undefeated, and I would
like to say Azir and Lilia are not
they're not the top three played. I
wonder how they're going to be going for
the best of as well.
>> Yeah. No, definitely. There's always the
best of to consider when you're winning
these. There's also the seeding to
consider when you start to move towards
that second day. So even though you've
locked in your top spot, these guys,
they're here to win. They're here to
take it all. They're not just going to
go, "Oh, rest on my laurels. I've made
it to day two." No, they want to
position themselves even better, even
get that mental edge over the
competition because imagine you're a 701
and you look at 800 and you're like,
"Oh, actually that's going to be a tough
matchup."
>> Then it comes down to the legends. But
sometimes it's all about that pilot diff
as we get that respectful fist bump.
GG's telling me we're almost ready for
this game too here, Ricey.
>> Yeah, I'm wondering what battlefield's
going to be chosen. Okay, we don't have
to wander much longer. Santism will be
playing with seat of power.
>> We do love a good seat of power here.
Seat of power and ans forge. So, these
are some really good battlefields. We
love to see the variety that has been
brought here before us in unleashed.
We're seeing a lot of new unleashed
ones, but that seed of power. When you
conquer here, draw one for each other
battlefield you or your allies control.
So, that tells me that they're going to
be looking to hold. They're going to go
and conquer the other battlefield. Then,
they'll want to conquer the seat of
power to draw the two.
>> Yeah. And in the hands of Lilia being
able to bring out these ready sprites to
try and conquer both at the same time
and get that extra draw. It It's It's an
option. It's definitely an option. So
definitely Santism wants to target that
ons forge first and then proc that seat
of power as you were mentioning. Lilia
is going to be the first card played for
Santism using all three runes while
Yanukasa has already gotten that first
conquer point is going for that forge
and with that with of course that
recruit and that sand soldier.
>> Yeah, forge obviously while you control
this battlefield the first friendly
non-token gear played each turn costs
one less. So, it's all about that gear
cost reduction. So, that means those BF
swords, they're going to be cheaper. So,
clearly Azir being such an equipment
heavy deck is going to value that quite
a lot, which is why the priority has
been placed on getting the sand soldiers
there, getting the recruit there, that
eye of the Herald. They really want to
build that one up and fast. Rice
>> discipline has also been used, which
means yellow gets to draw and also buff
that sand soldier a little bit. Lilia
though is now completely in the trash.
>> That's it. Lilia trashed nice and early.
Will not be able to produce those
sprites that she desperately wants to
do. Dare I say needs to do to bring this
early aggression online. However, just
pays that full cost there.
>> Tries to get use that legend of course
Bashful Bloom to produce that sprite.
Goes in and does win that fight against
that recruit and does claim that
battlefield. Now Satism on one point and
so is Yellowcaster. But it's back to
Yellowcaster's turn.
And out comes the scuttleb
>> that staple calm unit that we've spoken
about many many a times. It's a little
menace this one. Not to be
underestimated. Yes, it doesn't have
might, but it's doing a lot of work
because sometimes that private
information that is in the hand is
critical to how you shape your plays,
the timing of your spells, when you
decide to conquer or hold, it's all
about that information. I wonder whether
how many uh turns to dust Santism has in
that deck because I believe he just
picked one up which is going to be
really good against Yellow Cluster who
has a lot of gear, a lot of equipment.
But which one do you want to use it on?
Because some of these gears, some of
these equipments are pretty cheap, some
of them are really scary.
>> Yeah, look, turn to dust is a fantastic
new card from the unleashed set. It's
only two energy and it gives a gear
temporary, so it's not going to get rid
of the gear immediately, but it
definitely puts it on the clock. forces
your opponent to get some value out of
it if and where they can. Now, some
equipment that I would imagine that
Santism would want to target would be
that BF sword. That is probably one of
the biggest pieces of equipment that
this Azir would be bringing down. We
also have that soul sword which can go
to two and maybe the brutalizer that can
be quite the shock piece, but once it's
down, it's done.
>> I think as well that turn to dust uh was
not in their main deck. So this is a
sideboard tech. Little bit of a sneak
peek cuz we don't get to see that as
casters, but I did check the the main
deck not in there. I mean, we all
assumed that there was going to be a lot
of so I think every deck has come
prepared with at least something to deal
with gears in their sideboard.
>> Yeah, 100%. But that scuttle crab is
going forward trying to conquer.
>> It has. It is going into conquer and by
comes out too. Ambush stunning the
sprite. That means I think the scuttle
crab stays alive too. It absolutely will
because that sprite will have no might
to be able to allocate back to either of
these units. Scuttle crab conquers the
battlefield.
>> Oh my goodness, this is so great to see.
Scuttle crab with zero might conquering
the battlefield. Out comes of course
yellow caster on to seed of power as
well. And remember what is the benefit
of seed of power.
>> Yeah. So seat of power when you conquer
draw one for each battlefield
controlled. So that is why you go for
that forge first then the seat of power.
So, I really like they're forcing you
kind of to sequence the the way you
conquer these battlefields, but he just
indicated that ons forge and played out
that door and shield at that reduced
cost.
>> He did remember on forge when you play
your first gear for the turn and while
you're under control of it, non-token
gear just to specify just in case. You
get to play it for one energy less. And
out comes of course that weapon master
sand soldier being able to immediately
equip. I believe that one was the eye of
Harold.
>> Yeah. Zero might. That's the eye of the
Herald.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. We we do love to see a quick equip
here in Riftban regional qualifier
Sydney.
>> And that is exactly what we got there.
That quick equip there onto that sand
soldier. And that's just the power of
Azir. It's never just going to be a two
might sand soldier. And yellow caster
though is playing around. Does have
guards. Does have hidden blade.
>> We've got some cheeky cards in hand.
>> Would you hit and blade your
um own recruit or would you try and hit
and blade a sprite? I mean, we've got
that card there now. Hide it. Hidden
hide.
>> Double hidden. It's probably one of
those hidden blades.
>> Yeah, absolutely. One of those will be
that hidden blade. We can see that it's
now no longer in the hand. And typically
the reason you include that hidden blade
is either to get rid of a massive value
unit from your opponent or it's to
target one of your own unit tokens and
get you that two card draw that massive
value to get through there. We do see
the VI and what appears to potentially
be a back off.
>> I think it was a back off
>> in the hand of yellow caster there
>> which of course back off the way that
works is it stuns. You can choose to
stun one of the enemy units and uh when
you stun, you also get that draw if you
play it from hand, but you can also hide
it as well. Um but right now, of course,
Sandersonism, it's his turn. He's going
to recycle two runes and pay one, two,
three, four, five, so seven in total.
>> Unchecked power.
>> Could be in fact that unchecked power.
>> He knows. He's smiling. There it is.
>> And that wipes the entire board clean,
Logan. Unless yellow has something in
response. And we can see his guard. He
doesn't have anything. No, not so fast.
I mean, does not so fast even.
>> So, the only thing that can really stop
this is a wind wall, which is just a
straight up hard counter, but it's
extremely expensive. This will sweep the
battlefields clean here, doing 12 damage
and getting rid of those hidden cards,
which is a fantastic value. And there it
is, the hidden guards and the hidden
hidden blade. So, Santism has to be
happy with the value he just got out of
that sweeper.
>> Yeah, quite a lot. I mean, of course,
though, uh that is a complete board
wipe. He does get to see the cards
because of that scuttle crab. And now we
can have a look too. Two turns of dust,
two on guards. I I was still looking at
that, but that's okay. We get to see it.
And so does Yellow Caster.
>> Yeah. And that's the part of being a pro
player, right? these these pro players,
they've got their notepads, they've got
their pens, they get to write down every
single card exposed in their opposing
players hands. It's that private
information that becomes public
information. And uh hopefully we get
another look, but he's putting that hand
back together and passing it over.
There's a stupify on top as well.
>> The rest will remain a mystery to us,
but Yellow Caster, he knows, and that's
the only person that it matters.
>> Exactly. The other has that information
and only has three cards in hand himself
though. So now that he knows what cards
are in hand, he has to try and work
around what Sanderson has, too.
>> Quite frankly, I think there's actually
three turn to dusts. I did see two at
least.
>> I saw two. You think there's three?
>> There could potentially be I saw another
blue card at the back there, but it
remains to be seen because this is an
exciting matchup here between two
tokenheavy decks. As you said, we
haven't really seen Lilia able to come
online and do much right now though,
Rice.
>> Yeah, having that faith be completely
taken out of the game in that f second
round or so means Zandism has to try and
find spells, has to try and find gear
that will be able to bring those sprites
back. Otherwise, has to rely on that
legend, which does cost four, but at the
moment, he's going to be using a five
ability. Yeah, I thought it might be
sprite burst, which does bring out two.
ready sprite tokens.
>> Yeah, that's what you want. You're able
to present those units, the ready units
so quickly. Yes, they have temporary,
but they get you ahead. So, he's going
to conquer that forge, which is what we
called at the start. If you're going to
go for both at the same time, gets
forge, then go for that seed of power to
get that cheeky two card draw. And we do
see Santism's points currently up at
four to yellow casters three. So,
Santism must be happy with that. And
that's private information that Santism
has that Yellowcaster doesn't now after
that hand reveal. There's more unknown.
So Yellowcaster has to play that much
more carefully.
>> Exactly. Has to be careful here. Doesn't
know what that single card that
Sanderson Drew is. But we can kind of
see what Yellow Caster has here with
those three gears. And uh of course Azia
out in play as well.
>> Yeah, I have Herald, Ivald, and Dorian
Shield. But that is Azir Sovereign. Aziz
sovereign is that champion unit does
love to move those tokens around and uh
recently they people were teching the
Azir sovereign into the Leblanc decks
but they uh changed up how those sort of
token copies work so will not be seen in
the Leblanc there but the Azir sovereign
reads four energy and has accelerate so
you may pay one extra energy and recycle
an order rune when I attack you may move
any number of your token units to this
battlefield
>> at the moment So just going to be
equipping that Dawn's shield and going
in against the Sprite. Currently four
might versus three in the showdown. But
this is of course a common mind deck.
Out comes one. We I mean yellow cast
knows there's an on guard. We he
literally saw it just a round or two
ago. I think there were two from memory
as well. So yellow cast I'm sure is very
well prepared on guard. Give a friend
unit plus one this turn. Then an
additional plus one if it is the only
unit you control there. And last is the
only one there.
>> Yeah, we do see a discipline placed down
into the base from yellow caster as
well. He's exhausted his runes here just
to force something more out of Santism's
hand. Santism deliberating. He's paid
the one and one.
>> Out comes the defy. We know defies are
so common amongst these two players.
Going to be defying that discipline. H
which means he doesn't get that card
draw as well. Yeah, it's a really good
one to prevent uh resolving there. No
two might, no card draw for you, so no
card advantage.
>> Be interesting to see how Yellowcaster
plays this one off. He's leaving it on
the base. He's checking his runes.
>> That looks expensive to me. 1 2 3 4 5.
It might be the buy which does stun on
play. It is an ambush.
>> Just explaining how he's paid for it
all.
comes in
will use all those runes and of course
for Cycl one that does stun the sprite.
It might be a bit costly in this turn
but yellow caster does win that
battlefield going to four points.
>> Every point matters here and is going to
pass the turn after hiding something on
Forge here as well. Yellow caster did
conquer that battlefield and Santism.
It's now Santism on the play here.
channels those runes, draws his card.
Both players, four victory points a
piece. It's getting tense here in this
game, too.
>> Yeah, it's pretty tense indeed. I mean,
Sanderson does have that one game up.
It's currently one zero in Sanderson's
favor right now. So, it it definitely is
Yellow Class's game to try and win and
stay in this series. But Sandism, we
know how Lilia works, of course, with
those sprite tokens. at any moment he
can still play those four use four
energies to play that one ready sprite
and could use it to conquer seed of
power.
>> Absolutely. Obviously, it's not maximum
value, but it is still somewhat nice
value there. We do get a look at the
trash of yellow caster. We can see the
hidden blade, the vi, there's a
discipline, two disciplines, the scuttle
crab guards and charm. So, that
obviously reduces the potential
responses that yellow caster has into
what Santism wants to do. Disarming
rake. When you play me, you may kill a
gear. And of course going to be choosing
that Doran's shield trying to reduce the
might of these uh defenders on Forge.
Out comes that ready sprite via Lilia's
bashful bloom and is actually going to
go for that seed of power. Not going to
contest on Forge.
>> I really do like Disarming Rake. This is
a spirit forge card that a lot of people
have started teching into gear heavy
decks. So I would expect to see this
into things like Jax, Lucian, also
Auroras, but especially Aziz as well,
who loves their gear as we're
deliberating our next play. Two runes
up. Santism
is tempting fate. He's teasing us all
here with that slow play of those two
mind runes.
>> I don't know what Yellowcaster was
looking at, but if he was comparing
legends, I mean, Yellow Castle, yours is
impressive. All right, we see that as a
signature. We see that as a 9.5 rating
as well. Absolutely amazing. Um, Azia,
Emperor of the Sands of
>> Yeah, he's probably just looking at the
Lilia Bashful Bloom going, you know, you
could get this graded, mate. This could
be like a 9.5. Great centering there.
But just a cheeky little look here as
yellow caster playing with the runes,
counting them up, making sure he has
enough energy, enough power to make the
plays that he wants to to start trying
to close this one out.
>> Oo, Ash gets played. Now, Ash is such an
interesting uh CH unit being played cuz
when you play me, you may choose an
opponent, they reveal their hand. So,
once again, Yellow Casa gets that
information. You can choose a card
revealed this way and completely banish
it. But when your opponent holds, you
have to return it to their hands. Even
if, of course, Ash has been trashed.
>> Yeah. Yeah, what I'm really liking is
this one's actually been sideboarded
into a lot of order decks in answer to
auroras because you are literally able
to pluck that Aurora out and banish it.
Just removing it from play entirely and
shutting that down. But it looks like
yellow caster. We see two turn to dusts
an on guard and a stupify.
>> Looks like it's going to be discipline
that is banished. You can see it on top
of the Lilia bashful bloom. And so that
is sort of what people like to put for
the the banish zone. Yeah, it looks like
he's actually put it off to the side
there. So, we don't actually get to see
that discipline banished off the side of
this one, but we do Oh, the judge has
heard us and he's made his way back to
the battlefield for us.
>> So, yeah, Discipline is the one that
they banish. So, now Yellow Cluster is
also quite aware of what Santism has in
the hand. They know there's two turn to
dust, which means that has to be careful
of the gear that he has.
>> Yeah, we're back onto Santism now,
though. That sprite being temporary has
whisked away. Importantly, that happens
before you conquer and before you get
those points, so they're good to conquer
with, but they're not great to hold with
here. Icy as disarming rake on the base
for Santism. And that's about all he has
right now. If we can get a peak, we do
know the turn to duster there. The ong
guard as well.
>> I don't know what he drew though in this
beginning of the turn. Is that another
disarming? No, we saw the D.
>> Yeah. No, another disarming rake.
>> Oh, that was the one he drew.
>> Yeah. Well, that does get rid of
potentially he could get rid of three
gears if he so wanted. But of course,
what I think he actually also wants is
that seed of power and of course once
forge.
>> Yeah. But do you see this right
disarming rake when you play me? Kill a
gear. Yeah.
>> Turn to dust. Turn to dust. All of your
gear is gone. In fact, there's not even
enough gear on yellow caster's side for
Santism to have to use it all right now.
And Yellow Cast knows Santism has that.
But Lilio Bash for Bloom is going to
produce another ready sprite.
>> Produces it indeed with that legend
exhausted. In goes the sprite trying to
contest the Ash and the Azia. It's a
three to eight at the moment, but I mean
we all know Santa's card has that
stupifier. Going to be able to get a
draw unless yellow has something to say
about it.
>> There is that hidden card. He's just
double checking making sure if he wants
to reveal it now or wait till after.
thinking, deliberating,
>> writing notes.
>> Writing notes as well. Remember, what
did he see from with that ash in Santa's
hand?
>> That's it. And just like them, I write
notes. So, I'm basically a professional
player, I see.
>> Oh, yeah. I believe you.
>> No, thank you.
>> Yeah, I totally believe you.
>> Yeah, I'm the losingest Kaiser in
Victoria.
>> Oh, I is that that is a professional
position to be in.
>> All right, decisions being made. Stupify
does resolve. Puts that minus one might
onto Azia sovereign. Gets that card
draw.
>> And there is the hidden card. It is back
off going to be stunning the sprite. And
now if Sanderson has nothing to to
answer to that, that sprite is just
going to not deal any damage. Either
bounce off or be of course turned I was
going to say turn to dust, but that is
an actual card evaporated into the air.
>> It will absolutely go back into the
Nether here because Ash and Azir are not
stunned and they will be able to assign
their might in combat damage back to
that sprite and they win that sort of
fight at that showdown there. Uh the the
battlefield is certainly well in control
of yellow caster. However, we do see the
disarming rake gets moved in and uh
picked up a conquest point and drawn a
card.
>> Exactly.
Uh with Santism now on six points is on
that, you know, that that amount of
points that you want to maybe win the
next round. So he starts building up his
base once more, has that another
disarming rank in the base, and will of
course be destroying one of those gear.
>> Yeah. So he actually took out one of the
eye of the heralds. That was the one
that was equipped to that vi the ambush
stun that we did see a little bit
earlier. So he's just played it just to
develop his board here. Get some units
down. It is.
>> He's like, I've paid enough. What are we
doing? Oh, he forgot two champion cards.
But he was so excited about that Ash.
Out comes that Ash, which means he gets
to see Santerson's hand once more and
can banish another
another card.
>> Yeah. And the interesting thing about
this is choose a card. So, it doesn't
worry about gear, unit, spell. It can
banish anything. And I'm really loving
that people were kind of sleeping on
this Ash. Uh, except Patriot Time. Patri
time actually predicted this as one of
his cards and then here it is highly
represented in these order decks
banishing away these key pieces from
their opponents.
>> Out comes a stupify from Sanderson
probably wanting that card draw as well
wanting an answer to this Ash but I
don't really know what's going to happen
here cuz of course yellow card has so
many units in base too as well.
Sanderson wants to be able to hold on
that previous one. Out comes the on
guard as well and now showing all the
cards. Yeah, tried to play as much out
of his hand as he could get the value
the card draws off that stupify off that
Ong Guard there too. Except sorry, Ong
Guard does not give card draw. That's
discipline.
>> Trying to avoid banishment here from
Yellow Casta, but he does go for that
discipline.
>> Now there's two disciplines being
banished and in yellow goes onto seed of
power. He wants to contest. He wants to
win. And he does in fact win that uh
that showdown and quite quickly too
which does mean yellow caster gets that
extra job because of the seed of power.
>> Yellow caster now seven conquest points
here. He only needs to hold to win.
Santism has to do everything to push
yellow caster off both of these
battlefields here. Rice.
>> Yeah, it's going to be quite a difficult
battle. But look at those runes. If I
can count correctly, it's around about
11 available to Sanderson right now. And
though we know what cards he has, he has
to kind of top deck something really
strong.
>> He actually has 12. There were no runes
left in the rune deck on the side. So he
is at maximum runes here right now.
>> Let's see what he top decked. See if he
has something that could take back this
game. Of course, those sprites going to
be ready at any time. Is that unchecked?
>> No, it's it's not. It's actually going
to be the Thousand Tower Watcher.
>> You know what? You were also right. It
was uh 11 just to make sure. Yeah.
>> But Thousand Tail will be landing on the
base. Has recycled two runes. Will be
applying that minus three might to all
enemy units. Just such a strong classic
powerful mind finisher here, Ricey. And
it is good to see it played. He was able
to top deck it so it managed to avoid
all of the banishing that he was trying
to get done with those Ash Focus. pretty
lucky top deck there for Santa is still
in the game. Is obviously wanting to as
well conquer both battlefields. I
believe he may have accelerated it as
well cuz he did use two recycled powers
to be able to pay for it. So that is a
ready Thousand Tower Watcher can go in
and potentially conquer both
battlefields. Don't forget as well
Lilia, but I don't think he can pay for
Lilia with only three powers up. Yeah,
he doesn't have any other sprites, so
there's no cost reduction in play for
that Lilia Bashful Bloom. A sprite out
of her would cost four energy and in one
exhaust. As we are doing the math here,
seeing how much negative might that the
thousand tail has applied. So, it's
three on every enemy unit. There's five
enemy units. That's minus 15 might
that's happened to yellow caster right
now. And he's just thinking, how best
can I answer this thousand tailed
Watcher? That's such an effective
finisher. I see.
>> Well, he looks a bit stressed because he
didn't expect the thousand tower
watcher. Remember that was a top deck
card. He knows every other card that's
in his hand except that Thousand Tower
Watcher came completely a surprise to
Yellowcaster. Now doing that maths. If I
do quick math myself, buy is on two. Uh
crates are still at one because it's to
a minimum of maximum of
>> to a minimum of one
>> max minimum not maximum of one. Um so
that's still four
might. Did I m three might
>> three might
>> three might on cedar power
>> which critically brings it into kill
range of the disarming rake.
>> It is it looks like it's just game. They
conceded
>> that's game. Yeah,
>> that yellow had no answers to Santism. I
think it is actually completely GG. Two
zero.
>> Uh I have to think that yellow caster
has won this one here. He was in the
better position. I think Santism didn't
have the ability to swing in and take
both.
>> They are shuffling.
>> I didn't finish doing my maths in my
head. So I was I'm not able to do the
calculation. So
>> that is a Okay.
Yeah, look at that. Good spirits. It is
starting to get late here in Sydney as
well. These guys, this is round seven.
They've been at this for a long time.
And as I called, yellow caster takes
game two here tonight in our best of
three match.
>> That thousand tar watcher could have
been what um Santism needed, but it just
wasn't enough. Did quite a lot to
everybody on the board, but of course
was not able to completely take both
battlefields, which is what he needed.
He needed both battlefields.
>> Yeah, absolutely. That Thousand Tail
Watcher wouldn't have been able to move
in and clear that battlefield. The
disarming rake would have been able to
trade on the oppo o o o o o o o o o o o
o o o o o o o o o opp opposite
battlefield, but it just as we said not
enough. Had to prevent holding at least
one and just could not get it done with
the tools in hand and they knew it. And
this is one of the things that you see
in the professional play, right? A lot
of the times they know when they don't
have those lines. A lot of the times
they know when they're beat and they're
willing to concede. It saves time. It
saves mental exhaustion and it gets you
back into the next game where you have a
better chance of winning. Yeah, I mean
this is a long day. We're in round
seven. There's only there's one more
round after this for today and then of
course tomorrow there's a another eight
or so rounds as well to go through. And
with this one here, we also have to keep
in mind that timer, that clock, as you
mentioned, they want to be able to get
through game three quickly. They don't
want to end on a draw. Neither of them
win if it's a draw. So, they want to try
and win, of course, this third game.
>> Absolutely. It's in everyone's best
interest to take that win here. As we do
start to get prepared for our game
three, we do take a look back at the
battlefields we've seen already. That
Dusk Rose Lab, that seat of power for
Santism, Forge, and Hall of Legends for
Yellow Caster there. So, just a really
nice selection of battlefields, ones
we're not overly used to seeing here.
You know, typically it's that Raven
Bloom, that abandoned hall. They've
definitely increased in popularity now
with Unleash coming out.
>> Well, there's only one battlefield each
that they can play. Looks like it's
going to be the arena's
greatest for Bashful Bloom theoretically
as something magical happens
>> and Trifarian War Camp for Santism I do
believe.
>> Yeah, going to be quite exciting.
Arena's greatest as we I think most of
us are familiar with Arena's greatest.
It um
>> of course gives you that one extra
point.
>> There it is. Arena's greatest for
Santism as you call Trafarian War Camp
for yellow car. So that was my mistake
there sayingism and that is expected.
The arena's greatest obviously giving
them that extra conquer point in their
beginning of their first turn. So this
will be potentially a much quicker a
much more explosive game three
>> to decide who wins this round seven.
Round seven, a game three, one between
these two calm and token decks. Not a
mirror match, but it's a mirror, I would
say, emotions between the two of them as
well. They want to go in with their
wonderfully buffed, stacked, geared up
tokens. And well, Lilia is going to be I
believe starting out has those two runes
up and he's going to be using both of
those two runes to bring out a scuttle
cry.
>> Turn one play always good. He's like,
I'm not even ready yet. What are you
doing?
But the play has been made by Santism.
He is going second. He's got those three
gorgeous order runes. We also got a
quick peak there. A defy in hand, but he
gets that sand soldier and equips it
immediately. He does equip it
immediately with that dorman's blade
shield, sorry. Um, plus one is a tank as
well. So that's a little bit of a chunky
sand soldier at three might. And of
course the scuttle crab has zero, but
will be able to conquer the arena's
greatest.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Scuttle crab just
proving that he is indeed the arena's
greatest there with that conquer. But
Rice, you said Dorian's shield a little
earlier and as we know there's Dorian's
blade in the game, too. But did you know
in League of Legends they've added
Doran's helm and Doran's bow? And it
makes me wonder, are they going to bring
that to Riftbound as well?
>> Surely. Surely. We have all the Doran's
uh gear.
>> Yeah.
>> And it would be great to have the
variety. I mean, maybe they'll go into
every single domain, but we don't want
to miss this mask of foresight. Just got
played when a friendly unit attacks the
defense alone. Give it plus one this
turn. Very strong gear in the hands of a
Lilia who loves those sprites. Yeah,
definitely a nice piece of tech that we
also see in those AR decks. There is
also a Raven Bloom out there now. So,
it's going to be able to swing on its
own as a three might and then any spells
that come through, any spell slinging
that Santism is able to offer it is just
going to bolster it up even further.
We've seen it all before. We know and
love that Raven Bloom student as Yellow
Cer is considering his options.
>> I mean, one option is that Trifarian War
camp. It's tempting. And I can see
yellow cast are thinking about it.
Looking of course at the other cards in
hand right now, but easy conquer point
for them and looking at it here have
plus one on Trifarian War camp and
instead he's actually going to contest
the arena's greatest and going to have
to of course reveal the hand due to that
scuttle crab. I actually think that was
why he decided to go into the scuttle
crab to give the reveal over early
before he's developed a hand a plan with
it and then he'll go into the trifarian
war camp a little bit later. I actually
like this. I think this is quite heads
up from yellow caster just to be like
look I know you're going to get to see
my hand but I'm going to time when you
get to see my hand. You get as little
information as I can possibly give you.
And there's that vi one more time. That
assault stun powerhouse that just turns
combat showdowns around.
>> Thinking about Doran Shield,
but lots of options here for Yellow
Caster. Trifarian War Camp is uh
probably not going to be able to be
conquered this turn. So, Yellow Caster
thinking about what to do for the next
turn.
>> Definitely has five runes up and is
looking to develop that board state,
right? You want to make sure that you've
got some plays to be able to respond to.
has that door and shield, creates that
sand soldier, and plays guards.
>> Gods.
>> Well, when you do play guards, I lie
because this is the way you can conquer.
You may pay an extra power to ready it.
You get to play that sand soldier and
ready one. And that does mean that
yellow does in fact get that trifaren
war camp. And we've got to remember
trifaren war camp. They do have that
plus one.
>> Yeah, you have plus one might. This also
includes attackers in those brackets. It
cannot be forgotten. Typically, we see
this in decks that care about being
mighty. Fiora Victorious, for example,
when she moves on to that, she becomes
mighty, gets those triggers and buffs up
quite a lot. So, in this situation,
it'll be quite interesting because the
sprite will swing in as a four might
into a sand soldier, which natively is a
three might, but because of all the
equipment will then also be a four. So,
we're just trading bigger tokens. Rice.
>> Yeah, bigger tokens. And uh, of course,
the other thing with Santism playing
Lilia, those sprites will have
temporaries, so it's hard for him to
build up a little army. On the other
hand, Yellow Caster could have more and
more units. And each of those units will
also have plus one. So, it could be
quite a hard battlefield for Sanderson
to take back control of if Yellowcaster
builds a base there. Yeah, as this
sprite burst does come out, I just want
to call out. We got some cheers from the
crowd here. And Yellowcaster flexed to
his fans in the audience, which you do
love to see. Good spirits here from both
of these players and the audience. But
Santism is on that fourpoint break point
here. Half way to that eight point
victory condition. And Yoliccasta
currently sitting on three.
>> Yeah, using that sprite burst to of
course win those take down that sand
soldier. As you said, they were both on
four. So, one of them gets sacrificed,
but the other one will in fact conquer
it. So, Sandism now on four points.
Well, Yellow Caster on three, but still
thinking, what do we do next?
>> Yeah, yellow caster is on the play. Has
that BF sword, has that VI in hand,
still holding on to the Defy and what
looks like a discipline as well. So,
will be able to pump some units up and
over Santism. Importantly, Santism
though, only one rune available to play
with right now. Yeah, I mean one run
though in the hands of a calm deck. We
can think of quite a few options there.
You know, defy um on guard is one for
fire as well.
>> Fire is one. Oh, we see the on guard. We
see two on guards. In fact,
>> he's thinking which one do I want to
play?
>> Which one looks less pretty? Uh I'll
hold that and I'll get the good one out
here as we do like see the thought
process going on these lines that are
developing. That's a singularity in
Santism's hand. That is a big removal
piece.
>> Well, the one on guard did get played by
Santism and so Yellowcaster responds
with Defy. So that on guard doesn't come
through. So it is going to be
Yellowcaster's battlefield still.
>> I still like that play. He forced Yellow
Cer to have it. That Defy is now one
less tool that Yellowcaster has to be
able to respond to Santism's plays next
turn. Yellow casta though with that
conquer does go up to four on that
trifarian war camp
>> but you did mention being forced to use
that as a fight. He's now at four
exhausted runes right now compared with
Sandism. I don't want to do I don't want
to do counting but 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 eight.
I can kind of count eight there just
loosely.
>> Yeah, there's eight.
>> I believe you.
>> No, you're right this time. I'm not
going to correct you cuz you're right.
That's eight.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Yeah, I believe you. Of course, Raven
Bloom student is in the base and ready.
Maybe wants to go up and get that
arena's greatest.
>> Yeah, that's true. Actually, that Raven
Bloom student has been sitting there for
a hot second.
>> I really do think Santism is trying to
find those stupifies, that other tech
that he has, the the cheaper sort of
mine spells to be able to get that Raven
Bloom bolstered up. But if it goes in
alone, that mask of foresight gives that
extra might as well. But Lilia Bash
Bloom just going to produce one of those
sprites. He's thinking, do I go in with
both? Do I go in with one? As you said,
that Masco force does get that little
buff. He's going to go in with just the
sprite. See how he can deal against this
sand soldier. Remember, yellow cluster
completely exhausted. Out comes
discipline, of course, with that
discipline. Sanderson does in fact win
that conquer.
>> Yeah. No, he absolutely conquered that
battlefield. That mask of foresight is
proving to be a thorn in the side of
yellow caster where that would have
traditionally been an even trade. that
extra one might pushes it over the top
in combination with that discipline. So,
excellent play there from Santism and
set up with that mask of foresight. Four
runes exhausted from Santism there. And
yellow caster just thinking on the play.
What can he do? Two more runes have been
exhausted. That was for that discipline
as you called. And the one and one, two
and one here, sorry.
>> There's going to be a Sprite fountain.
And now comes one ready spider immedely
going on to that arena's greatest. And
of course it's a temporary gear. It's a
very interesting gear because it is
temporary. And so when he plays it, you
get to play one ready sprite unit. You
when the death triggers out comes
another sprite unit. You got to love
sprites in Lilia. That is what she wants
and that is what this deck is built
around. And uh it was interesting.
Yellow caster actually started to
prepare to remove that BS sword. Fully
expecting I think a turn to dust for
that sprite fountain taking him. And I
dare say all of us by surprise currently
does have I think it's around six runes
up. They are very beautiful runes as
well. These alt arts are chef's kiss
here. But can we get a little insight
that Vi is still in Yellow Cast's hand
as he goes to take a look at the trash
of Santism. As a reminder, you can check
your opponent's trash at any time. It is
public information, so that is totally
fine.
>> Of course, I if I remember correctly, I
think yellow cluster, no, it was yellow
that had to reveal his deck to
Sanderson. I don't think Yellow Caster
has been able to see Sanderson's deck
just yet with an Ash or with um with a
scuttle crab.
>> Yeah. No, I haven't seen one of those
come out just yet. We do see that soul
sword, we do see that VI, and we do see
that discipline. So a few options
available to yellow caster here as he
has exhausted and recycled one here.
>> Equipping both the domes shield and the
BF sword going to be taking down that
little spider. I mean it is a little bit
of a buff sprite with that mask for but
not that buff.
>> Yeah. No, I don't think it can contest a
two might sand soldier with that door
and shield that BF sword and the extra
might from the Trifarian war camp on
that battlefield. So, Yellowcaster doing
the minimum he needs to do here to still
conquer and get these points. However,
the play has gone back to Santism.
>> Santism uh very importantly is on six
points as well. If he conquers both
here, he wins the game. Look how many
ranges got up. I don't want to count
that again. But look at also the uh the
units he has in base. He has one ready
sprite and of course that Raven Bloom
student also of course has the option to
bring another ready sprite with that
Lilia Bash Bloom and I don't know what
else he has in his cards but in his
hands but he may have something
something else to play.
>> Yeah, look Ricey nine runes is a lot of
runes to have in like ready on your side
of the board. Santism considering his
options deeply that lilting lulli that
signature spell for Lilia able to
counter a spell and then your opponent
can't cast spells for the rest of their
turn. It's very very strong and at
reaction speed. So
>> quite the answer if Yellowcaster has a
spell to play and we do know he does
have that discipline.
>> It's going to be potentially Singularity
looking at it paying the cost of it. Out
it comes. Singularity is such a
heavyhitting spell. He deals six to each
of up to two units. And there's only one
unit on the board.
>> Yep, that's okay. He's just going to put
the six into the sand soldier here.
>> Oh, I think he forgot about the
Trifarian War camp.
>> Is that not enough? Is I mean that sand
soldier has plus three from the BF has
one from the Doran's blade. It is six in
the total. And you're right with that
triband war cap. It's not strong enough.
>> It takes it over the top to seven might.
Singularity,
dare I say, unfortunately wasted. Does
have six points of damage on it.
>> Does have six points. So maybe it's not
completely over just yet. That sprite
still does three damage in and of
itself. Um I mean technically for a
trifarian war camp.
>> There's still options available like you
said. Send the sprite in, force the
discipline out, lilting laby counter and
shut down the rest of his turn, but it's
going to get so little value with the
rest of the turn.
>> Don't forget also that Raven Bloom
student could then just conquer the
other battlefield too. There is still a
chance that Santism can take this second
game.
>> Here and now. Here and now. It It's the
third game. If Sprite goes in and
trades, he removes the sand soldier from
this battlefield. However, the Sprite
will not live. The lilting lullaby will
counter the discipline. The Raven Bloom
will go into the arena's greatest. So,
this will take Santism to seven if
that's how it plays out. But he still
has to win next turn.
>> Oh, we forgot about the Vi. The Vi comes
out, stuns the sprite.
And well,
at that point, well, I mean, Zandm still
can uh I believe Oh, no. Cuz he has no
damage. He's stunned.
>> Yeah. So VI is a fantastic response.
Sprite now has zero might to be able to
allocate to anybody on that battlefield.
So this is a great heads up play here
from Yellowcaster. He did hold up all of
those runes to have that as an option
available to him. Those six points
marked on that sand soldier token. If
this combat showdown ends as it stands
currently, it'll just heal back up to
full and Santism won't get another
chance like this.
>> Santism has three runes up. has to do
other calculations. How do I do this? I
mean, yes, the sand soldier has six
damage, but he's still seven mighty. Out
comes that discipline. Able to get that
draw. Are you going to be able to get
something good from that card draw?
>> Digging for answers here, but with a
stunned sprite.
>> It effectively reduces your might to
zero. You can't deal combat damage.
>> Yeah.
Oh.
As the trade has occurred,
Trafarian War Camp with the might
increase sends in the Raven Bloom
student for the sevenpoint conquer.
Santism wins the battlefield.
>> He does now on seven, but he's not able
to win this entire game just yet. And I
don't think actually Yellow has an
answer to that. So, he wins off the
hole. That's it. It looks like Sanderson
does take the entire game.
>> There it is.
They're both going. That was game three.
Santism wins round seven. 21 against
Yellow Caster on the Azir. Santism on
that. Lilia Bashful Bloom. That new set
three unleash legend and one of your
favorites. Ricey.
>> It is. Lilia is such a fun joy to play.
I mean, you produce so many sprites just
absolutely everywhere and it's it's
really fun to play um in general.
Yeah, as we're still going through the
motions there, obviously the judges
having a chat with the players, just
discussing that last play and how it
happened. So, uh, that'll be a learning
lesson. But we're getting these
panoramic sweeping camera shots, which I
am a fan of. And that I think that was a
great matchup, Ricey. The only other
sort of unit token that I can think of
is that Victor. So, we did get to see
two out of three here tonight.
>> Yeah, I mean, those token units are so
fun to play. I mean, being able to
produce as many as you want. Really, if
you have the resources, out they come.
Out they come. You don't need the number
of cards. You just need to have those
resources.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Resources make sprites.
Sprites make conquer points. And sprites
with conquer points win games. And that
is exactly what we saw here. He didn't
even need that lilting ly here tonight,
Ricey, as he's now seven and zero
already guaranteed into day two. But
he's just making himself look that much
better. is Santism.
>> Yeah, wondering if Santism is a
contender for that best of Lilia. 7 to
zero is a pretty good score to go in. I
mean to potentially maybe we got one
more round left. Could end 8-0 could end
7-1. And that is a really good score to
end day one.
>> And one thing I like is he's wearing a
Australia shirt here too. Just
absolutely repping right now getting
prepped for that interview. And one of
my favorite parts about these interviews
is actually getting these insights into
the minds of these players. Right. Why
did you pick that card when you were
building that deck? Why did you choose
that particular line to conquer that
battlefield or to prevent it being
conquered? And uh yeah, it's in these
decks there's so many tools. There's so
many answers and it's why do you play
that then that singularity still proved
useful putting those six points of
damage onto that sand soldier.
>> Exactly. you know, so many useful cards.
I mean, in both of their decks, but it's
so fun to see the the thought process
behind them because these are kind of
the I won't say not kind of these are
the best of the best here in Australia
and it's great to see their insights.
Why did they pick those decks and what
do they choose and how do they come to
the conclusion that this is potentially
the best of deck?
>> Yeah, look, I'd be so bad at these
interviews, right? If someone said to
me, why did you pick that legend? I'd be
like, the art was absolutely sick. But
let's hear from Santism, the winner of
round seven.
>> Thank you very much, Logan. That was
quite this series. I'm here with
Santiago.
>> Santiago. Yeah.
>> From Argentina originally.
>> Originally from Argentina, but I live
here in Sydney.
>> How long have you lived in Sydney for?
>> Uh, around 80 years.
>> How do you like it?
>> Yeah, I love it.
>> Yeah, it's my favorite. I'm from here,
so it's my favorite city.
>> Yeah. Nice.
>> So, uh, how long have you played
Riftbound for?
>> Uh, I started playing like a few weeks
ago. Yeah.
>> Uh yeah, I play Lorana, which is a
different car game. And yeah, since the
original was here in Sydney, we said
like, "Ah, it'll be fun to go play." We
picked it up, practice a little bit
online, and here we are. Yeah. Having
>> So, how did you settle on Lilia as your
legend?
>> Uh, so we wanted to go for a side quest,
you know, like try to get the the best
of card. Yep.
>> Uh so we because we picked it up not
long ago, we decided to go for one of
the new legends and Lilia was the one
that Yeah. we enjoyed the most and we
decided to go for that one.
>> Yeah. Uh so far it's working quite well.
It was still undefeated after six
rounds. Guaranteed to make there too.
How have you found the deck?
>> Yeah, very good. Very good. Yeah, I'm
I'm really enjoying it. Uh the play
style is very good. Having fun, which is
the important thing. So yeah.
>> So you definitely had a couple of
moments in that series that uh were
tricky.
>> Yeah. That was the end of a few misplays
as well. A few misplays as well. But
yeah, it was my first time on on stream
or um so I was quite nervous. Uh but
yeah, luckily I
>> I could make it.
>> Yeah, found the line in the last game.
And game two, I believe you had a line
as well at the end of game two.
>> Yeah. No, I I actually miscounted and I
thought that I could take the ball, but
I couldn't. So, but yeah, was Yeah, very
good. Very good. When Ash When Ash
looked at your hand, you
>> played the on guard
>> to pump the
>> Yes. Yes. Uh I didn't realize that uh it
was when when she attacks that he stuns.
That was my Yeah. One of the misplays.
>> I mean, the set has not been out for
very long, right? It got released a
little over a week ago. What has it been
like testing for such a wide field, so
many different decks?
>> Yeah. Well, for me, it was all new. So,
I started with set three, so every
single deck was new. Uh so yeah, it was
a lot of information to take. Uh a lot
of legends, a lot of different cards. So
>> yeah, we're still learning. Yeah,
>> every game with every game I'm learning.
>> Well, uh you've learned enough to still
be undefeated. How are you feeling about
your chances in day two moving forward?
Maybe winning that best of.
>> Uh look, I'm very happy with the results
I've I've accomplished so far. So just
one game game at a time and we'll see
how it goes.
>> Well, best of luck. We'll see you
tomorrow.
>> Yeah, thank you so much.
>> All right, back to the casters.
Thank you so much, Pastry. What a
wonderful insight we're hearing from
this three-w weekek old player.
>> Yeah, you love to see it. So many new
players coming to Riftbound. But a point
of clarification from that previous game
as well, that VI only stuns when she's
an attacker, which is how Santism was
able to take over that battlefield
there. So, really good piece of
information to have. But as you say,
only three weeks in Riftbound. So many
new players here coming from previous
other TCGs as well. And so many from
League of Legends.
>> Exactly. Yeah, League of Legends
players. And right now we are in the
middle of game three of our other
featured match. It's going to be quite
exciting as these are also kind of neck
and neck as well. Five points to four
points. Stigits the master Yi 6-0.
Current uh I think the only that's
currently 6-0 in this uh in the regional
qualifier so far.
>> It is good to see a Y here. Currently 6
with three XP up as well. So that is
that sort of XP variant that cares about
it. However, we do see the legend that
is the one when I defend alone. I get
that two might. We do see Aurelia
Fervent here. They are in the midst of a
showdown. Aelia with that plus five is
currently nine with the gear 10 might.
>> Very very strong. Of course, every time
you target her or choose her Aia, she
gets plus one. So now Ral Dogs is able
to get themselves onto five points each.
This may end in a draw because looks
like time is over.
>> Yeah, we do see the time. So that looks
like they will be going into that
overtime here. And we see that Trinity
Force on the base force digit the Wu
sort of bladesman Yei there while the
friendly unit defends alone. He gets
plus two might which can be forgotten
about quite easily. But we see that XP
tracker down the bottom there being used
very very well. Showing that 3 XP which
is that new mechanic from Unleashed
here. All right, I see
>> Clockwork Cooper is going to be used
here. And when you play Clockwork
Keeper, you may pay a power to draw one.
I feel like he did use that. It looks
like uh Stig is trying to find the cards
that he has wanted. I may have missed
that recycle happening, but lots of
cards in hand, lots of options, but the
time is uh the time is over. So, we're
in overtime right now. Both of them are
five each, which they definitely want to
get that two-point lead.
>> Yeah, you definitely want to get ahead
here in the next couple of turns.
Otherwise, it will be that draw. And
obviously, you don't want to lose, but
you also don't want to draw. A win is
always worth so much more. And we do see
that Za's hourglass as well for Rald
Dogs on the Aurelia. So, has that
protection and I have to believe that's
a guardian angel. Ooh, that's a good
card to be playing.
>> It is indeed. Don't forget also that
Trinity Force as well. When I hold score
one point, that could be what you need
to uh get as many points as possible. is
going to be equipped onto Rengar the
trophy hunter who does have ambush not
going to be using as ambush but he also
can be played to an open battlefield
build if he chooses to do so at the
moment though he is trying to make him
as strong as possible and of course the
double points
>> yeah this Rengar trophy hunter is
definitely a superstar in this Wu
bladesman legend when it defends alone
it gets that extra two might and
typically because you can ambush it onto
that enemy battlefield even if you don't
have units suddenly you present an eight
might unit that they have to overcome
here. However, not ambushed. Gets that
plus two from the Trinity Force onto the
six might. Rengar for a total of eight.
Presenting here as we're taking it all
in. We're looking at our options. Is
Stig has a few cards, a few tricks up
his hand,
but we don't know what they are.
>> No, he just jumped into this game, this
next match. So, we have no idea what has
been happening so far. But Ral Dogs,
it's his turn right now. He wants of
course to get to at least seven, maybe
eight as quickly as possible in this
overtime round right now. H has quite a
few runes up and we can't see his cards.
He's kind of off to the side a little
bit. But what is he wanting to play
here? What would you think would be the
best card?
>> Yeah, I mean it's an Aurelia deck.
There's not much that you play that
isn't going to be the best card to pump
that Aurelia up. She's been reading so
she has that plus one might as Rodogs is
looking for some options here. currently
at that six conquer points has that
abandoned hall. So when a player plays a
spell, they may give a unit they control
here plus one might this turn. So if a
defiant dance is to be played, it's not
going to be that four might swing. It's
going to be much much bigger in the
realm of at least six. Plus four for the
Aurelia, minus two for the opponent.
However, currently sitting on that grove
of the Godwillow, when you hold, you may
draw one card, but right now we're not
worried about holding. And Rod Dog's
taking a lot of time to consider his
options. This is critical.
>> Thinking about putting more units on to
the grove, including the lonely parro.
Lonely power though isn't lonely today.
Is joined by Ireelia. So the death now I
lie. No way. Ireelia has been considered
to be moved back. Will move back and
maybe he has a unit ability to bring
them over to the abandoned hole.
>> Yep. is indicating Aurelia Fervent and
Rengar trophy hunter for that switch
with the defiant dance. Interestingly
having chosen and yeah there it is the
blade dancer legend effect will pay to
ready that Aurelia fervent as well
leaving that lonely porer on that
battlefield and then contesting holding
even that abandoned hall making stig
work for it here
>> indeed that is a very mighty Ireelia
fervent that is going onto abandoned
hall getting that second conquer point
but Stig has no answers to that doesn't
have that ranker on hand to ambush push
is in fact on the board now and is going
to be charming. I was wondering if our
dog was going to use this charm to try
and contest this. Oranga goes in of
course minus two might. Now is the time
to do all or nothing. Still has two
runes up. So has that energy can also
commit three power if needs be. But he's
just going to straight up win that
combat rice here. Yeah, that is in fact
Stig losing out that Renga and Ral Dogs
are very mighty. Ireelia is going to now
be another plus six on top. Let's see if
Stig has any answers. Only has one rune
up here.
>> Yeah, that definitely compounded that
abandoned hall getting that extra value
for Aurelia. Fervent Rodog's in a
spectacular position here right now.
Seven points to five over to Stigit. It
is up to Wuju Bladesman pilot here to
make something happen. That lonely porro
is obviously the easiest target, the
juiciest target, but it's going to give
raw dogs a card. So it's like, oh god,
I'm going to be punished this way.
Aurelia fervent though is going to be a
tall order to overcome. Does have that
guardian angel equipped is just
naturally five might with that
combination. And Rod Hogs with two in
hand could have one defined dance could
have one on guard. We just don't know.
and neither does Stig.
>> Not entirely sure what Ro Dogs has in
hand to to counter whatever Sidget does
here, but Sigette has to try and I would
say wants to conquer both battlefields
to try and turn this into a 70 situation
because uh it's going to be hard though
with only 1 2 3 4 five six seven runes.
>> Yeah, obviously having the hands over
there. It looks like there is those
seven runes. You are once again right
there. Icy is exhausting one rune so
far. I was expecting to see more.
>> Yeah, there. Okay,
>> what are we going to see here? Icy
>> cycling both of them as
>> two and two.
>> It's
>> charming the way.
>> That's one and one.
>> That gets rid of that very mighty
Ireelia means that Sig will be able to
potentially move that Clockwork keep her
up or maybe just contest that Lonely
Power. Yeah, had to cop that deflect
cost for that Aurelia Fervin as well,
which is why those two runes were
recycled to the bottom. A very costly
charm here.
>> Taking a look at the trash of Stig
again. That publicly available
information. Roar Dogs just seeing how
many pump spells have been used. Could I
fight this one out? Because Stig still
has five runes up.
>> Does have five runes up versus Ra Dog's
only two. Considering a card, what do
you want to use here? Um, and the
clockwork keeper, one unit could go in
and contest that lonely power later or
get that open free battlefield, but it's
going to be a hard bargain. The way a
hard bargain works is they're forced to
repay that cost one more time if they
want to use it.
>> Yeah, hard bargain obviously is also a
repeatable one. They pay an extra two if
they want to prevent that countering
occurring. If you repeat it, then they
have to pay that four. So, it is an
effective counter spell, especially when
your opponent is low on runes. However,
Stig has five up, so he is deliberating.
Do I pay that two extra here to make
that charm land? And he's thinking
about possibly putting this one in the
trash, letting that hard bargain resolve
because it doesn't look like Stig has a
defy in hand
cuz that would arguably be cheaper than
paying the two energy. You pay the one
energy and the power.
He did in fact pay that to Energy to to
counter the hard bargain. And in goes
the clock keeper giving themselves
giving Stig six points and giving
control of a bandit hole to Stigit.
>> There it is. There's the GG's. There is
the fist bump. I do believe Raw Dogs is
going to take this one. 21 here in the
overtime of our featured table matchup
in round seven. an undefeated Aurelia
here. Raw Dogs, congratulations.
>> Congratulations, Raw Dogs 2 and one. It
was felt like such a close game. I mean,
we only got to see that little sneak
peek at the end there. Um, but it was
such a close match up between these two.
They're discussing the game. I love
seeing them discuss the game afterwards
because we're all here also not just to
have fun, not just to win, but also
sometimes to learn, to better ourselves
at Riftbound.
>> I love that idea of bettering yourself
at Riftbound, right? because there is so
much to learn. I personally feel like it
has a low barrier of entry but a really
high skill ceiling here too. And this is
how you do it. You come to these high
OPL events and you compete against the
best of the best and you learn from them
when you lose as well cuz right now 6
and one for Stigit and 7 and0
for our winner here today, Raw Dogs.
>> Exactly. These are some of the best
players in Australia or even worldwide
and we are here to learn from them as
well. I mean in in this sort of I want
to say arena with 1,600 players with so
many different types of play styles, so
many different legends. I mean all 40
are presented here and we at your local
Nexus nights. I don't really have 1,600
people showing up to mine. I don't know
about you, but
>> No, neither. I do not have 1,600. I
think my my LGS's do between 20 and 40.
So, I mean, if everyone played one
legend and we matched it at 40, we could
get one of every single legend, you
know, it's quite possible. But
unfortunately, not the reality of those
Nexus Knights, which is why some of the
skirmishes are fantastic, too, cuz
that's typically where you'll get a few
more legends played and a few more
attendees.
>> Yeah, exactly. And maybe you get to play
some of those other legends with so many
legends in the game and so many more
coming out, too. Excited about the next,
but that's still so far away to think
about. I'm still headed in the game for
Unleash. I mean, it only came out a week
ago.
>> I mean, yeah, it only came out a week
ago, but Vendetta is going to be spicy
and radiance even spines here. We could
potentially hopefully see KDA brought
together because we have seen Saraphene
teas in that one. But as you say, we are
here now at the Riftbound regional
qualifiers in Sydney for 2026. And it is
the first unleashed Riftbound qualifier
as well. But that is enough from us
here. Round seven is wrapped up and
we'll be right back after this break.
Have you been feeling moody lately? Are
you also tired of conquering for your
points all the time? Do you not want to
play a normie deck like the others? Then
we got the deck just for you. Vex
Gloomist appears in Unleashed, a legend
that massively profits from holding
battlefields. Stop your opponent from
ambushing or accelerating consistently
as early as turn two with Vex apathetic
as your chosen champion unit. Tell your
opponents to back off by stunning their
units when they try to conquer. Play
your shadow ready into battlefields to
immediately use its ability on the
opposing turn. Vex can rely on so many
different defensive tools that the calm
and chaos domain already have. Use
guardian angel and zonia's hourglass to
protect your units from dying. Not so
fast and defy to counter opposing spells
and deny their tempo, but also new
defensive cards can be found in
unleashed like existential dread or the
mutated mouser. But in the shadow isles,
a monster lurks supporting Vex, giving
her near unlimited defensive and
offensive possibilities. Enter Vimmore.
The spider god has ambush, meaning it
can be played offensive and defensively.
with this powerful eight mighty jumps
into a battlefield that you are
attacking and crushes any unit smaller
than it without taking a single hit. If
your opponents doesn't manage to push it
out of a battlefield, an additional draw
for holding is a free bonus. With these
cards in your deck, you're going to be
able to keep all the others away from
your battlefields. Keep holding,
Riftbounders.
Welcome to the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney 2026. I am joined by
Merkat who is cosplaying as Jinx. And uh
Merkat, have you been having a good time
this weekend so far?
>> Yes, I love it. It's so big and exciting
and I love all the pictures on the
walls.
>> There's a lot of really good pictures.
Now, we have a lot of events happening
this weekend. Do you have any that you
are looking forward to partaking in?
>> Oh, I'm going to play the full box seal
tomorrow. I'm excited to make a pile and
lose every game.
>> That's my favorite as well. I I really
want to hit an overnumbered in the full
box. Now, do you have a favorite set
three legend from Unleashed?
>> Oh, I'm going to give away what I play
in League, but I really want that Yumi.
It's so cute.
>> Yeah, we do love a good Yumi. Yumi is in
Unleashed. And uh for the audience out
there, who are you cosplaying?
>> Jinx.
>> Me?
>> Yeah.
>> Jinx.
>> Excellent. This is Jinx. That has been
Merkat. And this is the Ripbound
Regional Qualifiers 2026.
I'm here at the Ripbound Regional
Qualifiers 2026 and I'm joined by
Valyriius. We have some questions for
you today. Are you having a good time so
far?
>> Yes. Yes, I am. I am having a good time
annoying everyone playing card games.
>> We've seen you being sort of a menace
twirling the staff as Lux would do. Now,
do you have any events that you're
looking forward to? Are you going to be
playing anything this weekend?
>> I'm going to try to learn Roofbound. Uh
maybe the Alux or Ahri deck. Those are
my favorite characters. Yep. Lux is from
the proving ground set and is quite a
popular champion. Is in the order and
mine domain. So, we do love to see a bit
of a Lux. Now, do you know the set three
unleash champions at all? The legends,
sorry.
>> No, I don't think so. But I've heard
that there is a Baron and and he's very
expensive.
>> Baron is one of the new units coming in
set three. Now, for those at home who
may not be aware, who are you cosplaying
and and why are you cosplaying her?
>> Um, I'm cosplaying Lux from League of
Legends. Well, from Rift Found League of
Legends series, Bright. Um, I'm
cosplaying Lux cuz I love Lux. I I've
played her for so many years now.
All fantastic. It looks excellent. And
thank you so much for joining us here at
the Riftbound Regional Qualifiers Sydney
2026.
I'm here at the Riftbound Regional
Qualifier Sydney 2026 and I'm joined by
Vera Chamira. Looking amazing in
Leblanc.
>> You thank you very much. Um, made her in
a day.
>> One, oh my goodness. one day for this
excellent cosplay. And so you put it
together for the Riftbound qualifiers.
What inspired you to go with Leblanc?
>> Well, her redesign is quite stunning and
I didn't see a lot of cosplays made for
it yet and I thought I'm going to take
up the challenge and make it for today.
>> Fantastic. I think it looks really,
really good. I'm sure we can all agree
here. Now, I know you're new to
Ripbound, but do you have any unleashed
legends that you're inspired or excited
by that you've kind of seen?
>> I have. Look, I'm very much of the sense
if it's a holographic and shiny card. My
eyes go towards it. I was looking
through some of the decks and I think it
was Diana. Some of her cards look
beautiful, but of course, I'm going to
go for yours truly and I'm going to hunt
down some Leblanc cards.
>> Good luck getting your Leblanc cards.
Thank you so much for your time here
today, Vera Chimera. And that is
Leblanc.
>> Welcome back to coverage of regional
qualifier city here. We've been playing
Riftbound all day long and there is one
more round of Swiss left. There are
still nine undefeated players coming
into this round.
>> Crazy that there are that many.
>> Also, I'm pretty sure the round hasn't
finished yet, so maybe more I don't know
about. There are still a few matches
remaining. So, round eight is on the
way. We'll be bringing you coverage as
soon as games are ready, but we do have
to wait a little bit until then.
>> I can be patient. It's fine. That's
good.
>> I can do it.
>> I believe we have a little mini game
that we can play. Production has
challenged us to guess the flavor text
of a few cards. Uh, can't wait for us to
mess this up royally.
>> The production will never be ready. Give
it a go. All right.
>> That's a lot of eyes. Common last words.
Is
>> is that
>> trying to Okay, I'm trying to think if
the the color of the text gives us any
clues at all. I don't think it does.
>> That would be too much of a hint, I
think.
>> Oh, no. That's tails. I was like,
thousand tail watcher. That's not eyes.
>> That is a lot. That would have a lot of
tails.
>> Lot of eyes.
>> Baron.
>> Maybe.
>> No.
>> Common last words. I'm going to say I
think this is Baron National.
>> I think Vile War maybe.
>> Okay, we've locked it in production.
Well, who is it? How wrong are we?
>> This is very wrong. This is what's
happening.
>> Ah, okay. There's absolutely no way.
Ever stalker from Oh, it is from
Unleashed. Never mind.
>> It is.
>> All right. Hit us again. I'm assuming
these are all from Unleashed. I guess I
can at least That would make sense.
>> I can at least get there. But B was from
Unleashed. I was I was trying.
>> All right. Well, load it up. What do we
got? I believe production is currently
3-0.
>> So now 4-0. Commentators doing not so
great. Uh what good is having a plank if
nobody ever walks it?
>> H I got nothing.
Well, it's probably a pirate,
>> you'd think.
>> So, could be MF. Could be Cannon Brush.
It's a pirate card with Gangplank
climate.
>> Well, if it's going to be unleashed,
>> could be as the Buccaneer mans with
oranges. It's probably not that. Is it?
Ooh. Is it cold a week?
>> That has someone on a plank on it,
doesn't it?
>> I don't know if that's it.
>> I'm going to say this is cold a week.
That's what I think.
>> Look, I have no idea. So, I'm going to
side with you and hope that your better
judgment can get US OFF.
>> LET'S GO.
>> YES.
>> This is what I play too much of this
card. This is how I know cuz I've seen
this art so many times. All right, one
one.
>> All right,
>> one more to go. Surely surely we'll get
this right. Also did not fall into my
own trap of thinking these are all
unleash cards. Good boy. Now, where's
the rest of them? So, this has got to be
one of the dogs.
>> Absolutely. I mean, we did see a lot of
them earlier today in that Ivan match.
I'm pretty sure it's not trusty
ramhound.
>> No,
>> I don't think so cuz I think I read the
trusty Ramound flavor text like in my
mind's eye looking at the card in that I
game.
>> Maybe.
>> But there's I feel like this suggests
that there's more than one. I guess
there could be more than one trust. So
Starhound. That's another dog.
>> I might be able to name Hang on. I might
be able to name.
>> Can you do it? Can you? All right. No,
this is a mini game inside of a mini
game at this point.
>> All right.
>> What other What other dogs are there? Oh
no, there's dogs in. So moss stomper. So
there's Sorry, there's dogs in colors
that
>> aren't Oh, it's cemetery attendant. I
was going to get there.
>> Ah, he's so cute.
>> He's very cute. That's a good card. I
play that one sometimes.
>> Big fan.
>> In a Heless Resurrection, whatever pile
I'm playing with that card in it cuz you
can pick up uh I don't know, Bewitching
Spirits. Pretty sweet.
>> All I'm saying is thanks to your great
intellect, we have broken production
streak.
>> That's true. We we did get one
scoreboard.
>> And I say we very loosely, so I'll I
I'll take the win. Anyway,
>> that was two Origins cards, I'm pretty
sure. That's kind of crazy.
>> Tricky.
>> All right, let's have a look at the meta
stats cuz uh we've had a lot of riff
rounds so far and we've been looking at
what has been happening here for all of
the decks.
>> So, we've talked a lot about these
decks. We'll talk about them again and
especially tomorrow depending on how
they convert, which I am very excited to
find out. But if you are maybe just
joining us or haven't tuned in for a
little bit, this is kind of where the
metag game looks coming into today on
day number one. So, Leblanc 7% that is
the highest manage that any deck has. No
one is breaking double digits, which
kind of makes sense when you consider
there's 40 legends to choose from, but
83 certainly the most popular deck in
the room, which we did expect.
>> Yeah, it's not a surprise to see Leblanc
up the top. It will be interesting, as
you said, to see how well it converts to
Mora. We shall see. But having Master up
there, Ireelia up there, and Diana all
reasonably close together, that makes a
lot of sense as well. I think uh what
I've been really enjoying is how much
Vex we've been seeing, not just on like
on our own, but also in a bunch of other
decks.
>> Yeah, I mean Vex certainly Vex Apathetic
certainly being one of the best cards in
the format. It feels like I'm I think in
general Aurelia and Diana are going to
convert relatively well. I think the
long master probably won't, which makes
sense cuz they're the two most popular
decks tend do not have particularly good
conversion rates when you have a lot of
players playing them. MF is interesting
cuz we know it's all Aurora. So, I'm
curious how many of those decks do well.
And when we look at eventually the other
Aurora archetypes, we can see maybe if
uh there's another one that did better
even with fewer numbers. Victor is like
always massively high in the meta for
some reason. People just love to
register this legend, which is wild
given that there's one in the same
domains that's doing I mean at least has
more represented. And I would probably
hazard a guess against it doing quite a
bit better, but Vex and how Vex converts
is interesting to me cuz I think more
players than I maybe expected gravitated
to this deck. Turns out it's just quite
good.
>> I mean, it's great actually, and I say
that as a Vex enjoyer. But yes, it is
very interesting to see Leblanc
essentially twice as many Leblanc as
Victor.
>> Yes. And that's still only seven versus
4%. And this is like this is eight
legends on the screen. 32 legends we're
not showing you that also have some
number of numbers. I actually curious. I
wonder what the lowest one is. Maybe
we'll find out tomorrow. Have a look at
the battlefields cuz we have seen uh
quite a few of these today. I will point
out we have seen very little Starring
for how many star springs are in the
room?
>> I really thought there would be more
>> at least on stream.
>> Well, yes, we have seen a lot of
abandoned hall though.
>> Much more than I was expecting. I don't
think we've seen that much Z warren
either.
>> No, Zong Warren is kind of one of the
one of the most represented battlefields
for quite a while from Origins through
Spirit Forge. Uh there was some little
bit of rumbling from certain uh voices
online that was on wars after the bands
might be actually one of the best maybe
maybe a little too good in some cases
and I think that's probably maybe not
true but it's certainly a very good
battleground that a lot of different
decks are happy to play helps you filter
through your draws can enable some
strategies. There aren't that many like
trash centric decks in roofbound right
now, but you can get a bit of additional
value that way as well. But yeah, at
least on stream we have seen a a huge
amount of abandoned hall relative to
everything else. And I think the other
one that's on here we've seen quite a
bit of is uh rock flop.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we have also seen a couple
aspirin climb and the arena's greatest
as well here and there which is good to
see. I don't think we've seen that much
sunken temple though.
>> A little bit. It's kind of like most of
the time temple I feel like is uh maybe
some Aurora and like a lot of Aurelia
>> and maybe some set. There's a decent
number of sets in the room at least at
least based on conversion rate sets
doing very well this uh this event
>> cuz there was I think multiple
undefeated sets going into the last
round. So certainly something we uh
might be seeing more of maybe honestly
depending on how the pairings shake out
maybe this upcoming round in a round. I
I I have to tell you, I've had a pretty
big peak at the standings kind of in the
last few rounds checking on the
undefeated players and uh the potential
matchups we have in this last round.
>> If you uh if you're someone that watches
a lot of Riftbound, a lot of uh lot of
the US events especially, you will be uh
very happy to see some of the players
that are still undefeated
>> definitely
>> here towards the end of day one. There
are some killer matchups coming up
potentially depending on how the pairing
shake out.
>> Mhm. Whether it's today, it almost
certainly will be tomorrow as well.
>> Oh yeah. I mean, yeah, we someone has to
lose events, right? The undefeated
players eventually
>> you can't stay undefeated forever.
>> Well,
>> well, I mean, one one can.
>> Yes. Famously, a zero didn't.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's certainly possible, but uh I
think players will be rocketing towards
the top eight depending on how the
standing shout out. And there's a lot of
uh there's a team that's still
undefeated
>> at the end of this round.
>> Impressive.
>> Very impressive. Especially Legend, I
think, is probably changed quite a bit
with Unleash. Seems like a lot of
different chaos cards you can
potentially work with. So excited to see
how all these things shake out when we
finally get our matchups cuz I I say at
this point I've had a pretty good idea
of what we are going to get this round.
I am completely in the dark and there's
a lot of fun we could have as let's have
a look at Ooh, this is our unleashed
meta mvps.
>> Mhm. Look, I will explain myself. Okay,
I want to explain myself. I think Baron,
as divisive as it can be because I am an
Aurora player, I don't actually have
that many in my deck, but I still love
that it does make such a difference
having that Baron pit. And I will stand
by that it can be very, very useful
depending on how your play is. And I
will say it's just so versatile and so
good.
>> It's so good. Big big fan. I do think a
number of decks that we've seen in terms
of representation, I think one of the
reasons Diana is seeing as much play as
she is is cuz Hay is just such a good
unit. I think many players have
described Hay as like kind of like
another Stellorn and that is relatively
accurate. Even in decks like Diana that
don't have that much ability to make
Quay mobile, unlike which obviously does
a ton of that with Stellorn. Uh often
Quay just says discard two, draw a
discard one card, draw two cards.
>> Yeah,
>> some extra steps to get through there.
other things you can do as well, but for
the most part, Clay's versatility, but
also his raw power, even as a more
expensive unit is really sweet for me. I
guess I'll say I did pick one card that
I personally really love that I thought
we'd see more of in Heatless
Resurrection and one card I think is
actually legitimately good. So, we'll
start with Heatless Resurrection. Um,
look, I like brewing, okay? And I think
this card's really sweet. Uh, we haven't
seen Ezreal today at all. Don't know how
Ezreal's doing, but there are certainly
some slower chaos shells that I think
can make pretty good use of this card.
Um, I know the anti- Aurora players have
been uh really yelling for a reaction
speed solution for Aurora, and I have to
tell you, you can do it. You have a
Heless resurrection, a disarming rake,
and another unit that you can
potentially sacrifice. It is possible. I
don't know if it's good, but it is
possible. And certainly a card that I
think we'll see a bit more of, but we
certainly haven't seen much of today.
But Ash focused, I think this is one of
the reasons Order might be good. This
card is so in this meta game especially,
this card is so good.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And also, it is no
surprise that both Logan and Ricey have
both Vex.
>> I mean, it we've seen how popular Vex
has been, and it's it's undeniable at
this point. So many decks are running
Apathetic. And having Elder Dragon makes
a lot of sense. Starrust again in a lot
of decks as well. All of these I think
are very fair picks actually.
>> I feel like Starrust incredibly good
card. not a card and we haven't seen
that much chaos today. I suppose I'm
curious how well the chaos decks do cuz
Chaos has been a very successful domain
in the early history of Brickband. If
you go and look through all of the RQs
between Origins and Spirit forge, you'll
see quite a few Chaos decks
>> rumaging around. Star Quest does feel
like another tool that is just very good
for these decks. But I feel like maybe
it's just with how many different decks
in Legends we've tried to show today on
stream, we haven't seen that much chaos.
But I have a feeling as we get towards
the later rounds, maybe late in day two
tomorrow, that we'll see one of the
reasons why this card is such a prize
meta card because it is it is real
powerful.
>> Absolutely. Look, I think hopefully,
fingers crossed, we will see a lot of
these cards tomorrow to be honest with
you. We will certainly see some Vex in
one deck or another.
>> I think it's been at least for Chaos, I
think easily the most popular unit. I
think of the units in the metag game, I
think it's been in the top five, if not
higher. M I I honestly think it it
represented so much more than expected.
>> Yeah, I think ambush being such a
prolific keyword in uh in Unleashed and
the players did want an answer that felt
good to it. I think it's also one of the
reasons why Vex is one of the more
represented decks because as we heard
even from Bolan in his interview after
his win on feature. Uh yeah, I just
wanted to play the deck that had access
to this card.
>> Exactly. Understandable. I I love Vex.
So it automatically was a yeah, I want
this kind of situation for me. But it's
really really satisfying to see how well
it has played across a bunch of
different decks, across a bunch of
different play styles.
>> Yeah, card's really good. Uh, turns out
jamming something on turn two that
doesn't cost you power, that has an
effect you want in a bunch of good stats
seems pretty good. As we're going to
have a look at something else that we've
had poking around,
>> make a deck that's going to be all
around the deep.
>> We are here at the RQ in Sydney. I am
joined by Prismat, fresh off a win in
Atlanta. How are you feeling about
Sydney?
>> I really enjoy it here. The weather's
been really nice. I like the wildlife
and so far it's been going all right. I
think maybe a bit jet-legged. I think
I'm not playing amazingly. Three and one
so far in the pre-arch, but it's all
right. Got to get the losses out of the
way today and then do well in the main
event.
>> As long as you get them over and done
with now. And you do still have the jet
lag to contend with. So, how recently
did you get in?
>> I got in yesterday morning. So, Thursday
morning. Today's Friday and it it hasn't
been I haven't felt bad, but game play
is has felt bad. So,
>> well, there's a whole weekend ahead and
there's plenty to see how it's going.
How are you feeling with everybody here?
>> Oh, it's nice. Yeah, everyone traveling
out from different parts of the world.
Allan coming from Europe. Randy, I mean,
he's kind of living in China at this
point, so it's a bit easier of a trip
for him. Uh, but yeah, seeing everyone
again, and then we'll see each other all
in Vancouver as well.
>> And obviously, we've just had Unleashed
release. How does that change how you're
approaching Sydney compared to how your
decks have been in the past?
>> Uh, honestly, it feels for me similar to
Le where I settled on any I feel like
the deck is good. I know that I'm not
going to have any really bad matchups,
so I can always play my way out of any
match to be able to win. Um, but it's
not like I'm super confident. I think
when I was going into Atlanta, I was
thinking, "Okay, my my deck's the best
deck." And Allan saying, "Yeah, your
deck's still the best deck." And maybe
starting to believe him over time. I
think Diana's also really strong. Um,
but it is really interesting because
there's a limit to how much you can
prepare for each matchup. Like you can
say, okay, we expect these decks to be
the the top percentage, top meta decks
coming in. Like Aurora is a big one. Um,
I think today there's a lot of Master Yi
and Aurelia, which is a bit surprising
cuz they don't have very good Aurora
matchups. Um, but, you know, prepare
against the the expected matchups and
then the rest of them you just have to
go on the fly.
>> Well, we will see what happens. Uh,
we'll see whether it comes down to Annie
and Diana. Who knows? Maybe we'll see
how it goes. We've got a whole weekend
ahead of us. Thank you so much and good
luck.
>> I'm here at the Sydney Riftbound
regional qualify. Right before the
weekend kicks off, I have the one and
only Alan Ziku. Alan, how are you doing
in the preq?
>> Uh, wonderful. Lack of sleep doesn't
stop me from just winning back to back
so far the runs and hopefully it follows
up until tomorrow.
>> So, how you feeling about your deck? You
have changed legends but not uh domains
and we kind of knew this was coming.
How's Diana treating you?
>> Uh very good. Deck is so good. I think
it's like the second best deck in the
format right now.
>> What's the best deck then?
>> Ani
an player on your team maybe that we'll
be seeing around.
>> Most certainly you will he will swap
eventually to the same domains in
different champion. But for this event
there was a bit short of time on the for
the practice because uh we just finished
Atlanta and then we had to travel. So,
and we had literally one week to
practice and we just stick to what we
know. Uh, but for the next events, we'll
definitely be mixing up.
>> How have we been feeling about Unleash?
Obviously set very close to release kind
of with this event. How have you been
feeling about the shifts as set 3 joins
Riftbound?
>> Oh, it's amazing. There is such a
widespread meta. You get to play around
so many things against so many things
and like it just so many different play
styles. It makes hard with the current
sideboard side to make a deck that's
going to be all around deep decent into
everything. You have to sacrifice the
some matchups uh because how uh like low
on the cards you have in just the cyber
slots.
>> Of course, expecting a pretty diverse
metag game over the weekend. There are
40 legends now and obviously you're
chasing Diana. You went pretty well on
the Ezreal hunt. How's Diana gonna go in
this season? Uh, I like I like the deck
to the extent where I think I could go
for four out of four on Diana. We'll see
how it goes on the event. I might get
humbled and the deck might actually fall
apart and like it might run out of just
the value in general. Maybe too much
tempo. We'll see. But, uh, as solid this
set as well, so worst case, it's a fall
back.
>> Best of luck. Have a great tournament.
>> Thank you so much.
Welcome to Riftbound Basics featuring
actions and reactions. There are three
different types of spells in Riftbounds.
Normal spells, which you can use to
start a chain during your own turn from
a neutral game state. Actions, which can
be used in exactly the same way, but can
also be used in combat to start a chain,
and reactions, which have all the
advantages of the other two, but can
also be used to react to triggered
abilities or spells. Reactions are super
fast and can lead to lots of exciting
interactions as they resolve before all
other spells. For example, if you have a
stupify in your hand and your opponent
activates a spell that really bothers
you, you can use stupify as a reaction
and draw a card before your opponent's
spell is resolved. This might allow you
to draw another reaction that saves you
from their situation, like a defy.
Another exciting example is dealing
damage to a unit with a spell before
combat. If you go into combat with a
unit that's already damaged, you should
make sure you win the fight. Otherwise,
the units will heal after the combat.
Let's say you have dealt six damage to
your opponent's mind splitter with
falling star and you go into combat
against it with your watchful sentry.
Your opponent might want to activate an
action in response, such as grim resolve
to generate extra might and win the
combat. You can still respond to that
with a stupify. You reduced the mind
spplitter's smite to six. And because it
still has six damage counters on it, it
will die before the grim resolve can
save it. Which one is your favorite
reaction card in Rift Bond? Let us know.
>> Welcome back folks to coverage of
regional qualifier Sydney. I am Patrick
time. That is still Steph Panicasio. And
I believe round eight is all paired up.
>> It's time
>> last round of assist for day one. It has
been quite the day here in uh in Sydney,
but it's been a fun one so far and there
are still many matchups to resolve and
still many records to leave unblenmished
as we move into day two.
>> We shall see how it goes. But yeah, a
lot of unconventional matchups, a lot of
things that we saw that were maybe not
exactly how we thought they'd play out.
>> Look, I'll level with you all. We have
tried, especially in the early stages of
this tournament, to show things off,
right? To show things like Ivan that we
maybe don't expect to see uh coming up
later. Uh, apparently we don't have to
do that much work to show off some
diverse match ups cuz even our final one
here that we have on feature is going to
be a fun. It is Teemo versus Fiora. The
exact match up we expected rolling into
the weekend.
>> Let's see how this goes. I am very
curious to see if we are going to see
another Vex in here somewhere given that
Vex has been in pretty much every deck
that can run it.
>> Well, one of the decks is playing Chaos.
So, I have to suspect that probably team
are hiding around. You're also
shockingly popular choice. Yeah.
>> This event and uh there are still some
doing well deep into the tournament. Uh
I wonder what they know that I don't
>> because uh I did not expect Fiora to
have that much representation.
>> I wonder how many of them are running
hook.
>> I think that are still in the
tournament.
>> Probably zero.
>> Well, once we have deckless, we'll get
them up for you on screen and have a
little peek what's going on. But on the
right, you can see our Fiora player
shuffling away, which means our Teemo
Enjoyer is on the left. And Teemo is a
deck that
I don't know it. I don't I'm not going
to say it's Teemo's time, but Teemo has
certainly gotten better with each set,
which kind of makes sense when the deck
is all about hidden cards. The more
hidden cards they add to his domains,
the better generally Teemo is going to
perform.
>> Mhm. Absolutely. Look, if you had told
me earlier today that we would be seeing
a Teemo with this record, I don't know
whether I would have necessarily been
100% believing that, but it is really,
really great to see.
>> Yeah, I don't know if players are X1 or
XO, but I do know again coming into this
round, it wasn't undefeated Teemo
player. So, I have to think if we're
putting them on stream, it's probably
the undefeated Teemo player.
>> One would think.
>> I don't I don't think I saw any other
Teeos with an X and one record. Like, I
can't imagine the legend is doing all
that well. Also, let's have a squid,
shall we?
>> Let's kicking things off with Ashen OCE
on Teemo.
>> No Vex to be seen.
>> Interesting.
>> There we go.
>> There's a Baron in this deck.
>> Wow. I mean, running three Nocturns
makes sense.
>> Yeah,
>> I think this all tracks aside from that.
Yeah, there's definitely some I mean
depending on where you want to put
Teemo, you can certainly play a slower
build, but uh I do think if you want to
play kind of a more aggressive, more
mid-range deck, I think you do want to
be on Nocturn.
>> Kind of wild to see three Nocturns and
zero stacked decks given that stack deck
is one of Chaos's best cards in general.
>> But uh bunch of new hidden cards and
some old favorites I suppose as well.
Three Switcher, three Windser, that's
Gust on a stick basically upping that
count. Only two Teemo strategist down
from the three that we had in a bunch of
decks before. Three Sprite Found has
kind of become one of the best early
drops for these colors in general.
>> Uh two bone skewer. It's a fun hidden
card you can play every now and then.
And one Evelyn
>> also the two existential dreads
>> are in there as well.
>> Yeah, very cool card to see.
>> Haven't seen that one too often today.
Kind of expected to see it more from the
Vexes we've seen honestly. But uh two is
a relatively high number for a card that
you cannot hide. Although it is quite
efficient. kind of like Kaus's thunk if
you will, but if you stun the unit, you
also get to return it to their hand.
Also noted three purple Teimos in their
deck. So, not just the one you have in
your champ, but the rest as well as Rez
is going to be our Fiora player here.
>> Look, again, a lot of things that we'd
be expecting to see here. Obviously got
the Lucian in there, Doran's Blade,
Punch First, a lot of stuff that
realistically I I would have expected to
see. Yeah, I think the things that made
people interested in Fiora again and and
set as well to some extent, right? A
sacrifice, a new card that got added in
unleash that is uh kind of adding card
draw that the didn't you didn't really
get in these decks. Uh interesting to
see only one in this list. Uh definitely
seen I think every number of copies from
one to three. Also two Ashan in the main
kind of is like I'm expecting uh to see
certain things
>> and I would like to punish them when I
see them. Mhm.
>> So, not a unit that I think we'd see
that often in the main, certainly in
those numbers, although we did start
seeing it creep up a little bit in the
end of Spirit Forge, especially with
Azir kind of coming to the forefront.
But otherwise, just a lot of really good
numbers on these cards.
>> Absolutely. Three challenge, two
sabotage, one hidden blade. Interesting.
Not really that surprising.
>> Got to hide it somewhere, I suppose, as
I am very curious how this match up
plays out. I have no idea how much of
this match up these players have played.
I think we're definitely at the point
where like I don't think players are
that familiar with this match up, but I
just saw something that I am very
surprised by.
>> Oh, what did you
>> Our Teemo player has Teemo Strategist as
their chosen champion. That is the mind
Teemo.
>> So, one of the great things about Teemo
is that when you play Chaos Teamo,
Teemo, I call it it's Beimo cuz that's
the the alt art. It's beautiful. I don't
know. I think it's Teemo Scout is the
actual name of the card. Anyway, uh that
one is when you play it, it gets plus
three might that turn. So when you play
it from hidden, uh it's pretty big. We
actually see a number of chaos decks
just use it as a hidden card in their
arsenal because uh it's something that's
really tough to think about when you
just flip over a four might tee when
you're trying to think of what other
five hidden cards could this this chaos
deck have.
>> Exactly.
>> But uh the great thing about that team
is it's a two energy unit that doesn't
cost you any power. So you could just
play it on curve every single game as
one of your opening plays and you'd be
good to go. team of strategist does cost
a power and kind of needs to be
defending or or hidden in order to get
stuff done.
>> So very curious to see
>> uh team of player lean on that one from
the chosen champion. So curious to see
how the play patterns change there cuz
you don't really have the same kind of
free two drop you might get in a bunch
of other games as we are going to kick
ourselves on into the final round 6 and
one. The two undefeated players do have
a draw in their record. Not a loss.
Still technically undefeated.
>> It still counts.
>> Certainly does. As players are going to
mulligan, it is star tip peak for our
team player. When you hold
>> uh you I don't know if you I think you
have to do it actually. When you hold
channel a exhausted
>> you may
>> you may don't miss it. Don't miss it at
home friends. And then monary of harana
kind of the set battlefield but makes
sense in Fiora as well. She has some
buffing in her deck. Also, obviously in
Set's domain. Uh when you conquer here,
you may spend a buff if you do draw a
card.
>> Mhm.
>> So, quick pass back. Neither player
having an early drop right now. This
Fiora kind of surprisingly not finding a
two, but Teemo is going to just play
Teemo. Nope, it's Sprite.
>> Oh, that's such a cute Sprite.
>> Oh, I love that.
>> Off to the peak.
>> Adorable. Unfortunately, Sprite as a
temporary unit cannot hold onto the
peak.
>> So even though uh for the same reason
you can't score points, you cannot do
anything else. And we're just hiding
Teemo strategist.
>> Just it's face up.
>> Hiding hiding.
>> Air quotes.
>> Mhm.
>> It's hidden.
I
did not know you could hide Teemo from
the J.
>> It it feels like a little bit, you know,
superfluous to hide from there. But you
know what
>> I mean, you do want a unit there.
>> You do
>> because the sprite, as we noted, is
temporary. And Fiora going to come out.
Fiora Victorious. Very good unit.
>> Mhm.
>> Obviously a chosen champion for this
deck as well. See this in a bunch of
other decks though
>> in Leona recently. in set recently as
well. But Tim strategist just going to
flip on up and kind of make camp with
the star tip peak. Get that extra rune.
>> Not hidden for very long.
>> Point and not hidden for very long at
all.
>> Even using Teimo's legend special
ability to get in there for without
losing extra power. One of the
advantages of going
>> second and actually getting an extra
rune, which is
>> kind of a very convenient confluence of
things that's happened here for Ash.
>> Absolutely. Tim just a very good
defender.
>> Oh, I can't stop looking at that sprite.
>> Oh, it's so cute. It's going to be even
better cuz it's going to the monaster
>> in just a moment as looks like players
maybe just chatting to the judging staff
at the table.
>> Peak trigger was not missed, I don't
think. Although maybe it was
>> cuz started with three, recycled one for
the fountain, paid for everything else.
Yep, did miss the starship pig trigger.
I think that's I think that's where we
are.
>> As we said, it's May. So
>> that's true. When you hold here, you may
turn one exhausted. So it may be past
the point
>> where it matters.
>> Oh,
>> just Oh, no, never mind. You could
react. Sorry. I was also going to say
that
>> uh something funny
>> that I think could have happened is I
don't remember if you get a I guess you
would when the sprite goes away, but if
uh Rez didn't play a Oh, wait. No, that
doesn't actually either. Okay, so
timings in rebound as the players are
sort out what they have to sort out uh
is kind of an interesting thing.
>> So reactions generally can be played at
any time. That's the most like unfeted
>> speed you can play something at in
Riftbound,
>> but you do need a place to play it. The
something needs to be on the chain
something you can actually react to.
>> And playing a unit is not something that
opens a chain. You actually can't react
to that. So I believe what happened is
that because the sprite the temporary
trigger I believe is an actual trigger
that does go in the chain
>> and that I believe is how went Temo unh
hit against
>> but I think we might be past the
beginning phase.
>> So I don't think it's possible for Teemo
to hold this point which means you
couldn't trigger peak anyway.
>> Fair enough.
I don't know why I have to figure this
out on the fly at round eight, but here
we are learning new things together on
air.
>> There we go.
>> You worked it out. Maybe.
>> You think so?
>> I think so.
>> Who's to say?
>> Looks like the judging staff is also uh
I think relaying information to the
players. I I believe I have that right.
And the point totals as they stand
should be two to one, but not three.
Sorry, two to zero, but not three to
zero cuz a point for conquering on the
first turn. No point for holding this
turn. And then one for the sprite.
>> Mhm.
>> As he whisted on over out of the
lanterns. Oh no, we've been replaced
with the vanilla sprite token. It's a
tragedy.
>> A It's fine, I guess.
>> Well, I'm glad we saw it for at least a
little bit. That's a very cute token,
actually.
>> It was a little joy for the end of the
night.
>> All right. Well, hiding more cards on
Battlefield. That's kind of Teemo's
whole thing.
>> But the sprite does at least take
control for a little bit as Teemo
Strategist is camping on over. And I
think a little bit of uh bit of fun
there being had by Ash just saying,
"Hey, where do you want to go? Which
hidden card do you want to do you want
to deal with? Could be anything.
>> Could even be edge of knight.
>> Not actually because we know it's not in
his deck, but it could be."
>> That would be tricky.
>> Res doesn't know. Instead, it's going to
equip the dors. Say maybe it doesn't
matter if my Fiora is gigantic and very
good at combat is made mighty. Sopha's
legend ability is going to trigger.
Basically getting a reby
>> on the power used to equip that Doran's
blade.
And where do we go next? Cuz there's a
lot of keywords on this Fiora now. Now
that she's mighty ganking, deflect and
>> something else. Tank.
It's a lot of words on the card. There
we go. Deflect, ganking, and shield.
>> There we go.
>> A different defensive keyword. So pretty
good at just about anything you can do
in a combat situation. kind of an
allrounder
>> makes sense for Fiora the jewelist.
>> So res deciding which hidden card do I
want to go in. I think phase tanking the
team strategist trigger as well probably
doesn't feel all that fun.
>> I believe that will force team to play
deflect.
>> Might find out in a second. Here we go.
Fior rotating in.
>> Let's see.
>> So Tim just says when defend reveal the
top five cards of your deck. Deal one to
an enemy unit for here for each card
with hidden then recycle them. So, uh,
because Fiora is currently a six thanks
to the Doran's Blade, Fiora cannot be
felled by this trigger, but could still
take quite a bit of damage.
>> Uh, that's four hidden cards, by the
way. And there's a Nocturn.
>> So, four hidden cards in a nocturn, not
too bad. And this Nocturn, of course,
now that's been revealed when you're
looking through the top of your deck,
can be played by recycling a power. So,
that is what's going to happen. And uh
it could just be played to somewhere
you're allowed to play a unit to. And
you're allowed to play a unit to a
battlefield you control.
>> Mhm.
>> Currently controlling that battlefield,
but Fiora is trying to do some damage.
>> It's going to put her in a position.
>> Also controlling the one with a sprite
added if you'd rather have something a
bit more permanent.
>> But Teemo, at least right now, is
currently set to win at least trade in
combat with Fiora. Not something that
often happens in League of Legends.
Again, if you had said that sentence to
me earlier today, I'd be like, "Okay,
sure, why not?"
>> Here we are.
>> Fun things happen in happen.
>> So, where's Nocturn going? Have paid the
cost. So, Nocturn is going to be played
somewhere. Little former unit with
ganking. Pretty nice one. Deflect also
paid as well. Did have to pay for
choosing the Fiora. That was the unit at
the battlefield here for the Teemo
Strategist trigger. So, we're running
out of runes, but not running out of
options with two hidden cards at either
the battlefield and an Octurn.
>> So, we can uh can just now win the
combat. We'll lose a unit, but doesn't
have to reveal the hidden card if it
didn't want to.
And also then a matter of what is
happening in the bottom battlefield.
Have to think it's probably another
unit. You would imagine so.
>> Kind of funny to think when you want to
pick your window to flip it over if
that's the case. Cuz again, you don't
get infinite windows.
>> Mhm.
>> Both players keeping their cards very
close to their chest there. No sneaky
peaks this time around. It's
>> kind of nice against a deck that hides a
bunch of cards.
>> Yeah.
>> To be very good at keeping them from our
our very uh
>> feels right.
>> It does feel more accurate.
>> I want a little sticky beak. Hello,
>> one of them was a Teemo on the north
side.
>> So, uh that is a four might unit. This
is Teemo Scout. This is a unit that uh
not only is Ashos not playing in their
champ, but is playing three of in the
main. So, Nocturn going to be felt.
Fiora going to lose the fight to two
different Teeos, Spirit Blossom, Teemo,
and Beimo teaming up to take out Fioran
keep control of Star Tipped Peak.
And now a little manner of the sprite in
the bottom lane
>> as Fiora worthy going to be committed
>> doesn't cost a power makes your mighty
units ready or can ready them. So once
again we're going to do the thing. Get a
point for holding here. I thought a
should be at three points but not yet.
There's GG. Easy Teemo.
>> Mhm.
>> Little altart action clearly collecting
all of the bling but again same old
thing. able to hold onto that
battlefield where there was temporary
control. Again, shouldn't get the point
with how this all works out, but should
have, I think, three points.
>> Mhm.
>> One for two for conquering and one for
holding.
>> Y
>> over the first few turns. So, actually
at four. Maybe I cannot figure out how
team holding work.
>> Five.
>> Five. All right.
>> Goodness me.
>> All right. So, it turns out I was wrong.
Teemo will get the point there when you
flip him over even with the temporary
unit chilling at the battlefield.
>> There you go.
All of a sudden, that point score looks
very different.
>> Makes sense why Ash is pretty uh
aggressively defending the spots as
well.
>> Absolutely.
>> And they're going to have to play the
guessing game again. You have to think
>> at this point. Oh, I just want to see.
>> I like uh I think this is a good thing
to do if you're a Teemo player. Just put
your hand on the table. Yeah. As a force
of habit.
>> Mhm.
>> I don't know what it is. If I don't know
what it is, you don't know what it is.
It could be anything. Looks like three
hidden cards in the middle of the middle
of the battlefield.
>> It does. It does indeed.
>> Very intimidating.
>> It's ominous. What? It could be.
So,
>> it looks like we're just again maybe
confirming with the table. I did see the
word five mouthed over. So, that should
be the point total. And looks like
players are just correcting it. And Temo
is indeed racking up the points at a
rapid rate here.
can see why maybe this play is
undefeated.
>> Yeah, look, I as I said, I was I was
surprised, but given how well this is
going so far,
>> you know what,
>> credit to them.
>> So, not sure what else Res is up to.
>> But, uh, still haven't don't believe Ash
has drawn their card for the turn. So, I
think still some conferring with the
judges just to make sure that
>> points are where they should be and the
interactions are
>> adequately explained to the players
because again, I don't know if we
mentioned it already, but there's 40
legends you can play currently in
Riftbound.
>> And uh turns out not every player has
seen every legend. Not even the best
players have had time to test against
every possible deck you could maybe play
against.
>> Well, there's some questions sometimes
about what does this do cuz they all
play in a different way. especially with
Unleashed only having released basically
a week ago at this point. Yeah,
>> not a huge amount of time to prep for
everything. Uh obviously some additional
cards coming in from that. It's it's
going to make a big difference for
people who aren't necessarily aligned
with the newer play styles of those
cards coming in, especially against some
of those newer champions as well.
>> Certainly not. as uh looks like we are
still have a bit of discussion at the
table
as the players
explain everything to them. But judges
are confirring with both our players at
the table and the judging staff working
behind the scenes as well. Don't worry,
there's judges everywhere if you've
never been to a card game event. And
they do a great job.
>> Certainly given the length of today.
>> Oh yeah,
>> they've been doing uh quite a lot of
work.
>> Absolutely. I would like to see the step
counters on.
>> Oh goodness.
>> Oh my goodness. Terrified. Truly
terrifying.
>> All right, so looks like last little
bits being explained back and forth
and we should be good to go in short
order. Also, the vibes pretty
immaculate.
>> Probably can see in the player cams.
>> Look, sometimes you'd think last one of
the day might be seeing a little
fatigue, but everybody seems to be in
pretty good spirits.
Don't want to alarm anyone, but uh I did
just see a judge
run rapidly out of our production area,
which is right near the feature match
area.
>> Interesting.
>> Perhaps some more some more deliberation
>> discussion perhaps
>> needs to happen.
>> Again, those step counts, I'm telling
you,
>> they move quick.
>> They do. They do. They zip.
>> The rounds are timed. So, the Dodgers do
get to the tables as swiftly as they
can.
>> All right.
>> There's a little bit of charter still.
headset off as players are just
>> I think clarifying. Oh, we've rolled
back to this.
>> Okay,
>> interesting. Okay, maybe just explaining
the specific interactions. So, a new
deflect was played. I know was seen. You
are allowed to play Noctturn when you
see him on top of your deck. That
includes being revealed off of Teemo
Strategist.
>> Mhm.
>> So, that is all above the board. Fur did
take four damage, but Fiora of course
>> got to take out a unit or two.
>> And that Teemo was four might. That
Noctturn was only four, I believe. Maybe
Teemo strategist
>> was also something they could have.
Actually, I think by the rules of the
game, you have to kill a unit with
damage if you can.
>> Yeah,
>> interesting.
>> So, it looks like maybe draw back to
that point. Maybe realize there was a
unit there that shouldn't have been
there any longer.
>> So, that Temo was there and that team
was mighty big. Not quite mighty big
quite big.
>> Large.
>> Large for a Teemo, especially
>> a big old Teemo.
>> A Teemo of uh unusual size.
>> Larger than average, let's say.
>> And I can see the uh the shirt of the
head judge
just behind the table. So I think making
sure everything's a okay.
We got some sights and sounds of the
tournament hall. There's a lot going on.
I did once again spy a bunch of players
playing 2v2 this afternoon.
>> Yes, eventually you're going to convert
everybody I think at this point.
>> Um look, if you're out there and you've
been playing some Riftbound or not,
first of all, welcome. I highly
encourage you to give the game a go.
It's an absolute blast. Whether you are
were a League of Legends player, still
are a League of Legends player, or have
never heard of League of Legends,
Riftbound is a great game for all. But,
uh, just get a couple friends together,
jam some decks, and just try to just try
some 2v2, you know, break free of your
your one v one testing for an afternoon.
>> Move move that scrim game to the next
day and just give it a go. It's so fun.
>> That's beautiful.
>> It's great. 2v2 is great. Don't worry,
we'll play later.
>> I was going to say I haven't had a go.
>> That's the first thing we're doing when
we get back to the hotel.
>> I'm intrigued to see how it goes. We'll
go for it.
>> It's good fun.
number of players still in the main.
>> Curious to see how many players we'll
have left at the end of today. I do know
that the field has shrunk.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Significantly as players records have uh
dwindled perhaps towards the uh towards
the lower half of what they wanted out
of their event. M
>> tables have uh haven't needed quite so
many tables for the main event as the
day has gone on which is pretty common.
>> I will say depending on where your
legend sits uh and I know players do
track this as the tournament goes on
there could be some scraps in later in
the round for a best of depending on how
the records of certain legends look.
>> I mean every every legend is
represented.
>> Oh yes all 40.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Did anyone strike gold? anyone get to be
the only deck in the room on the I very
much doubt it.
>> I would be very surprised. I think at
minimum they'll still be at least four
or five.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I think I think the smallest
number is typically something like three
and that's really rare.
>> So I think probably five is about what
you'd expect no matter which legend. I
know Jin was kind of one that I think a
lot of players maybe thought,
>> oh, like probably not that many gins.
Deck doesn't seem deck's kind of kind of
tough to build.
>> Newer legend. There's like 15 gins in
the room still starting day one.
>> So, you know, got to be careful.
>> I mean, there's probably a lot of people
who are going Teemo that uh now are
thinking, okay, maybe the best is a
little bit tricky. It it must be
heartbreaking to be uh someone on like
you know a deck with I actually don't
know how many teams in the room but if
you're playing a deck that has like I
don't know somewhere between 10 and 15
copies like not that many. I guess 50 is
kind of a lot for the field. Maybe like
10 or less.
>> Sure.
>> And you're like you know you're enjoying
your games you're having a good time
maybe you're X1 X2 kind of feeling it
and you look up you're like oh there's a
EXO
>> Leona still after five rounds.
>> Exactly.
>> Oh no.
>> Ah look sometimes it's just not your
day. Sometimes it is.
Well, we are having a holding caught in
the fem area for now. Looks like we are
backing up to where we did, I think,
miss some combat action. And by the
looks of things, things have been
resolved. I believe we had to unwind to
a point where the game state was fixed.
And yes, team of strategist is now in
the bin.
>> Yep, there we go.
>> Honestly, given how much might have
added up today, I'm surprised I didn't
figure that one out. But everything is
all good now. There are simply two
different Teimo scouts on two different
battlefields still racking up points for
Ash and OC.
>> Look, you've done a lot of math today.
>> Too much.
>> You've done so much math today. You can
you can uh give your brain a little
break soon.
>> In 47 minutes, I'll do just that.
>> Mhm.
>> For now. Uh and then I'll do it all
again tomorrow. Can't wait.
>> Exactly. You'll be refreshed by then.
>> Hope I probably count to nine a lot
tomorrow. I think that'll happen.
>> Yeah.
>> All righty.
>> Back in.
>> Back in business. Uh five points to
zero. Pretty nice lead just about any
match up in Earthbound. See a couple
cards there poking forward just briefly.
>> Finally getting a peek. Consult the
pass. Bright fountain
>> not so hidden after all.
>> Switcheroo. And one more. That one I
know is consult the past.
>> Mhm.
>> I saw it with thine own eyes.
And of course Teemo uh lets you hide
things by paying one energy for them
instead of paying a power.
>> And that's not a once per turning. That
is just uh all the time when you're
hiding stuff.
>> So, typically Teemo wants to control
both battlefields because the more
battlefields you control, the more cards
you can hide.
>> Exactly. Right.
>> You only hide at each battlefield once
unless you're at Teemo's little home
ground of the bandal tree.
>> Back we go to Res's turn. Fiora
awakening. Doran's Blade. Fiora worthy.
Ready to maybe get in there. Maybe make
a different unit get in there.
Something's going to happen this turn
cuz uh Res can't really afford to keep
falling behind on points like this.
>> No, not at this point.
>> Look, we'll see. I think at this point
of the day, especially after a long
discussion, getting back into the zone
can be a little bit tricky. So, it is
going to take a little moment to get
ahead straight again, but right back
into it.
>> Little mental reset.
>> Breathe in, breathe out, and look at the
cards in your hand. See if they're any
good. Mhm. He's hoping I
>> think I spied an action.
>> Thinking about cards like set brawler.
Pretty good unit that makes itself
mighty nice and easily.
Something we see quite a lot in this fur
list. It's generally one of their better
units.
Rez considering all the options going to
pay to for something.
>> So sabotage as well. There's another
Doran's blade.
>> Very shiny Doran's blades. Very shiny.
>> Nexus Knight promodoran's blades I
believe.
>> Pay power. Equip my Fiora. She's become
mighty. Go ahead. Exhaust my legend.
Channel a rune exhausted.
Got to make sure you tunnel the rune so
you can pay for punch first sometimes.
>> Mhm.
>> But that fur looks big enough for this
teamer. Only one might now after being
played.
>> Surely nothing can go wrong.
>> Same as last words.
Well, I think Rez is understandably a
little bit cautious. So, going to
challenge
I would like to challenge your team
away. That one up the top.
>> I would like to draw two cards.
>> So, a bit of a bluff, but the two cards
are still worthwhile.
>> Just spotted a bone skewer there. Was
that
>> That was a bone skewer.
>> Haven't seen that one happen just yet,
but certainly a card that can do some
pretty nasty things.
>> Yes. Most definitely.
>> Fur does get the first point on the
board for res. Rolling it up to the star
tipped peak and still the manner of the
bottom lane as Teemo is threatening to
hold for point number six first mate.
Going to ready Fiora. This one does not
have gank, but we will move her back to
base where it's nice and safe
and leave GG. Easy Teemo for another
day. Zash going to un going to awaken.
go ahead and collect point number six
>> and uh look to try and navigate to an
endgame state in the next turn or two.
Can't win this turn, but can certainly
set up to try and win on the next.
>> Closer and closer. I mean 6-1. You'd be
happy to be in that position any day.
>> It's going to be 7-1 now.
>> 71 with that Sprite.
>> Sprite Fountain the second and the third
as we can see in hand.
>> Mhm.
>> Getting some work done. I wonder how
often the uh just do it bone skewer has
worked. We may be about to find out.
Does stun the unit when you pick it. As
long as there's a unit to pick, but if
that unit's bigger than you want it to
be, might not work out so hot for you.
>> Oo, is it coming?
>> It's coming. Interesting.
>> It's coming later.
>> It's on its way.
>> All right. Well, uh it off you go. kind
of again blocking that it's a unit
because you are threatening to hold for
a win here
>> from six although I do believe Ash
should be at seven points
that Sprite did conquer off of that
fountain so
>> yep
>> GG easy T-Mo is threatening a win and
potentially so is the start peak
battlefield depending on what is under
that sprite
>> you got to be very very cautious if you
are res in terms of suspicion I suppose
you would think that the hidden card
would be something a little bit uh you
know more well not necessarily more
threatening the bone skewer plenty
threatening in its own way but I don't
know I feel like I would be very very
mindful of which one I mean you have to
go for both but still
>> yeah well it's an interesting bluff cuz
the temporary unit can't actually hold
the battlefield
>> Mhm.
>> But if there's a unit under there and
you don't go there well then you lose.
>> Exactly.
Separ though, the unit I was pointing
out earlier. Pretty good one. And bone
skew are going to get played.
>> There we go.
>> So that's I believe in I think that's
exactly where we are. I think we might
be at the point where Set is buffing.
Actually on the only unit that can be
picked. You don't have to choose a unit.
I do want to remind you all
>> for those of you who have not seen it
yet. Bone skewer reads, "Choose a
battlefield. An opponent reveals their
hand. You may choose a unit from it.
They play that unit to that battlefield,
ignoring any and all costs. When they
do, stun it.
>> So that Axon, if Ash wants to take it,
can only go to the battlefield where the
sprite is. And obviously Axan is bigger
than the sprite.
>> But given that it would be stunned and
wouldn't deal combat damage this turn.
All that would happen is Ashan would get
played and then basically have to go
back to base cuz it's not a combat Axan
can win.
>> Whether you want to do that or not, I
have no idea. Look,
>> because you kind of just play a unit for
your opponent for free otherwise
>> and Ashan can
>> or at least I believe should be able to
use his own playability. So I think
Axan's going to stay in the hand at
least make res pay for it if he's going
to come out. So that was in response to
the uh set brawler gets a buff trigger
using a very interesting uh uh not often
used reaction window. Then Fiora going
to trigger cuz sets now become mighty
recycle and order power to ready set.
And we've seen this many times in Fiora
at this point.
>> One of the reasons Sepu is such a
powerful unit in this deck.
I
>> have to say appreciate the giant box
that Ash has got his Teemo legend in.
>> Yes,
>> it's very pretty.
>> It is pretty. It's It's a good vibe.
We've definitely seen players uh for the
most part in the future mature have a
lot of love for their decks it seems
like.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Whether they are
representing it with their own
accessories, whether they are taking
good care with good deck boxes, whether
they're rocking some interesting hats,
who's to say
>> hats are two and0 in the future. I do
want to point that out.
>> Maybe that's what we've been missing.
>> Maybe that's
>> Yeah, surely we can we can rock a hat
over these headsets. Why not? Both the
Teemo hat and the bucket hat
>> currently undefeated
>> on day one.
>> That's the secret.
>> First mate going to go ahead and rolling
into the monastery though. And currently
three might is bigger than one. So the
hidden guard may make a difference, but
of course depends on what it is.
Little card from hand action here.
>> This is still an action even though it
is a card you can hide. Sprites call.
Going to make that fight a little less
fair.
So, an extra three might you maybe
weren't expecting now occupying that
battlefield. And you get to make a
choice. Do you want to kill the
temporary unit that's smaller, that's
bigger, or the real unit that's much
smaller? Cuz one way or another, your
first mate's going to lose this combat.
>> Yeah,
not ideal, but
see what happens.
>> And again, kind of the same situation.
you've figured out what the card on the
on the top battlefield is.
>> Mhm.
>> But again, if you don't and it's a unit,
you can lose. So instead, deciding that
going to have to kind of do it all and
roll back in with at least one more of
these units. Don't have to worry about
the star tip peak uh right now cuz that
sprite cannot hold to win that
battlefield, but it will get your point
if you go there. So there's some
attraction to it still.
But what is going to happen with that
monastery?
>> If it is a unit, it kind of depends how
big it is.
>> Yeah.
>> Ooh, existential dread.
>> Another little trick. This one says stun
an attacking unit.
If it's already stunned when you do it,
uh, instead return to hand. Does have
repeat. Does cost two to repeat that
here. So just the stun mode. You can
think about it like thonk basically
>> from calm.
>> Such cute art as well.
>> It's good. It's a real good one. I don't
know what the the little guy in there is
going through, but it's a lot.
>> Look, when hasn't existential dread
stunned some people, you know,
>> it's fair.
>> All right, so Set's spending his buff.
>> Goes back in.
>> Is that unit not still stunned?
H
>> I believe it is.
>> Yeah,
>> cuz res was like, "Oh, never mind.
>> No, I'm going to walk that one back."
>> Looks like Fiora,
I think, reddied it when it became
mighty again. Again, very convenient
numbers on this set where gets a buff
when you play it. Goes from four to
five, becomes mighty. Take the buff off
all of a sudden as a four again
temporarily until it becomes plus four.
Once again, gets mighty as Fior is going
to rumble on in and switcheroo. I think
he's going to seal game number one. That
Fiora is a lot smaller than she's
supposed to be. And that is it. Teemo
still rolling on strong here. Taking the
first game.
>> Can't say I saw it coming, but I'm
impressed.
>> I honestly should have cuz Switcheroo is
the one that it's always Switcheroo.
>> Yeah,
>> it's uh it's it's so much value in Teemo
because you so often have a one might
unit there just chilling out.
>> So, anything that rolls on if it's a
single unit is going to lose that fight.
>> Exactly. Right. Even if it's just unless
it's another one might unit I suppose.
>> I mean sure
>> they can just trade. It's fine.
>> But especially when there is that risk
then do you do you wonder which unit it
could possibly be? You can't you can't
not take the risk and you have to go for
it. So realistically it's going to work
out well.
>> Certainly did in that game for our
resident Teemo player. So far so good.
But uh certainly more games to be
played. see what Rez has in store as
both players have a look at their
sideboards,
>> shuffle up their decks, and figure out
what they want to do in games two and
three.
>> A little sneaky peek, seeing that there
was a sabotage there.
>> Saw Repost in that board.
>> Love having a peek.
>> Yeah,
>> just a little gander.
>> Just a little look.
>> So, uh, did mention repost. Fur
signature spell. Very powerful.
would have been good enough to not lose
the game on the spot to switch but was
not there. I believe the runes were
available. So Ash's gambit works out
blitz to five points in that game. It
felt like
>> with the very Trixy sprites plus uh
hidden units combination.
And from there able to navigate to a
point where finding one more point in
the game wasn't too tricky. And uh Teemo
can be decent at holding because again
you kind of build a little bluff for
your opponent every single game turn
after turn.
>> Absolutely.
>> When they're under points pressure never
feels good.
>> You put them in a position where they
cannot not take the risk. Look, you got
to do it.
>> Well, may not want to, but you certainly
have to at times as players are getting
shuffled up. So filter here for game
number two.
>> Flipped over one. Oh,
>> unflipped it, I believe.
>> Make sure the operations stay clean.
>> All smiles over there. It's good to see.
>> That is honestly impressive. It is. It
is late. The players started at 10:00
a.m. this morning.
>> Yeah,
>> it is. Currently 9:35 local time.
>> Oh, it has almost been 12 hours. So, to
still see smiles on faces, that's I
mean,
>> yeah,
>> testament to these people to how much
they are enjoying themselves.
>> Vibes certainly are immaculate. And
again, card game tournaments are long,
grueling affairs. Your brain is not
nearly as good at the end of the day as
it was when you started playing in the
morning. I can tell you that much. So to
continue to make good decisions, pilot
your deck well,
>> navigate through Teemo, making a little
virtual mental minefield to deal with in
the battlefield. This is tough.
Look, it you cannot underestimate the
value in making sure you are hydrated,
making sure you are fed, making sure
that you have little rest breaks
whenever you can just to mentally reset
just to get back in the zone for a very
long day.
>> Yep. And uh potentially, if you do well
tomorrow, going to be even longer.
Remember, if eight rounds of Swiss
today, cut to day two, all the X2s
should make it. So, at least be battling
for perhaps the best of perhaps perhaps
>> perhaps
>> top eight if uh breakers get a little
bit spicy for you. But X1 should feel
pretty good depending on where you lost
as well. And a bunch of the players
again, they're coming into this round
undefeated will have some undefeated
players to kick off tomorrow. So,
they'll be feeling pretty good about
their chances after three more. No, five
math
>> math.
>> Five more rounds of this.
>> 13 total. 8 + 5 is 13.
You're doing so well.
>> Eight rounds each day. Three of them at
top eight tomorrow.
>> Much math.
>> So yes, if you've enjoyed it so far,
we'll have basically the same amount of
rift bound tomorrow, but maybe even
more. Top eight is on time, so it can go
a little bit longer. As Battlefields are
up for round number two, Sunken Temple
for Fiora, something we probably could
have figured out when we looking at
Battlefields earlier in the meta
breakdown.
>> Yeah, tracks and then Grove the God
Willow. It's the first one I've seen
today.
>> Haven't seen too many of this one. See
it in set every now and then. Obviously
Ahri doesn't mind this one, but
>> I'm actually surprised we haven't seen
Vex on this battlefield. Like something
I thought
>> she might have liked basically is her
legend text, but uh a little bit
different, but no. In Teemo, of course,
is the first time we see Grove of the
Godwill, at least on stream.
>> Very interesting.
>> All right, players are drawing up for
game number two. So, let's go down to
the beach match area and uh have a look,
shall we? See what players are
considering. Ice by a beimo
>> tie turner consult and switcheroo the
>> in there still as well.
>> All right, two cards mulligan for Fiora.
>> We see a sabotage over here.
>> Ruin runner Fiora and a pit rookie. So I
was going to say there was no early unit
for Fiora in the last game that is going
to be rectified here in game number two.
Let's
>> see how this changes the pace.
>> Obviously as we said earlier Teemo going
up to five very quickly.
See how that plays out this time around.
>> So two back for both. Throwing a couple
more little windser and a gorilla war
team signature spell, excuse me. As pit
rookie not going to be able to buff
anyone but just fine here as an early
play for Tite.
Want to get on the battlefields and try
and hold on to them as Teemo
going to channel three runes and
>> fountain in there. Same card he liked in
the last game is going to be back on
deck.
>> Are we going to see the same thing
again?
>> I have a feeling we might.
>> Yeah, looks like it.
>> Sprite fountain makes a sprite.
>> Which one? N
>> to grove. And are we hiding again?
>> Look, it worked once.
>> Could work again.
>> Again. Hiding with air quotes given that
not so hidden before.
>> I appreciate that Ashes laughs every
time he does it. He's like, "Yeah, I'm
I'm hiding the thing. You definitely
know what it is. What are you going to
do about it?"
>> All of a sudden, five might alone at
that top battlefield. That isn't even
considering the trigger Teemo Strategist
gets when defending. So, this went from
looking like a really easy way to take a
battlefield early for Fiora. And now
that looks impossible to take that
battlefield. So, you're going to have to
take the other one instead perhaps.
>> Look, I mean, you would gravitate
towards sunken temple anyway, so not the
end of the world. But
>> well, the problem is sunk temple is a
battlefield you want to conquer.
>> Exactly.
>> And if you take it and sit there, can't
conquer it again.
>> And pit rookie might be a great unit,
but it is not mighty.
>> Not.
>> Oh, could be now actually.
>> Yeah,
>> but no extra resources to pay the
temples tax. Might still be worth it.
Those Fior is going to get you a rune
channel thanks to making a mighty unit
again. Give you basically a rebate on
the BF sword equip you just did. And uh
that may well be enough to contend with
the might in that top battlefield.
>> You can already do the math and know
that it is five.
>> Mhm.
>> A three plus the two for Teemo. I guess
you have to worry how good is my
opponent. Will they flip exactly five
hidden cards off the top of their deck?
>> And do you even want to trade? That's
the other thing, right? Do I actually
want to trade here or do I just want to
take the point? I don't think
>> you want to lose your temple value.
Never mind. Take the point.
can't pay Temple, so just heads it on
back. Team Strategist once again going
to do the thing. Flip on over as the
temporary unit says goodbye. Gets the
point and should get the card draw, I
believe.
>> Yeah,
>> up to two points. Draws a card for Gro
channels two runes. Believe did miss the
peak trigger in the last game, which is
why they're so carefully sequencing
these next few uh beginning of turn
steps.
Now, a pretty big grip as Ash moves into
turn number two, if you can believe it.
I feel like going second has been very
advantageous for Teemo.
>> Absolutely.
Interesting to see what we've got in
hand here.
>> Little bit of chatter at the table.
>> All right, so Sprite moving back in.
Fountain obviously made a second one.
Thanks for the death now. Didn't
consider
trying to contend with the pit rookie
>> was some possible options, but that
sprite at least will represent three
more might
at that battlefield. I think it would
have taken a little too much to try and
fight the pit rookie. You could have
switcheroo with that sprite and at least
won a combat for now, but
>> sure. I mean, get even more complicated
with something like uh Windser if you
can make the might small enough. But I
think instead Ash is saying even though
I went second, I kind of have the point
lead. So, I'm just going to try and sit
here and keep it.
>> You know, I can't blame them honestly.
>> I think the other thing is if you vacate
the temple for your opponent by making
it conquerable,
>> and they get to draw more cards and
you're already drawing cards. You're
just chilling on the grove. You're
having a great time.
You're uh relaxed, moisturizing your
lane.
Just let him let Fior let Fiora have a
visit. You know,
>> have it. It's fine.
>> I got six cards in my hand and one I got
five cards in my hand and one hidden.
What do you want?
>> Yeah, that math.
>> It was six before.
>> All right, here's six runes being
exhausted. There's a ruin runner.
>> Pretty good unit.
>> Mhm. Where is it going to go? Well, it's
going to chill out in the base for now,
but I think it's going to head towards
that very cluttered battlefield up in
the top in just a moment, but for now,
it is point number three. And it is card
number two just from this grove of the
Godwiller alone.
>> Channel two runes and draw a fresh card
for the turn.
>> Huge swath of cards in hand here for
this Teemo.
>> See Rebuke, see a Noctturn. I see a tide
turner. Switch wins a gorilla warfare
sprites call
>> the options here
>> lot of options
>> mean res holding cards very close
>> kind of get a little peak there
>> pretty sure I caught a sabotage
>> I think uh deciding to think about what
you want to do about the rune runner
>> and whether you want to try and do
anything about the pit rookie if you can
cuz teammate strategist I've said it a
few times but it's such an excellent
defender with that defense trigger like
doing I think the average is what like
two and a half damage or so
>> something like that.
>> Uh you know that's enough to at least
trade with a bunch of different units
even though Temo himself is not all that
big.
But Ruin Runner doesn't care about any
of that cuz you can't choose it with
enemies spells or abilities and Teemo
for Fiora is very much the enemy. Just
having a little read of Fiora there.
>> Again, as we were saying earlier, not
everybody will have prepared for every
matchup. Oh no.
>> So understandable to have a little peek
and refamiliarize yourself with what
you're up against.
>> I think I think the rep part of that
word is important cuz even if you do
know, even if you have actually tested
>> or played much of a bunch, you might not
remember exactly halfway through the
final round of the day after 11 hours of
rift pound. as tie turner.
>> Going to let Teemo exchange places. The
teammate strategist is going to roll on
over to the other side. So, we're
switching it up here at the sunken
temple.
>> Doing a little switcheroo again there.
>> I would like to be the mighty unit,
which hilariously also lets Teemo
trigger hidden temple sunken temple.
>> So, now five to two
>> except for the Teemo side,
>> which we very aptly named.
I feel like at the end of the day, a lot
of people will be making the face of
Switcheroo just from purely just being
so exhausted. I I you got to respect it.
>> So I think considering the temple
trigger,
>> he's going to use it. No, he's going to
hide something.
>> Ah,
>> and again. Oh, we can't hide. Oh, no,
no, no, no, no, no. That's not allowed.
>> You cannot hide more than one card in a
battlefield. that is not named the
bandal tree.
>> Think having it to the side there. Got a
little off guard.
>> All right. So, uh, order restored.
Noticed it immediately. And, uh, just,
you know, leave her in open.
>> See what happens. I'm I'm pretty sure
Tim was big enough to get the sunken
temple conquer,
>> I would imagine. So, I
>> think so. Anyway, think about it another
day perhaps.
>> As back to res we go. Four to two in
points. Fur trailing by a couple
>> as Ash is on pace
>> to win in two turns
if he's able to get both points every
single time. But
>> I do suspect that through and runner is
going to cause a bunch of problems
because all of the tricks that Teemo has
>> basically just don't work on this card.
It does put a little spanner in the
works there, but I mean for for Teemo
going this well, who's to say what can
happen?
>> Just trying to think what you could
possibly have here cuz Fu doesn't work.
Can't target the camel.
>> Uh Team Strategist doesn't even get to
do anything. Don't even get to deal some
damage.
>> So you could have a unit, right? But you
all know that the unit the size of the
unit is going to be three.
>> Yeah,
>> even if it was Pike, which is another
option this tech could play. Uh, if it's
a sprite's call, that's about as big. I
guess sorry, it could be Teemo Scout.
That's a four.
>> Sure, it could.
>> But then it'll be six might versus five,
which looks good, but then you realize
the BF sword's on the table and it's
never not getting equipped to this ruin
right now.
>> Oh, absolutely.
>> Yeah.
>> So, he's trying to play around it like
go where it can only go to one
battlefield at a time.
>> That's true.
>> So, perhaps you just take the other one
every turn and hope that one point a
turn is enough with a two-point lead.
Noturn, I suppose.
>> No turn. Maybe
>> you do still get to use the Teemo
strategist trigger. I believe you. You
just can't choose Ruin Runner. So, it
just doesn't do anything.
>> Mercifully, you can only choose enemy
units. So, you don't have to kill your
own units. Yes,
>> that would be a bad time.
>> Oh, rough.
>> All right. Where's the camel going?
And as is picking up the sword, I have
to assume so. A lot of runes awake here
for res. So can't imagine one of them
isn't going to get used to power up this
rune runner to be a little bit better in
the upcoming combats.
>> All right.
>> What's happening with that?
>> Kinku init initiate.
If you have uh it's a new card actually
from unleashed
>> but when you play this if you draw one
if you your other units have total might
five or more kind of an interesting
little three might three energy unit
from the set. Ruin runner is going to
indeed pick up the sword and tide turner
is going to be paid to visit
2v7 there. Love the little graphic, but
uh
don't think you needed either that or me
to tell you that this is bad news.
>> Yes.
>> The for the uh for the Titan. It was a
Teemo.
>> Yep.
>> And uh it's going to get shown, but yep,
not big enough. Six is not as big as
eight.
>> So, Ruin Runner, as expected, wins that
first combat. Going to go to three
points now for
>> going to be very tricky to contend with
that one. Now,
>> I'm like racking my brain trying to
think like Thousand Tail Watcher, I
guess.
would be a way to deal with that card
because that doesn't actually choose.
>> Not that many outs.
>> Not really. Not
>> that Teemo has as Fiora going to get
played again. Fiora victorious. Seen
this one already. When it gets mighty,
it gets a bunch of extra keywords which
is good in the deck that wants to make
everything mighty.
>> Absolutely.
This is Ash going to go ahead awaken
those
permanence and have a look at five
points of what we can do here. Even that
rebuke that I can see in the far left of
Teemo's hand is not good against Ruiner.
And seriously, it is all the tricks that
you would normally use just do not work.
You have to beat it uh let's say fairly
with enough might in combat for real for
real. And uh against a deck like Fiora,
that opportunity does not come very
often cuz you might not be able to
target it, but she can target it as much
as she wants.
>> Absolutely. And you're not necessarily
seeing uh a lot of big Teemo cards
there.
>> Noturn's the biggest unit we've seen so
far at four might. And that's Teemo
Scout sometimes.
>> It's Little Yawn escapes the uh the uh
the mouth of Ashos. Again,
>> speaking of Nocturn,
>> long day is Nocturn going to just be
played the regular way by paying its
actual cost instead of finding it
miraculously on the top of the deck. And
uh point beholding and a card draw
thanks to Grover the Godwiller here as
Raz awakens to a very pleasant surprise.
Still down in points, but not by much
and could get to parody this turn if
that Teemo strategist is upended from
the bottom battlefield.
I don't like Teemo's chances.
>> No, not looking great.
>> Four and a three. That four is going to
usually quite a bit bigger. And Teimo
strategist again very good at picking
off some units of size. So again, we're
going to This one you have to be a
little bit careful with.
>> When you send the units in one by one,
uh Team Strategist triggers every time
he defends. So that's two,
>> three, that's already enough to kill it.
Baron. Nope. The Baron.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> And Tumo Strategist, that's four. That's
enough damage to kill the Kinko
initiate. Goodbye.
>> So Team Strategist holds strong.
>> Oh, looks like Ash's writing down the
cards that recycles to the bottom of his
deck. That is very diligent.
>> Interesting. Look, at this time of day,
it makes sense to keep track of what's
going on a little bit more than you
might normally.
>> Are allowed to take notes. This is
something that uh
>> some decks uh do relatively often. I
know Allan did it a lot. I think he did
it in his head, but he did it a lot
playing Ezreal. Yes,
>> that uh that deck was so good at
churning through all its cards with cold
shot in particular,
>> but uh especially with decks that see a
lot of cards in chunks. Aurora sometimes
does this. Uh baited hook decks often do
this. Uh Teemo kind of makes sense.
You're seeing cards in increments of
five that you can maybe reasonably keep
track of. So is interesting to see Ash,
but I think it makes sense as you are
going to churn through your deck with
some regularity as Fiora threatening to
pick up the sword that's been played,
>> which uh would maybe be helpful not only
for all the keywords it gets access to.
Oh, never mind. Ruin one are going to
ruin the party as it were.
>> Y
>> I didn't like that little Teemo
strategist trigger. So I'm just going to
plow through it.
>> Yeah.
>> How do you like that? Uh
>> if I'm the team player, I don't like it
at all. On the fur player, I'm very
happy with how the second game is going.
Oh, all the beer swords. Oh my goodness.
We're all in on the on the ruin runner.
>> Makes a lot of sense.
>> So that is going up to
>> big number.
>> That is a nine.
>> 11.
>> 11. There you go.
>> Math.
>> Wininger. That one is good to gust the
Teemo.
>> Nifty little play, but not enough to
save the battlefield. Sunken Temple
Trigger. I certainly have a mighty unit
here. I would like to draw a card.
>> Absolutely.
>> And uh point parody has been achieved.
>> Five five.
>> Definitely a much stronger game this
time for Rez.
>> Might not last with Noturn threatening
to score yet again at the go over the
god Willow, but
>> feels like Fiora's units are a little
too big. Yeah, look, it is going to be
difficult to match up here,
>> especially with those swords on.
>> Yeah, I mean, even if the Ruin Runner
doesn't make its way back in in a hurry,
>> first bit and Fiora are seven might on
their own. So, and Fiora again gets uh
even scarier very quickly.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Whenever you make her mighty, which is
kind of the whole thing Fiora wants to
do as a deck.
>> You do want mighty units, but you don't
want them to start as mighty units. You
want to train them in the way of the
blade.
I'm going to see the journey, you know.
>> And for and for the journey, you get
runes.
>> Exactly. A just reward.
>> A just
>> All right. So, we know about the team of
strategist cuz of course it was a bounce
back with that wind singer.
>> Mhm. Is there another Sprite fountain
coming in here?
>> Certainly looks like it.
>> There we go.
>> That suspiciously looks like the cost
for Sprite Fountain.
>> Not technically how that works, but a
little bit of shortcutting is uh seems
fine. Not too long left in the round. 16
minutes for these two players. And could
be a third game to play. So point number
six comes through for Ash and OCE.
Hiding a card, passing it back and
saying, "What do you got?"
>> Maybe he's considering if there's
anything else that wants to happen here.
>> Kind of terrifying with a full might
unit ready in base to just be leaving it
there. But I think Ash just considering
>> the rest of this turn
still got a lot of
>> options there.
>> Yeah, holding up rebuke makes sense.
Holding up sprites call is a card we've
seen you can play at action speed still.
Obviously, again though, one of the
benefits of hiding cards is that when
you get to play them, you didn't pay
very much for them. So, sprite score
cost three, but you hit it for one power
or one energy if you're Teemo.
>> Uh, get a pretty good discount on that
card. Still though dealing with that
Ruin Runner.
>> Well, Ruin Runner is Ru Runner's over
there, right?
>> Yeah, but still.
>> That's a that's a next turn's problem.
>> Patience is a virtue.
>> Noturn did move over. Oh, sabotage. All
right, Jigs up. What do you got?
>> Show me your spells.
>> All right,
>> so uh three hits of this fourcard hand.
Tie Turner. Not one you can take, but
Guerilla Warfare, Sprite Call, and
Rebuke.
>> Now, if you were Rez, what are you
picking?
>> Rebuke.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I think all of the in general, Body does
not like to see Rebuke,
>> given that that card kind of makes
combat feel a bit impossible at times
when you spend all this time and effort
to make your units all big and strong
and train at the French barracks or
whatever Fior is up to. Still having to
think about it though.
>> I think it's important to even uh even
late in the day, even when uh you're
going to have to play a third game if
you do want to keep your record
relatively unblenmished.
>> Take the time when you can. Can't take
too much time, but you do want to take
time
>> when it's important and does indeed
recycle that rebuke.
>> Makes a lot of sense.
>> Knows about the sprites call though.
That's the only other card that could
affect the upcoming combat this turn.
obviously has to think about the hidden
card as well.
>> Death group. Yep, just a brief one.
>> Yeah,
>> rookie spectral matron. Always a fun
one.
>> Pretty good with first mate, honestly.
>> Could be a way to actually reset the
ruin runner.
>> Retreat to base.
>> Run the first mate in to its untimely
demise. Maybe trade off with the unit
and then uh
>> play the matron to reset it from your
yard. does currently have enough
resources to do that. Going to equip
this sword, make Fiora mighty, channel a
rune exhausted.
>> Also, death grip just pretty good card
right now in general.
>> Yeah,
>> not sure pit rookie is where we want to
be, but I think the math is mathing and
think res is starting to realize that my
units are quite a bit bigger than yours.
Starting to play catch-up here in this
game.
There you go.
>> Okay.
>> Rookie indeed.
>> So, turning off the matron first mate
line here, but buffing up the fur,
making it even bigger. Seems just fine.
>> Mhm.
>> It's an eight might unit right now with
uh ganking, deflect, and shield.
Seven might that top battlefield. So
eight is a slightly larger number.
Again, if it's another switcheroo, you
might feel a bit silly,
but uh got to do something. Rolling on
in. And the first m's coming in, too.
>> There you go. A decisive play. I love to
say it.
>> See what happens.
>> The chosen champion units in the way of
progress here. There's too many things
on this Fiora. You got a buff, you got
equipment. She's loaded up.
>> Boy, is she mighty.
>> Certainly is.
wasn't when the turn started. Certainly
is now.
>> Currently 11 plays seven.
>> Ruin Runner holding down the fort
at the sunken temple.
It doesn't seem all that easy
for Teemo to
>> break through as you have a little peek
at the hidden card.
>> We're going to see it one way or the
other. It is Teemo Strategist
>> and you do get the trigger points the
first mate. M.
>> So that would be 4 5 6 7 8 9us
3 would be eight. That would mean Teemo
would win the day on combat if there's
nothing else behind this for res.
Assuming we flip at least three hidden
cards up,
>> you would think, but who's to say at
this point? All right, we've got
>> had a death grip. Didn't want to use it.
That's not Those are not hidden cards.
That one is
>> There we go. That one is
>> That one is not
>> says the word hidden on it. Is not a
hidden card.
>> Not a hidden card.
>> All right. So, uh, two damage dealt to
the first mate, but that is not enough
to fell it. That will mean that Fury is
going to be happy with how this all
plays out. Not going to have much left,
but going to have enough.
>> Again, writing down the cards in the
stack.
>> I respect it.
Seeing what's there, what's what's
potentially coming up later.
Giving him a little shuffle and put him
on the bottom. And now, uh, are we just
going to combat or we playing something
else?
>> It's a little bit of discussion.
>> Yep. One player passes.
>> Yep.
>> Looks like Ash may be passing as well.
>> Some quick counting.
I believe there's enough might for a
trade to happen here thanks to that two
damage. So
>> doesn't get to win the combat, but does
at least maybe get to equalize it here.
>> Still the same problem on the bottom
battlefield, but
>> again something I have to think about
later.
>> Exactly. That's next time's problem.
>> Next turn's coming up pretty quick,
unfortunately.
So that is nine on one side, that is 11
on the other, but two damage marked on
that first mate means that should be
nine allto together.
>> Equalized there. Yep.
>> Right. Everyone
goes away.
>> Mhm.
>> So no one left at the grove of the god
Willow. No readyed units available.
We're not sure Rez can sneak on in for
point number seven, at least this turn.
>> But still holding at the sunken temple
there.
So it happens for two more turns. Feel
pretty good about your chances.
>> Yeah,
>> I guess at this point the pit rookies
also threatening to just roll on in with
the BF sword next turn as well. They're
going to play Fior worthy and impassive
back to try and get as much presence as
possible
in the base and just say I'm pretty sure
I can figure it out next turn.
>> Equips the sword right now. Why not?
>> Makes it mighty.
>> Doesn't get Fior activated though. Oh,
readying it. That's why I like that a
lot.
>> Do it.
>> So, using Fiora worthy when a unit you
control becomes mighty, you may pay an
order power to ready it.
>> I like
>> had to recycle a few runes, but got the
seventh point and now
>> for threatening to win on either
battlefield by holding.
>> Goodness me.
>> And again, we've already talked about
how this run feels basically
impenetrable.
>> Yeah.
>> So, at seven points when you just need
to hold for to eight. Seems like we're
going to game three. looking pretty
likely with only 8 minutes left in the
round here. It's going to be very
interesting.
>> Sprites aoy in the top battlefield, but
again,
don't think that's the one that uh Ash
needs to deal with.
>> Not so much. I just I feel like there's
really not much that can be done here.
>> We got to scoop it up and play game two
cuz we do not have very long left in the
round.
>> Yep.
>> Still going for it though. Consult the
pass. What else do we have?
I don't even what we have.
>> Yeah,
>> not those.
>> Nope.
>> All right, shuffle them up.
>> There we go.
>> Got seven and a half minutes, boys.
>> Two rounds.
>> You're playing three.
>> Now, if we do get to uh extra turns, I
believe, if memory serves, the overtime
rules are the active player gets to play
a turn, their turn zero, and there's
three additional turns. So, one, two
each, if you want to think about it like
that way. You will win if you are ahead
by two or more points or if you somehow
get to eight in those remaining turns
depending where the game is at
>> amount of time.
>> I have to say if I'm looking at a deck
to get two points and maybe stay ahead
kind of seems like it might do it.
>> Look, I would be you know what I would
be kind of thrilled if Teemo continued
the streak here. It would be very
impressive. I mean, Fury can also get on
get on base, as it were,
>> relatively quickly,
>> but players are going to have to play
real quickly here.
>> Yeah,
>> cuz I don't think either of these
players want another draw.
>> Oh, no, not so much.
>> Even though it would mean they're still
both undefeated. As we have a look at
the deck list, once again, this is just
the main deck. Again, we don't know what
the sideboards look like, but uh some
options here for the early drops here.
Well, we do know that the Ruin Ripper
came in and side.
>> It certainly did. That card looked very
good, didn't it?
>> That did make a considerable difference
there.
>> Yes, three pit pit rookies, three unsung
heroes.
>> Didn't see any Lucian that time around.
>> Lucian pretty good. Also very good at
getting points. So
>> maybe something that would be uh
>> work to great effect.
>> Mhm.
>> In uh in this particular game, which is
under I guess some slightly different uh
not yet, but potentially going to be
playing under slightly different rules
given how much time is left in the
round. So
>> judging by that, it looks like we are
going with Trafarian War camp for the
last battlefield there.
>> So you got to go. Pretty good at making
your units mighty
>> by making them just one bigger.
something the baited hook players know a
lot about. Your might values are very
important to you.
>> I feel like we need a tally count for
how many times you've said baited hook
this weekend.
>> I think it's only up to I think I've
less than five so far today.
>> A lie.
>> I'll have a look at Ash's deck as well.
That one Baron very curious addition to
this deck. I guess maybe it's really
wanted a third battlefield to hide stuff
at.
>> Look, fair enough. But also, I don't
imagine that it sees a lot of play. I
also noted and I I did clock this when
we first saw this deck list, but sneaky
deck hand is the card in the main of
this deck. And again, looking at cards
that are good at getting points early in
a game that is not going to be played
for that many turns unless the players
play at light speed. Feels like there
are some things here that might look
good, but the players are ready cuz
again, they need to play quickly. There
is going to be about 6 minutes left in
this round.
>> Also, if I clocked that right, we've got
Arena's greatest.
Well, well, well.
>> Perhaps we will get all the way to the
end of the game.
>> Anything to to speed it up a little.
>> Yep. There we go. The arena's greatest
is coming in third for Ashen.
>> The battlefield choices of this team
deck got like kind of wild and wilder. I
feel like
>> as the game rolled on, I don't think I
would have predicted that one.
>> No.
>> If you asked me to predict them blind,
but
>> seems good. Again, a very aggressive
slanted Teamo list by the looks of
things. Wanting to get points early and
hold on to them for dear life. See if
that works out here in our final game.
And again, players have four minutes
left.
>> Oh goodness me.
>> So there's a two. It is a hidden card,
but don't worry about that. We're not
hiding anything right now. It is time to
get points ASAP.
>> Mhm.
>> Little Evelyn moment.
>> Think we've seen one
uh face up Evelyn trigger today. It was
pretty sweet.
>> Hoping to see more tomorrow. Very cool
hidden card added to the roster. See
that switcheroo in hand? Oh,
>> put him away.
>> Nah, hidden. No one needs to see.
>> Still hidden. S Fiora.
>> All right.
>> Couple more runes. One card. Slide on
in.
>> Mhm.
>> If there was ever a time to get points,
it's right now.
>> Got to go for it.
>> Sprite call also here. It looks like
probably Sprite call. Hide. Hide after
conquering.
>> Mhm. Evelyn straight in there.
>> Two points to one. going to be three
soon if that surprise call has anything
to do with it. And I think Ash knows the
drill.
>> Yeah,
>> honestly I think the deck would play
this way regardless given the uh kind of
the game plan and the strategy
presented.
>> But certainly again with less than 3
minutes left in this round. I think this
is
>> got to go for it.
>> Yeah. Not even just the way he wants to
play. Probably the best way to play
right now.
>> Exactly right. Exactly. And then we have
again the so-called hidden. I do
appreciate the how how how much joy it
brings out
>> a little eyebrow raise every time a
little smirk.
>> I mean honestly if this is going to be
how you want to play the game it does
make sense that that is the teamote in
your champ zone.
>> Absolutely. Some very decisive play
there with only two and a half minutes
to go,
>> but uh threatening to get to five points
next turn. And I don't know how easy it
is for Fiora to walk into either of
these battlefields.
>> No, not so much.
>> Right now, not mighty.
>> Only good at readying mighty units. And
she's already ready. He got played on
turn two.
>> Truly don't have a lot of time to think.
So even something like
>> so okay you know it's simo strategist on
on trafarian war camp
>> it also actually is kind of problematic
because that war camp represents one
extra might that wouldn't be there
normally usually war camp is pretty easy
it's just you take the base numbers for
both of the units and you add one more
and it's like well it's basically the
same right if it's two threes that's
kind of like two fours and that's the
same well that math gets different when
you have more than one unit at the
battlefield all of a sudden your
opponent is benefiting a little bit more
than you are
>> so currently that sprite is four with
the war camp and we know that there's a
team and that's three more. That's
seven. Fur is currently at three.
>> Yeah. Look,
>> so even a BF sword not enough to win the
combat straight up,
>> but you don't really want to go to the
other places. You don't know what's
there.
>> Yeah.
>> Little smile on Ash's face.
>> Certainly someone that is a little
teeocated in their mannerisms, I will
say.
>> Getting down to the wire here. It's got
to be difficult to have the last game of
the day come down to the wire like that.
You've already got a lot going on.
>> Unsung hero.
>> Not the unit you really want to see
right now. Would have been great on the
first turn of the game.
>> Oh, absolutely.
But it is what it is.
>> Another one.
>> Another one coming out.
>> Go.
>> Two points. Same old trick. Flip over
for the hidden Teemo.
>> Yep.
>> Wasn't so hidden.
>> Came straight from the champion. Up to
five points. Four-point lead.
>> With 30 seconds left in the rounds.
>> Look at this point.
>> Channel draw, hide, pass back. Can't
imagine there's too much more to think
about here.
There's three, two, one. There.
>> All right. So, who is the active player?
>> It is still Ash from what I can see on
my screen. He's going to pass back. So,
I I wonder if that was turn zero.
>> If that is true, and let's just let's
just use that as our working assumption
because I have no other way to know
right now. Mhm.
>> Rez is on turn one. There are three more
turns to be played from this point. 01
23.
>> So R should be the last player.
>> Ash should get one more turn after this
pass back. Currently ahead
with enough points to win by.
>> Mhm.
>> Need to win by two. If you can't win the
game outright.
>> Outright.
>> Yeah. Five to one at this point. You've
got to be feeling pretty good.
And judging by the look on Ashen's face,
not feeling too dissatisfied there. All
smiles still the whole game regardless
of what's been going on.
>> Yep. Very u very mischievous.
Again, very uh very much aligned with
aligned with the Teemo brand.
>> Definitely Teemo energy.
>> All right, so let's have a quick think,
shall we?
>> Three, four, five, six, seven might.
Looks like Judge is explaining
the uh extra turns procedure, I imagine,
to the table. Mhm.
>> And uh the judge did indicate one over
on res's side of the table. So I believe
>> based on everything we know, I believe
our current working assumption is
correct as unsung hero is going to try
and face check this Evelyn.
Going to say, what is your hidden card?
I'm happy to trade my unit. I just want
to see what's up.
>> Checks both of them. Can play either.
They are playable as reactions.
We know one of them is consult the past
which is not a combat card. We can say
>> in hand there
>> switcheroo wouldn't do anything here
actually cuz
>> it just go for two.
>> Yeah, both units have the same might
value.
probably not teammo strategies because I
don't think you'd think this long.
>> The battlefield itself is the arena's
greatest. There's nothing special
happening there. We have to keep track
of. It's tie turner. Ah,
>> interesting.
>> Now, this does work.
>> Yes.
>> Swap on over and you still get your
defend trigger. There's a hidden card.
There's not a hidden card. There's a
hidden card. And that is a failed unsung
hero.
>> Yep.
>> Going to take three damage after that
flip. So first attempt unsuccessful.
>> Does potentially open the floodgates for
the war camp though.
>> Noticeably not riding this one down
given the amount of time that we've got
left.
>> Yeah, I think at this point you're not
going to make it to the bottom of your
deck again.
>> No, no, no.
>> Unsung hero again. This time offering
yet another two for two trade. I think
this is somewhat smartly checking for
switcheroo.
>> Yep.
>> So, but consult the pass going to be
shown instead. Going to draw two more
cards. Could still have a window here to
play something like a sprites call.
>> Looks like we've got Is that abandon?
>> See a ride the wind.
>> That is
a very good card.
>> Yeah. Abandon, consult the pass,
switcheroo, tie turner number two, I
believe, and ride the wind.
>> Mhm. Here's Fiora. Fiora victorious.
We shall see. Trailing very badly in
points. He's only been able to trade at
one of the battlefields. Sabotage.
>> Sabotage.
>> Do you just abandon it?
>> I guess play it again.
>> Probably not then.
>> Pretty dire.
>> I guess if you lose your switch, it
might be hard to beat the Fiora.
>> True.
>> I mean, the team trigger can also get it
done for you. So
>> I I feel like it's kind of clear that
your opponent doesn't have a way to
>> like a piece of equipment for their
Fura.
>> Yeah,
>> they would have played it already. Could
have a punch first, right? Which
obviously you only see in combat,
>> but a little sneak peek there.
>> I don't think the hands too worried.
First mate Fiora
>> pit rookie. I think a lot of units at a
glance. Again, not great in the combat
situation you currently find yourself
in.
>> Could also score off ride the wind as
well,
which would think five to six. That
would actually threaten a win.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh if you're able to find a way to get
on the other battlefield.
>> Yeah,
>> switcheroo going to get taken. Seems
like the most powerful card of the
bunch.
>> Makes a lot of sense.
>> So, here's the interesting thing. Oh,
never mind. F going there.
>> Oh, he's doing it now.
>> Ride the teamer. Oh, goodness. We're at
it again.
>> Oh, there we go.
>> I'm still defending.
>> Trigger.
>> Ready.
>> Yep. Let's see what happens. Wait, this
actually wins if he just if he kills the
Fura actually wins. There's one.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> There's two.
>> That's enough. It's only a three my
units. One more. Four damage dealt.
There he
>> is.
>> Is there another spell? So going to take
the point on this stone. Take out the
Fiora and then just hold for two points
and actually get to eight thanks to the
arena's greatest.
>> Goodness.
>> Is there anything else that Raz has to
not literally lose in extra turns? I I
really don't think so at this point, but
>> that's pit rookie.
>> There's the buff. You're going to get
your runes from the legend. But
>> the two points for Ash needs literally
on the table.
>> Didn't have many turns left actually
with the maximum number of turns
available to him. Has found a way to win
this game. GG.
>> What a finish.
>> Wow. You've got to be pretty pretty
happy with that. You can I mean, look,
Ash looks very very pleased.
two extra turns basically, right? Turn
zero, turn two, that was the turn, and
turn zero was very short. That was
basically the end of Ash's regular turn
already.
>> And I think about 2 minutes of game.
>> So 2 minutes and 1 and a half extra
turns was enough to win Teemo an actual
regulation game of Rift.
>> Incredible. I mean, the arena's greatest
did come in clutch.
>> Yeah, that helped a bit.
>> Definitely. Again, not something that I
would expect to see, but hey, it it got
him there in the end.
>> Well, I guess we do need to have a
dramatic finish.
>> Yeah.
>> Little round eight. And that was a
pretty dramatic finish. About as close
as it can get as far as game dur go.
>> Look, uh, great way to finish out the
day. I'm very, very excited to be able
to see now how these decks will go
tomorrow. I'm I'm curious to see how
Teemo runs now going through.
>> I'm curious to see where our standings
are up to.
>> Yes. I don't know how far through round
eight we are, but I have a feeling we
can't have too many matches left.
Obviously, time has been called. The P
match almost always has extra time. So,
if they're going to extra turns, likely
the round timer has run out. How many
matches left to play? We do not know as
going to move over for an interview and
hopefully when we come back with that
very uh jolly looking man still
undefeated technically on Teemo in day
two at 70 and one only a draw. The only
stumble in the record. Not even a loss.
Just a draw.
>> Yeah, just a draw. Still counts as
undefeated.
>> I wonder if we'll have the standings
ready at that point. We'll have to find
out in just a moment. But when is ready,
we'll get down there cuz I don't know
about you, I'd love to hear more about
this team.
>> Absolutely. I want to hear more. I'm
very very curious. And obviously I feel
like we're going to have a very jovial
Ash on the other side there. So very
keen to hear what they've got to say.
>> I feel like that would have been true
regardless of the results.
>> Yeah. I mean, as you said, Teemo Energy,
right?
>> Yes. Very much Teemo Energy, which
again, a deck that I started to enjoy
more and more. This is Chararma's fault
if anyone's wondering. Uh, it happened
in Atlanta where we just happened to put
Teemo on stream for Chararma and this is
what happens. I'm waiting to hear what
Ash has to say. Let's go down with an
interview with our winner.
>> Thank you so much, Perry. I am here with
the winner, Ashen OCE. And I'm pretty
excited to see you win because Ashen,
you and I, we know so much about each
other from other esports. And I do want
to ask you, how did your esports uh
experience in in other games transfer
over here to Riftbound?
>> Look,
it's it helped me cope under pressure.
Uh a little higher. Uh it helped me cope
under the pressure. Uh end of the day, I
feel like I in that matchup just then
specifically, I made less mistakes
because um albeit I did make a big one
at the start. Uh I made less mistakes
because I'm more used to the high
pressure environment and um while my
opponent unfortunately was not.
>> Yeah, the long day as well. I mean, this
was the eighth round of the day. Did you
get a buy at the start?
>> I did. I did. I managed to get a a
couple of skirmish wins on Teemo and we
we took him in, you know. I didn't I
didn't cheat with another legend. know
teammo got this game to win. I got the
team here.
>> That's good to hear. Um you have of
course drawn one game previously that
was against the Ezreal. How did you feel
about that matchup and would you say
that Ezreal is one of the legends you
want to look out for or is there
something else?
>> Uh look, it depends on the pilot, right?
Ezreal and it depends how he's built it,
right? Uh if it's a hand Ezreal, they're
they're usually all right. It's the uh
it's the more it's the more control
Ezreals. They're a little they're a
little tougher, but end of the day, it's
a high skill deck. I I did play Ezreal
for a brief period to test it out. Um,
and it's it's up to the pilot, right?
Like I'd say if he pilots it perfectly,
they've got the edge over me 100%. But
if they make some mistakes, I I I'll
sweep him.
>> So, I mean, you are making day two. That
is absolutely guaranteed. How are you
feeling going into day two with this uh
701 score?
>> Yeah. No, it's uh it's fantastic. Uh it
would be it would be great if it was
8-0. Alas, uh, you know, the the I tied
to, he was really a really great pilot.
It was really tight.
>> Um, if we didn't go to time, he probably
uh probably would have won if we had
infinite time uh with how the game was
going. So, you know, kudos to him. But
if he played faster, he probably he
probably he could have taken the win off
me. So, you know, um but you know, we
got here and I'm quite happy. I was
expecting five wins at best. So, I'm
excited to to to get seven and not drop
a single game. So yeah, that's really
that's really I'm really happy about
that.
>> Well, having your score being 701 means
there is a possibility of getting best
of there was another team. I'm not
entirely sure what the score line is for
that, but they were currently 70. Are
you currently vying now for this best of
was that your plan coming in or has
plans changed?
>> Yeah, I was I was I wasn't trying to get
top 64. I wasn't trying to get top card.
I wasn't trying to make day two. I just
wanted best of Teemo in the past. Best
of Teemo hasn't even made it to day two.
I was thinking I've cooked up a really
nice deck with the help of a uh of a guy
named Noah from America. Um he he he he
he did a lot of work on this deck. So
big shout out Noah. You're the best. Um
so realistically it was it was
I thought I would have it on lock but
the other Teemo player who was 70 I
don't know if he's gone 8-0 if he lost
or if he tied. Um but he's got he's got
a really cool deck. Completely different
to mine. Completely different. Uh we've
gone two different directions, which is
really cool to see that one legend can
go so many different directions. Um and
I'm not sure who's going to take it.
It's it's very tight. Uh and he's a
really good pilot, that's for sure.
>> Well, I mean, there are only 30 teamals
in the regional qualifier, Sydney, right
now, which is only 2.4%, 19th at the
moment. And the fact that two teams
minimum are making it to day two is
pretty exciting. Um so, what other
matchups are you scared of tomorrow?
What who are you scared of in
particular? Who and who do you think's
going to be taking the qualifiers all
up?
>> The scariest for me is a a perfect
opening hand aurora. Uh you know, like
not much to do if there's a gust in into
a with immobilize into a catalyst into
Aurora. Not much I can do. That's just a
loss, right? Um but if that doesn't
happen, it's fine. So that is obviously
always scary if that ever happens. Um,
outside of that, it's those general
control matches. Uh, they are very high
skill, as I said earlier, the Diana, the
Ezrael, those type of people, they're
very hard to pilot correctly to the to
the best. And but if they do, as I said,
they do have the edge over me 100%. And
if they don't make any mistakes and I
can't bait them with some cheeky hiddens
here and there, they'll they'll take
they they'll probably take the win. Um,
but you never know, right? Like I I I've
absolutely cheesed a couple games with
insane off the top. I had like three
damage and two nocturns revealed. That
was that was that that was that was
cooked. And then I immediately followed
up with five damage and with another
reveal and it was really rough for the
opponent that I versed early in the
tournament. Um poor guy. And I I
genuinely feel bad for him. Yeah, I feel
like the deck that you're playing with
Teemo, one way of putting it is it's
kind of a gamble deck with you're of
course revealing the top, see how many
hiddens there are, how much damage you
can deal, but also of course uh putting
those hidden cards underneath. You're
forcing the opponent to also gamble like
what kind of hidden card it is. How else
would you describe your deck?
>> Look, it's it's very adaptive. Uh you
can't just, you know, do what Aurora
does. You walk in with a set game plan.
You do it, you win. Uh or you lose,
right? Uh it's it's very I'd say, you
know, not it's very changing based on
what's happening, right? So every single
based on every single matchup, I'm
putting a different battlefield first
based on every single uh possible
opponent uh what they play. I it changes
how I hide things. So uh there's even
times when I might I sideboard
completely differently. uh, of course,
as everyone would, but I even sideboard
the champion in times as well
differently, which most decks don't do
because that's how much variance is that
I've built in. And like I if the enemy
plays one card, it changes everything.
And I have to rethink about what I'm
hiding and how I'm doing this to make
sure that I don't mess up because if I
make a mistake, I've lost the game. I
need to like 100% lock in on this deck.
It's it's a very very high risk and I
and I have to make sure I I I don't mess
it up.
>> Yeah. You mentioned earlier maybe your
experience from other esports has
transferred in the into Riftbound here
especially in this highly competitive
environment. You're able to lock in as
you said and play under pressure and
also play for this really really long
day as well. I mean it's 10 p.m. here in
Australia. But thank you so much for
your Inside Ashen. We'll throw back to
our casters and see what else they have
to say.
What I have to say is show me the other
team deck games.
>> I'm fascinated.
>> I can't believe there's two different
team decks.
>> I I want to get my eyes on that. I'm
very very keen to see how that goes
tomorrow. But it has been a really
surprising day. I think it's safe to say
>> it has been. We've played I think a
little over 12 hours of Riftbound today.
Started at 10:00 a.m. local time. It's a
little past 1000 p.m. local time. I
don't know if the round is done. I
believe again it has to be closed if
it's not finished already. But we have
had some incredible matches of Rift
Crown and it's just the first day. We
have five more rounds of Swiss tomorrow,
three rounds of top eight and another
regional qualifier champion to crown. So
a lot on the line here. What are we
looking forward to tomorrow then? We saw
a lot of different things today. What
else do we want to see?
>> Yes, I mean look, a lot of diversity
today. We did see a lot of the unleashed
legends. I'm looking forward to seeing
them in tomorrow's matchups as well,
seeing how they go under a little bit
more pressure. And I'm I'm excited to
see more Vex to be honest. I It really
came out of nowhere for me, but I'm I'm
so excited to see more.
>> Well, we'll see what we have in store
for tomorrow. We are going to throw over
to the casters in the lounge to close
out our day.
>> Thank you so much, Pastry. Really
excited how this day has turned out. It
has been absolutely amazing. We've gone
through eight rounds, Logan. And I mean,
it's we're only halfway through. We've
got a whole day tomorrow as well.
>> It has absolutely been an exhausting day
here, Ricey. But I'm such a fan of
everything that we have seen. We've seen
some best ofs already awarded, but a
quick look at the standings here with
CTCG Daniel at the top with that
LeBlanc.
>> Yeah, Dan is at the top with that
Leblanc. We did think that LeBlanc was
going to be up there. We also see the
Ireelia Prismat as well, which was my
prediction, by the way. Pointed that
out, is up there with that Annie 80.
Interestingly, Ireelia, there are three
8 Z right now. And uh Diana is not 8 Z.
>> Yeah, and that's not surprising. I would
have to say like some of us predicted
that Diana, but right now with only one
in that sort of top 10 presented, it is
an interesting dynamic. A notable name
that's currently missing is Allen ZQ
here. We would love to see some more
representation of that Diana, but the
results are as they speak, Gaster Driver
actually also undefeated on that Aurelia
8 and zero. I still think she's so
strong. Uh we do I definitely want to
play now Ashton who we just saw on
broadcasts also top eight at the moment
and yeah very interested to see where
Allan is here. He is a name that we all
want to look out for. I do believe he
has dropped a game but let's have a look
at our talent predictions. Let's see how
we're doing with this Logan. I'm pretty
happy with my Annie so far. I mean
Prismat is still in that undefeated
zone. Unfortunately Diana not quite
there but pa with the Leblanc looking
pretty pretty.
>> He's up. Diana's up there. She's in the
top. You know, she's in the top 10.
She's competing with the best of them.
Me and Steph, we're still in with a
chance here. But pastry time absolutely
nailing it. That Leblanc prediction
proving very, very accurate right now.
Ricey.
>> Yeah, very accurate with that LeBlanc.
And maybe it's because he's been
attending lots of Nexus nights and
summer summoner skirmishes, which you
guys can attend as well. If you guys
attend your Nexus nights, you'll be able
to meet fellow Rift Crown enjoyers or
learn how to play the game. It's a fun
way to get into it.
>> Yeah, this is where the community
starts. This is where the community is
built at your local Nexus Knights. You
can scan that QR code and find an event
near you now. And then when you're
practicing, you're feeling comfortable
and confident with that deck, you can
step up to those summoner skirmishes
where the competition starts to ramp up.
>> Yeah. And that at those summoner
skirmishes, if you win, you do get that
buy into the regional qualifiers, which
is very important because today was such
a long date. They're already 10 p.m.
Eight rounds will turn into seven. And
as you can see the schedule here,
Saturday, eight rounds of Swiss starting
at 10:00 a.m. and well now it's
>> championship Sunday.
>> It's that's 12 hours. And tomorrow,
Championship Sunday.
>> Championship Sunday has five rounds of
Swiss with a top eight single limb.
Really, really exciting where we get to
see the best of the best compete for
that regional championship and that
Poppy exclusive and the $6,000 prize. A
lot of good prizes are on the line for
tomorrow. I mean, as you were saying,
top 60, top 128, get that plane mat. Top
64, get more prizes. I don't see the
prizing in front of me, but you go know
it. And we'll also love those 40 prize
world tickets as well, but that is going
to be tomorrow. It's going to be
starting at 10:00 a.m., so don't miss
it.
>> Don't miss it for the world. We have
more games of phenomenal Rift Band to
play here at the regional qualifier
Sydney 2026. I see.
>> Well, I'm ready for the for the
tomorrow. I hope I know you are as well.
I'm also ready to sleep as well. I'm
sure all our players are as well to to
come refreshed and ready for Sunday. So,
we'll see you guys all tomorrow for the
championship Sunday.
>> We'll see you there.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Heat. Heat.
Heat.